MEMBERS IF YOU ARE ON THE
SELECT COMMITTEE FOR POLICE
REFORMS PLEASE REPORT TO ROOM
TWO TO IS TEN OH ONE ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON POLICE REFORMS PLEASE REPORT
TO ROOM FORTY TWO- TOO SO WE
GET STARTED THANK YOU.
HE
STARTED. FIRST WE'RE GOING TO
GET READY TO GET STARTED THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON POLICE
REFORM- WEDNESDAY OCTOBER THE
FOURTEENTH IT'S APPROXIMATELY
TEN OH FOUR I HAVE A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING CHORES THAT I'M
ASKED TO READ SO PLEASE. BEAR
WITH ME. DUE TO THE CONTINUOUS
CONTINUOUS CONTINUATION OF A
STAY AT HOME ORDER WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO WE'RE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING ROOM IN PERSON. WE'RE
ALSO. ALSO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE-
PHYSICAL DISTANCING TO MAINTAIN
BY MEMBERS AS WELL AS MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. HERE IN THIS
ROOM WHETHER IN THIS ROOM OR BY
VIDEO CONFERENCING STE THE CARD
FOR THE SITE IF YOU DO NOT HAVE
A MASS ONE WILL BE PROVIDED FOR
YOU. SPECIFICALLY TO ROOM FORTY
TWO TO. BECAUSE OF THE LIMITED
AMOUNT OF THE LIMITATION OF
SPACE WE HAVE SOME COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHO WILL BE SEATED
SEATED ON THE AUDIENCE OF THIS
MAY NOT REALLY APPLY MEMBER
READ INTO THE RECORD. NEED TO
SPEAK- PLEASE GO BEHIND THE
PLEXIGLAS AND YOU'LL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH AGAIN
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO
PLEASE PROVIDE- PHYSICAL
DISTANCING DURING THIS TIME.
FOR THE PUBLIC ROOM WHEN WE
REACH THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION OF THE AGENDA I WOULD
ASK THAT EVERY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE ROOM PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE ONE
PERSON AT A TIME AND PLEASE
MAINTAIN SOCIAL DISTANCING AS
YOU MOVE AROUND IN THIS ROLES.
I WOULD ASK THAT THE PUBLIC NOT
TO TOUCH THE MICROPHONE SO THAT
INSTRUCTED NOW THE MEMBERS WHO
MAY BE SITTING IN THE FRONT ROW
IN THE AUDIENCE BUT ALSO THE
ARE THE PUBLIC ALSO PLEASE DO
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM AFTER
YOU FINISH TESTIFYING OR PLEASE
RETURN BACK TO YOUR SEATS
PLEASE AGAIN PROVIDE SOCIAL
DISTANCING SOCIAL DISTANCING
WILL BE ALSO IN THE CAPITAL
THROUGHOUT AND MEMBERS AND THE
PUBLIC ONE PERSON IN THE
ELEVATOR AT A TIME. IN ADDITION
TO BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM WE HAVE
SOME PANELISTS AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC MAKING
USE OF ONE OR POWER I WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOMS HERE
IN THE CAPITAL AND OR- ARE
REMOTE TESTIFYING STATIONS
LOCATED ON THE CAPITOL GROUNDS.
AND IN A FEW OTHER LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THOSE
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH THE
HEARING AND TESTIMONY AND ALSO
BE ABLE TO ASK QUESTIONS OF THE
PERSON TESTIFYING. FOR THE DIAL
IN WITNESSING WITNESSES WE WILL
ALSO BE USING A MODERATOR
TELEPHONE SERVICE FOR THE
PUBLIC COMMENTS. THE CALL IN
FOR THE HERE. PLEASE WRITE THIS.
IT IS. 877-692-8957 ONCE AGAIN.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR. TWO ZERO. TWO ONCE AGAIN
THE ACCESS CODE IS. THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO OH TWO. ONCE
AGAIN. THIRTEEN FIFTEEN FORTY
TWO OH TWO IS THE ACCESS CODE
AND YOU COULD ALSO FIND IT ON
THE ASSEMBLY WEBSITE OR ON YOUR
TV THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE
WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE
TO PROVIDE YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. IF YOU
ARE CALLING IN PLEASE LIEU.
LEMONADE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE.
THIS INCLUDES COMMUTING LIVE
STREAM BROADCASTS AND YOUR
SMART DEVICE TO REDUCE. SOUND
DISTORTION. WE MAY NEED TO
LIMIT HOW EACH PERSON HAS
PROVIDED DURING THE PUBLIC
COMMENT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYONE HAVE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK AT DEPENDING ON HOW
MUCH TIME WE HAVE WE MAY HAVE
TO ACTUALLY LIMITED TO TWO
MINUTES. PER INDIVIDUAL
SPEAKING SO THAT CONCLUDES WHAT
I NEED TO READ INTO THE RECORD
REGARDING THE- QUARANTINE THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING THAT WE HAVE.
NOW WE WANT TO GET READY TO GET
STARTED. SINCE WE HAVE A NUMBER
MEMBERS HRE ALREADY. THE
SELECT COMMITTEE HEARING. THIS
HEARING IS THAT INTRODUCTION
AND THE FIRST IN A SERIES. THAT
WILL BE. THEY'LL BE CONVENE TO
ADDRESS WAYS OF THE COMMUNITY
ADVOCATES LAW ENFORCEMENT THE
LEGAL COMMUNITY AND THE
LEGISLATURE. CAN WORK TOGETHER
TO PERFORM. LAW ENFORCEMENT
REFORM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE SELECT
COMMITTEE. WILL COMPREHENSIVELY
ADDRESS THE TOPICS OF POLICE
REFORM OVER THE COURSE OF THESE
HEARINGS FROM START TO FINISH.
WE HAVE BROUGHT TOGETHER A
DIVERSE COALITION OF
STAKEHOLDERS HISTORICALLY
ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN THIS
SPACE. WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM THROUGHOUT THESE
SERIES OF HEARINGS SO THAT
THEIR VOICES MAY BE HEARD AS
WELL AS MOVE. FORWARD WE INVITE
EVERYONE WE HAVE INVITED
EVERYONE. THAT WE COULD TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS SPACE
THROUGHOUT THE COMING MONTHS
THE COMMITTEE'S WORK WILL
CONSIST OF TOPICS BUT NOT
LIMITED TO. CIVIL RIGHTS UNDER
THE BANE ACT. AN EXAMINATION OF
DECERTIFICATION LEAST TRAINING
DEPARTMENT CULTURE DIVERSITY
WITHIN LAW ENFORCEMENT
SPECIFICALLY WITH REGARDS TO
HIRING. RETAINING OF WOMEN AND
MEN AND WOMEN OF COLOR. WHAT
DOES THE FINDING MEANS. I WANT
TO UNDERSCORE THAT THE FIRST
MEETING WILL SLOWLY ADDRESS THE
HISTORY OF POLICE REFORM
EFFORTS IN CALIFORNIA AND
NATIONALLY. THIS WILL ROUTE
WILL INFORM THE UNDERTAKING OF
CURRENT REFORM EFFORTS BY
BUILDING WHAT HAS HAPPENED AND
WHAT WORKED AND WHAT DIDN'T
WORK HOW DO WE KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE THIS IS WHY THE
SELECT COMMITTEE WAS FORMED AND
WHY WE ARE HERE TODAY I WANT TO
POSSIBLE MOMENT AND ALSO THANK
ARE AND EXTEND OUR GRATITUDE TO
OUR SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON. FOR
ALLOWING US TO HAVE SUCH A
HEARING AND THANK HIM FOR HIS
TREMENDOUS LEADERSHIP IN THIS
SPACE AND ITS COMMITMENT TO
REAL REFORM IN CALIFORNIA
AROUND THIS TOPIC. I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS WERE MAKING
THEMSELVES AVAILABLE AND TO ALL
OF THOSE WATCHING HERE TODAY
FOR THOSE IN THE AUDIENCE WE
WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS AT THE END
OF OUR HEARING DURING THE
DESIGNATED TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENTS. BEFORE WE BEGIN I
WANT TO RECOGNIZE MY COLLEAGUES
ON THE SELECT COMMITTEE AND
THANK THEM FOR JOINING ME AND
HOLDING HEARINGS OF THE OF
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE AROUND THIS
PARTICULAR TOPIC. NOW I WOULD
LIKE TO INVITE ARM MY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO JOIN ME BY OFFERING
A FEW WORDS OF REMARKS AND ALSO
SELF INTRODUCTION I'M GONNA
START WITH THE MEMBER ON THE
LEFT. WITH MISTER TOM LACKEY.
THANK YOU. I WANT TO. OKAY
MISTRUSTING AND- I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND THE SPEAKER FOR
ALLOWING US TOGETHER HERE AS A-
A GROUP OF LEGISLATORS YOU KNOW
THIS IS A VERY VERY SENSITIVE
TOPIC AND IT'S A VERY VERY
POWERFUL ONE AND I BELIEVE AT
THE VERY END OF SESSION IT WAS
ATTEMPTED TO BE PUSHED THROUGH
WITHOUT COLLABORATION AND SO I
THINK AT THE VERY LEAST WE ALL
NEED TO HAVE A CHANCE TO
INTERACT WITH EACH OTHER WE ALL
HAD DIFFERENT LIFE EXPERIENCES.
AND THOSE ARE VERY VALUABLE IN
THIS DISCUSSION I'VE BUT I DO
THINK WE OUGHT RELIABLE FAIR
INTERVENTION WITH THREATENING
OR VIOLENT BEHAVIOR RISES AND
WE NEED TO DO IT IN A WAY THAT-
WE ALL HAVE CONFIDENCE AND I
THINK THAT'S THE GOAL OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND I'M PROUD AND I
THANK THE SPEAKER FOR ALLOWING
ME TO BE PART OF THIS
DISCUSSION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS LACKING MISTER MASON.
YES COULD BE PART OF THIS-
SELECT WITH KNOW IS AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT IMPORTANT
ISSUE- I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
SPEAKER AS WELL- AND- AND CHAIR
GIPSON OF FOR PUTTING THIS ALL
TOGETHER WE ALL KNOW OFTENTIMES
THAT SELECT COMMITTEES ARE JUST
I USE THE TERM WINDOW DRESSING-
THIS COMMITTEE I KNOW IS NOT
GOING TO BE. A WINDOW DRESSING
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THIS
SERIOUSLY BECAUSE THIS IS A
SERIOUS- THIS SET OF ISSUES- I
THINK WE'LL DO IT IN A FAIR
FAIR WAY MY HOPE IS THAT
THEY'LL BE A REAL A DISCUSSION.
AND DEBATE I'M HERE AMONGST US
MEANT MEMBERS- IN THAT WE PUT
OUR PARTISANSHIP ASIDE BECAUSE
pTHIS IS THE PARTY SHOULD HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
DISCUSSION- IF THERE IS REFORM
THAT NEED IS NEEDED TO BE DONE
WE NEEDED TO TAKE IT SERIOUSLY
SO AGAIN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR- FOR THIS AND- LOOK FOR
DEBT TO WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS ROOM.
THANK YOU GIBSON ARE SOMETHING
GIPSON WILL ALL WANT TO THANK
US MEMBER GAY AND SPEAKER FOR
THE OP TO BE. AND I REALLY LOOK
AT ARE THE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US- WITH A REAL SENSE OF
RESPONSIBILITY AND A SENSE OF
URGENCY TO TAKE CARE OF WHAT WE
NEED TO TAKE CARE FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ALL OF MY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND COMING UP
WITH REAL SOLUTIONS TO BE ABLE
TO PRESENT. TO THE PUBLIC AND
AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES- THIS HAS
TO BE BIPARTISAN AND IT HAS TO
BE. SOMETHING THAT WE TAKE VERY
SERIOUS BECAUSE THIS IS. AN
URGENT MATTER BEFORE US AND WE
HAVE TO TAKE IT AS SERIOUS AS
POSSIBLE AND I'M HOPING TO BE
ABLE TO CONTRIBUTE POSITIVELY-
FOR ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS AND
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF
THE STAKEHOLDERS HAVE AND- A
VOICE IN THIS PROCESS I KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO COME
UP WITH A SET OF SOLUTIONS.
THAT WILL HELP- THE BUTTE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE PUBLIC.
MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OUR BK.
THANK YOU MISTER GIVES AND I
WANT TO START OFF BY RE ABOUT
COLLEAGUES AND ED AND THANK YOU
CONVENE IS HERE TODAY FOR THIS
VERY IMPORTANT IF YOU MEANT IS
ONLY THE- OF A CONVERSATION WE
NEED TO HAVE. AB MR LACKEY AND
I SAT IN THIS ROOM A LITTLE
OVER A YEAR AGO AND HEARD AB
THREE NINETY TWO STARTED EIGHT
IN THE MORNING AND WE SAT HERE
FOR HOURS UPON HOURS AS WE
LISTEN TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA COME INTO THIS ROOM
GROUP BY GROUP AND TESTIFY. THE
ABUSE OF FORCE THAT THEY HAD
EXPERIENCED AT THE HANDS OF OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND I KNOW FOR
ME IT WAS. A MOMENT I WILL
NEVER FORGET IN A MOMENT TO
CHECK ME AND THAT WAS AND WE
WENT ON TO PASS AB THREE NINETY
TWO DOCTOR MEMBERS INCREDIBLE
BILL THE STRONG AS USE OF FORCE
ON THE NATION HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BEFORE THIS SPRING
WHEN THE CONVERSATIONS REALLY
STARTED TO RISE TO A NEW LEVEL
AROUND WHAT IS RIGHT IN THIS
SPACE AND I AM GLAD THIS
CONVERSATION CONTINUES BECAUSE
THE WORK MUST CONTINUE. AND WE
HAD WE DID SOME INCREDIBLE WORK
AT THE END OF SESSION AND
SPEEDY TIME INCLUDING YOUR BILL
MISTER GIBSON WHICH BANS THE
CROWDED HOLD BUT THERE IS SO
MUCH MORE TO DO AND SO I'M GLAD
WE'RE HERE TOGETHER IN A
BIPARTISAN WAY SO WE CAN
CONTINUE THIS WORK AND DO WHAT
IS RIGHT FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AND IN THE FUTURE
LEGISLATURES WILL NOT HAVE TO
SIT. AND LISTEN TO PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA TESTIFIED TO THE
ABUSE OF FORCE AS THEY DID
BEFORE US. GONZALEZ AND THANK
YOU GERMAN GIPSON AND I WOULD I
THINK SPEAKER PLAYING ME TO THE
SOME SELECT COMMITTEE I YOU
KNOW IT'S OF INTEREST TO ME
THAT WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT THE
HISTORY OF POLICE REFORM. IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE ARGUABLY
THERE ISN'T MUCH OF A HISTORY
OF POLICE REFORM IN FAVOR OF
THE COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA IN
IN REALITY THAT'S WHY WE'RE
HERE- THAT'S WHY WE DEALT IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS WITH SOME
REALLY TOUGH ISSUES INCLUDING.
DOCTOR WEBER JEEZ FORCE BILL
INCLUDING- MISTER TEAMS ODY
BILL MEAN WE'VE WE'VE BEEN SO.
AB MISC. AT KNOW. TRANSPARENCY
BILL WE'VE BEEN STARTING TO AT
LEAST LOOK AT THESE ISSUES. BUT
IT DOESN'T COME QUICK ENOUGH
FOR COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE. AND
SO THE URGENCY OF THIS MATTER
IS ESSENTIAL AND I'M GLAD WE'RE
HERE AND IT IS IMPORTANT TO
BRING EVERYBODY TOGETHER. AND I
WAS DISAPPOINTED LAST YEAR. AT
WHAT I SAW ON JUDICIARY A BILL
ON ON PLEASE DECERTIFICATION
BUT I THINK WE CRITICALLY NEED
WE CRITICALLY HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT THE FACT. THAT THERE HAS
TO BE A WAY TO DECERTIFY BAD
COPS AND CLAPS THOUGHT SO TOO
THE UNIONS SAID THEY AGREED.
AND YET- WE COULDN'T GET TO A
PLACE ON THAT BILL. WHERE SOME
QUESTIONS WERE ANSWERED AND
SOME HOLES WERE WERE FILLED- I
HOPE FOR ABLE TO DO THAT
BECAUSE I THINK WE WILL HAVE
FAILED OUR RESPONSIBILITY IF WE
DON'T AT LEAST GET TO THAT
CRITICAL PIECE AND A CRITICAL
JUNCTURE OUT OF THIS- I LOOK
FORWARD TO TELL WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN AND I LOOK FOR TO
SUBMERGENCE THE FOR MY
COMMUNITIES AND OTHERS LIKE
THAT BUT HAVE BEEN.
UNFORTUNATELY WAITING FOR
POLICE REFORM I'M FOR VERY LONG
TIME AND IN NO WAY IS THAT. TO
JET TO SUGGEST I MEAN I CAME
OUT ORGANIZED LABOR OF COURSE I
I'VE WORKED WITH POLICE UNIONS
FOR VERY LONG TIME AND- I
UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEXITY OF
POPE ARE AND WHAT YOU KNOW. THE
RIGHTS OF WORKERS AS WELL BUT
THIS IS THE TIME TO STAND UP
FOR COMMUNITIES AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE. ACTUALLY GET SOME
THINGS DONE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MY- OKAY. YEAH YOU THANK
YOU TERM GIPSON FOR US AND ALSO
TO THANK OUR SPEAKER ANTHONY
RENDON FOR POINTING ME TO THIS
THIS IMPORTANT TIME WE SELECT
COMMITTEE- YOU KNOW I WILL
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS OF A LOT OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND CERTAINLY OUR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR LAST YEAR
ON. ON AB THREE NINETY- AND
LISTENING TO OTHER SUPPORT
PERSPECTIVES IN TESTIMONY OF
OUR COLLEAGUES INCLUDING MR
LACKEY AND ALSO- COLLEAGUES OF
OURS WHO- COME FROM COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR WHO HAD VERY DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCES WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT- WAS ONE OF THE
MOST PROFOUND AND MOVING.
MOMENTS THAT I'VE HAD IN MY
SHORT TIME IN THE LEGISLATURE-
I FOUND THAT TO BE A VERY VERY
MOVING DAY IN AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION AND THEN CERTAINLY
HAVE THAT FOLLOWED UP BY THE
EVENTS THAT WE WITNESSED- OVER
THE SUMMER WITH THAT WITH THE
BRUTAL KILLING OF GEORGE FLOYD
AND THIS PROFOUND NATIONAL
MOMENT THAT WE'VE HAD. ON OWN
RECKONING OF ISSUES AND RACE
AND JUSTICE THE CONCLUSION THAT
I REALLY CAME TO AND I THINK A
LOT OF FOLKS IN MY COMMUNITY
CAME TO IS THAT THERE'S SYSTEM
SYSTEMIC CHANGES NEEDED IN THIS
COUNTRY ON ISSUES OF RACE AND
JUSTICE-AND NOT CERTAINLY GOES
ACROSS THE HALL IS- A RANGE OF
ISSUES FROM FROM EDUCATION TO
HEALTH CARE TO OPPORTUNITIES TO
ALL OF THESE. DIFFERENT ISSUE
THAT WE EXAMINE THE LEGISLATURE
BUT POLICING IS CERTAINLY A
CRITICAL PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION AND I THINK THAT
THERE REALLY IS A DEMAND. FOR
CHANGING FOR CONVERSATION
AROUND THIS AND SO I AM LOOKING
FORWARD TO THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE VERY MUCH I THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE AN IMPORTANT
ONE I'M LOOKING FOR TO
LISTENING AND LEARNING- HEARING
FOR THE PERSPECTIVES OF THESE
PERCENT PRESENTERS AND THEN
HOPEFULLY MOVING FORWARD AS AS
OUR OUR COLLEAGUE SAID WITH A
SENSE OF URGENCY AND I THINK
THAT THIS IS WORK THAT THE
PEOPLE DEMAND. THAT THE PEOPLE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO MAN
AND I THINK THAT THERE ARE WAYS
THAT WE CAN APPROACH THIS WITH
NUANCE WITH- WITH CLARITY AND
UNDERSTANDING THE VARIOUS
ISSUES APPLY- AND HOPEFULLY
MOVE FORWARD IN A WAY WE CAN
GET IT RIGHT BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
GET IT RIGHT I THINK THAT'S
WHAT THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
ARE DEMANDING OF US AND SO- THE
CERTAINLY A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
IN THE COMING IN THE COMING
SESSION BUT I'M VERY CONFIDENT-
IN THE GROUP OF COLLEAGUES THAT
THAT. YOU ON THE SPEAKER HAVE
ASSEMBLED HERE MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND REALLY LOOKING FOR TO IT TO
BE PART OF THIS COME. SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TO WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR CONVENING.
THIS SUCH AN IMPORTANT- SELECT
COMMITTEE AND I THANK ALSO THE
SPEAKER FOR RECOGNIZING THE
URGENCY OF HAVING. SUCH A
COMMITTEE FORMED TO DISCUSS
THIS EVEN BEFORE WE START
SESSION IT'S ALREADY BEEN
MENTIONED WE'RE GOING TO LOOK
AT THE HISTORY AND- WE'VE GOT A
LONG WAY TO GO BUT WE'VE DONE
SOME THINGS WE REALLY HAVE. AND
WE HAVE MEMBERS OF OUR OUR OUR
BODY WHO HAVE. RESENTED THESE
THE URGENCY OF THE CHANGES THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN NEEDED. OF THE
BEST EXAMPLE THAT WE'VE ALREADY
TALKED ABOUT IS- DR WEBER'S AB
THREE THREE NINETY TWO- BUT WE
ALSO. YOUR YOUR BILL ON
CHOKEHOLDS MISTER GIBSON. AND
ALSO THE AG'S INVESTIGATION OF
POLICE INVOLVED SHOOTINGS- IN
THE WATCHDOG PANELS THE USE OF
ALL BEEN DISCUSSED AND I THINK
THESE ARE ALL. GOOD BEGINNING
POINTS. WE HAVE DONE A LOT BUT
THERE IS SO MUCH LEFT TO DO- I
KNOW THAT WE'RE NOT ALL GOING
TO AGREE ON THE SOLUTIONS. BUT
BEFORE WE HAVE A PER PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATION WE HAVE TO AGREE
THAT THE PROBLEM EXISTS. TO
THOSE WHO WANT TO SEE REFORM OF
POLICING THE STATE AND NATION I
HEAR YOU WE HEAR YOU. TO THOSE.
FAMILIES WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED
THE PAIN OF THE LOSS FROM THE
INTERACTIONS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE HEAR YOU ALSO.
WE WILL HEAR YOU WITH KNOWLEDGE
THE PAIN THAT YOU BOOK THAT YOU
HAVE EXPERIENCED. TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT
RESOURCES AND TRAINING NEEDED
TO DO YOUR JOB AND TO PROTECT
AND SERVE THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE. THERE ALSO ARE CONCERNS
AND WE HEAR YOU. IN ADDITION TO
THE POTENTIAL REFORMS. RELATED
TO THE PROCESS OF POLICING I
HOPE THAT THROUGH THE SERIES OF
HEARINGS THAT WILL OCCUR THAT
WE WILL LOOK AT WAYS THAT WE
CAN INVEST IN EARLIER SYSTEMS
INVEST IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
OUR YOUTH SO THAT WE CAN TURN
THIS TIDE AROUND. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISERY AS- MISTER
CUNNINGHAM YOU'RE UP TO BAT FOR
COMMENTS IN YOUR INTRODUCTION
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US. THANK
YOU CHAIR FOR HOSTING US TODAY.
SO IMPORTANT ISSUE WE GOT A LOT
OF DIFFICULT THINGS. FLUSH OUT
I'M INTERESTED TO HEAR THE
TESTIMONY. OF I THINK WE'RE ALL
WORKING TOWARDS THE SAME THING.
AND I'D LIKE TO HEAR IDEAS FOR
HOW WE CAN EMPHASIZE- TRAINING
GET MORE TRAINING. I THINK WE
CAN ACKNOWLEDGE THERE BEEN SOME
TREMENDOUS INJUSTICES DONE.
WHICH SADDENS ME I DO BELIEVE
THAT MOST OFFICERS THEY'RE
SWORN A DIFFICULT JOB WITH
INTEGRITY. I DO BELIEVE THAT.
THEY DESERVE OUR SUPPORT AND
THEY DESERVE OUR HELP IN TERMS
OF TRAINING. I COULD WAXON FOR
A LONG TIME BUT JUST THINGS
THAT HAPPEN IN MY- DISTRICT
RECENTLY. YEAH WE HAD AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER MY HOMETOWN TWO MONTHS
AGO. I HAVE PERSONAL FRIENDS
THAT RESPONDED TO THAT ONE OF
HIM TOOK A BULLET THROUGH THE
LAKE. FORTUNATE THAT HE
SURVIVED I JUST LIKE TO MAKE
SURE THAT AS WE. WORK THROUGH
THESE DIFFICULT ISSUES RIGHT
TRY TO CHART A PATH FORWARD
THAT'S THE TITLE OF OUR HEARING
A SUGGEST THAT WERE. ETHNOLOGY
THAT. YOU PLEASE WORK IS
DIFFICULT AND WE EXPECT A LOT
OF THEM WITH IT'S FIRST TO ILL
PERSON WHETHER RESPONDING TO
SOMEBODY THAT'S VIOLENT OR
DANGEROUS. AND THEY THEY
DESERVE OUR SUPPORT IN THAT
EFFORT. AND WE SHOULD BE
MINDFUL THAT AS WE WORK THROUGH
THESE ISSUES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE- AND THEN OFFER HIM
AN OPPORTUNITY- MISTER LOWE TO
GIVE SOME BRIEF COMMENTS INTO
SOME SO THANKS FOR JOINING US
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR JACKO
THE COMMENTS WITH RESPECT TO
ENSURING THAT WE ARE NOT.
GATHER JUST FOR WINDOW DRESSING
BUT RATHER WE ARE A
COLLABORATIVE IN NATURE AND
THAT WE'RE VERY INTENTIONAL.
SURGICAL AND REPRESENTING THE
DIVERSITY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH THE RESPECTIVE
EXPERIENCES GEOGRAPHY. AND LOOK
FOR THE COLLABORATION AT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I THINK THAT
CONCLUDES ALL THE MEMBERS WE
ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE WHO ARE
NOT WITH US BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT OF THE PEOPLE IN
THE AUDIENCE AND THOSE WERE
VIEWING NO OTHER ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE STATE ASSEMBLY
AS PART OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON- PLEASE OFFICE REFORM WE
ALSO HAVE MISTER JAMES RAMOS
WHO'S PART OF THIS COMMITTEE
WHO COULDN'T BE WITH US
PHYSICALLY WE ALSO HAVE DR
SHIRLEY WEBER. WE ALSO HAVE
MISTER ROB BONTA- CITY COM
LACQUERED DIALS. WE ALSO HAVE
KEVIN MCCARTY. AND ALSO WE HAVE
ROUTE MR RUDY SALAS SO THOSE
ARE ALL MEMBERS WHO WILL BE
JOINING US. THROUGH A SERIES OF
DISCUSSIONS AROUND POLICE
OFFICER REFORM- AND WHAT HAS
BEEN STATED IS THAT THIS IS A
VERY DIVERSE GROUP I WANT TO
ALSO ANNOUNCED THAT MR CHAD
MAYES WILL SERVE AS THE VICE
CHAIR. OF THIS A SELECT
COMMITTEE AS WE THANK HIM FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP IN THE WORK THAT
HE'S- AND ALL OF US. ARE
GETTING READY TO EMBARK UPON
WHAT HAS ALREADY BEEN SAID WE
WANT TO GIVE. KUDOS TO OURS OUR
SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON. FOUR
ONE- EXERCISING WISDOM
EXPEDITIOUSLY- EVEN THOUGH WE
ARE RECESSED- HE WANTS TO MAKE
SURE THE CONVERSATIONS-
IMPORTANT CONVERSATIONS TAKES
PLACE IN THE SPACE AROUND.
POLICE OFFICER REFORM AND I
THINK THAT HE HAS ASSEMBLED-
VERY- DIVERSE ARRAY OF
INDIVIDUALS AND CAN COLLEAGUES
FROM THE STATE ASSEMBLY TO HAVE.
THIS IN A VERY IMPORTANT
DIALOGUE. AND CERTAINLY I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO ONE- NOT DO
RENT WINDOW DRESSING BUT
CERTAINLY LOOK FOR TO TACKLING
THE ISSUES HEAD ON. AND I WANT
ALSO UNDERSCORE THIS. WE CAN
ALL DISAGREE WITHOUT BEING
DISAGREEABLE. WE WILL HAVE-
DISCUSSIONS THAT WILL BE HEATED
AND- THROUGHOUT THE THIS AND
THE SERIES OF MEETINGS- BUT
THIS IS THE PLACE WE HAVE IT.
WE WILL INVITE THE COMMUNITY TO
ALSO ENGAGE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. AND SO WITH THAT I WANT
TO SAY MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LESS ROLL UP. OUR SLEEVES
AND LET'S GET BUSY. AT THIS
POINT WE WILL TO BEFORE WE
BEGIN WITH PANEL DISCUSS WE
WILL HEAR TO- PRESENTATIONS ON
THE HISTORY OF POLICE REFORM.
EACH PRESENTER WILL HAVE UP TO
TWELVE MINUTES UP TO TWELVE
MINUTES UP TO TWELVE MINUTES TO
SPEAK- AND PROVIDE. OF THEIR
PRESENTATION IN THE ORDER ON
THE AGENDA. BEFORE THEY PRESENT
THEMSELVES THEY WILL ALSO HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO SELF
INTRODUCED. SO WITH THAT BEING
SAID. THE FIRST A PRESENTER IS
DR PETER HART THINK IN PLEASE%
FORGIVE ME IF I MISPRONOUNCE
YOUR NAME WE HOPE THAT YOU WILL
CERTAINLY CORRECT IN YOUR
INTRODUCTION. WHO WILL BE
PARTICIPATING VIRTUALLY. AND SO
WE WELCOME YOU AND YOU CAN
BEGIN. YOUR COMMENTS. YOUR
COMMENTS. HELLO MY NAME IS
PETER HANNAH I AM RESIDENT OF
THE CITY OF LONG BEACH. AND A
NATIVE OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
I'M A PROFESSOR OF SOCIOLOGY
AND CRIMINOLOGY AT CAL POLY
POMONA. I FOCUS ON POLICING- MY
RESEARCH FOCUSES ON POLICE
CITIZEN INTERACTIONS RACE AND
POLICE USE OF FORCE. WHEN YOU
LOOK BACK AT THE LAST FEW
DECADES OF POLICE REFORM IN
UNITED STATES IN CALIFORNIA. WE
MIGHT BE TEMPTED TO CONCLUDE.
BUT NOTHING WORKS. AFTER ALL
EVERY SINGLE CYCLE OF POLICE
REFORM SEEMS TO FOLLOW A
SIMILAR PATTERN. WE GET SOME
KIND OF CRISIS EVENT THAT
OCCURS WITH CALLS FOR REFORM.
WE GET A CALL HOME AFTER THOSE
REFORMS AND THEN THERE'S
ANOTHER CRISIS EVENT. AND WE
FIND OURSELVES NOW IN A SIMILAR
MOMENT. ARE THE VOICES WHO SAY
THAT NOTHING WORKS RIGHT I
DON'T THINK SO I DON'T THINK
THAT WE NEED TO BE PESSIMISTIC
ABOUT THAT. ARE WE DOOMED TO
KEEP REPEATING THE SAME CYCLE
OF CRISIS REFORM PALM NEW
CRISIS. I DON'T THINK SO BUT I
THINK IT IF WE'RE GOING TO GET
OUT OF THIS PATTERN. WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON. AND
IF YOU LOOK CLOSELY. I THINK
IT'S CUTE BUT WE'RE NOT
ACTUALLY DOING THE SAME THING
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
RATHER THE PATTERN THAT WE SEE
IS MORE LIKE THE SWINGING OF
THE PENDULUM. WHERE WE MOVE
FROM ONE SIDE TO ANOTHER. AND
SO IF WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN THIS
PATH FORWARD TOWARDS POLICE
REFORM I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO LOOK BACK. AND WHEN WE LOOK
BACK A TO MAKE SENSE OF THE
COMPLICATED HISTORY OF POLICE
REFORM I WANT TO FOCUS ON THREE
AREAS. WHICH I'M GONNA CALL
DISCRETION. DISTANCE AND DATA.
FIRST REGARDING DISCRETION AT
THE MOST BASIC LEVEL DISCRETION
IN THE CONTEXT OF POLICING JUST
REFERS TO THE AMOUNT OF TRUST
THAT WE GIVE TO POLICE OFFICERS
TO MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS THE
TENSION THIS PENDULUM SWING
THAT I DESCRIBE WITHIN
DISCRETION ARE THE IMPOSITION
OF STRICT RULES. VERSUS TOTAL
DEFERENCE TO POLICE OFFICER
JUDGMENT. AND WE SEEM TO SWING
BETWEEN THESE TWO EXTREMES.
BETWEEN ANY APPLICATION OF
STRICT RULES WHICH GIVE ZERO
DISCRETION. TWO MORE DEFERENCE
WHICH GIVES MAYBE TOO MUCH
DISCRETION. AND IN THIS TENSION
BETWEEN THOSE ARE THE EXAMPLE I
LIKE TO USE MY STUDENTS WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT DISCRETION IS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A FRY COOK
AND A BRAIN SURGEON. WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE JOB OF A FRY COOK
WHAT DO THEY DO WELL IF YOU'RE
WORKING AT MCDONALD'S OR BURGER
KING YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO CUT THE
FRIES A PARTICULAR WITH. YOU
PUT IT IN THE FRYER FOR A
PARTICULAR NUMBER OF SECONDS
AND THEN YOU'VE GOT YOUR DONE
YOU DO THREE SHAKES OF SALT AND
THEN THAT'S IT. OBVIOUSLY THAT
KIND OF STRICT RULE BASED
PROCESS. IS INAPPROPRIATE
WITHIN THE- WITHIN A CONTEXT.
AS DIFFICULT AND DYNAMIC AS
POLICING. FORMER LA POLICE LAPD
POLICE CHIEF CHARLIE BECK WAS
FOND OF SAYING IF WE WANTED TO
DO TOMORROW WE COULD END A
DRIVERS DISTRACTED WITH CELL
PHONES IN THE CAR. THE PROBLEM
IS WITH THAT'S THE ONLY THING
WE WOULD BE DOING. IF WE WANTED
TO EVERY SINGLE TIME A POLICE
OFFICER SEES SOMEONE ON THE
PHONE IN THE CAR THEY COULD
PULL THEM OVER BUT THEN THEY
WOULDN'T BE PULLING OVER THE
DRUNK DRIVERS WOULD BE PULLING
OVER THE PEOPLE SPEEDING. WOULD
BE PULLING OVER THE PEOPLE WHO
MAYBE WE ARE ACTUALLY MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT. ULTIMATELY SO
MUCH OF POLICING IS ABOUT
MAKING DECISIONS WERE GIVEN A
NARROW RANGE OF OPTIONS AND
DISCRETION. IS HOW POLICE
OFFICERS MAKE THOSE DECISIONS.
AND IF WE CONSTRAIN DIRECTION
TOO MUCH. THEN WE RISK A BAD
OUTCOMES. AT THE SAME TIME WHEN
WE SEE THESE ABUSES WHEN WE SEE
THESE CASES OF CRISES OF TRUST
AND LEGITIMACY. OUR NATURAL
INCLINATIONS TO SWING TO THE
OTHER EXTREME IN TO SAY OKAY
WHAT WE NEED TO IMPOSE.
BOUNDARIES ON POLICE DISCRETION
BUT UNFORTUNATE THE WAY WE TEND
TO DO THAT. IS WELL I'M A
LAWYER AND MANY OF YOU MIGHT BE
LAWYERS TO WE ACT LIKE LAWYERS.
THAT WE IMPOSE REASON THE BILL
OF THE TESTS. AND WE SAY WHAT
WHAT A REASONABLE OFFICER TO
WHAT'S A REASONABLE USE OF FOR
USE OF FORCE. AND UNFORTUNATELY
A AS WE ALL KNOW. SO FEW OF OUR
POLICE OFFICERS ARE LAWYERS.
AND IF WAY THAT WE'RE ATTEMPT.
TO IMPOSE THIS. IF THE WAY
THEIR ATTEMPTING TO LIMIT
DISCRETION. IS TO ASK POLICE
OFFICERS TO BECOME
CONSTITUTIONAL LAWYERS. TO DO
THE THINGS THAT THE SUPREME
COURT ITSELF IS RELUCTANT TO DO
WHERE ENGRAM VERSUS CONNOR IT
SAYS THAT POLICE USE OF FORCE
MUST BE REASONABLE. WELL WHAT'S
REASONABLE MEANS. WHO IS THE
REASONABLE MAN WHO IS THE
POLICE OFFICER WAS A REASONABLE
POLICE OFFICER THESE ARE REALLY
TOUGH QUESTIONS. AND IS THAT
THE WAY THAT WE IMPOSE
DISCRETION. WE WILL WE SO IN
THIS TENSION BETWEEN THESE TWO
EXTREMES WE RISK LEARNING THE
WRONG LESSON IT'S NOT THE
DISCRETION IS BAD DISCRETION IS
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL IT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART OF POLICING BUT
THERE HAVE TO BE LIMITS. THE
NEXT AREA IS DISTANCE. SO MUCH
OF THE TIME THE TENSION WHEN IT
COMES TO DISTANCE IS HOW CLOSE
SHOULD THE POLICE BE TO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY'RE
POLICING. THE LESSON THAT WE
TOOK AWAY FROM THE EVENTS OF
THE NINETEEN NINETIES. REMOVE
THE FROM RODNEY KING AND THE EN
LA NINETY TWO SO MUCH OF THAT
WOULD THE TAKEAWAY WAS THAT
POLICE WERE OUTSIDERS AND WE
NEED TO REBUILD TRUST AND THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE POLICE
AND THE COMMUNITIES THAT
THEY'RE POLICING. AND SO THE
PENDULUM SWINGS CLOSER TO BEING
CLOSER TO THAT COMMUNITY. AND
THE WAY THIS WAS SO OFTEN DONE
WAS THROUGH COMMUNITY POLICING.
NOT COMMITTEE PLACE IS A FUNNY
THING IF YOU IF YOU ASK A TEN
POLICE DEPARTMENTS- NINE OF
THEM WILL SAY THEY DO COMMUNITY
POLICING IT WILL GIVE YOU A
LEVIN DIFFERENT DEFINITIONS OF
WHAT IT MEANS. CAN BE POLICING
IS VAGUE ENOUGH FOR EVERYONE'S
IN FAVOR OF IT BUT NO ONE CAN
REALLY TELL YOU WHAT IT MEANS.
WELL WHEN WE LOOK AT WHAT
COMPLETE COMMITTEE PLACING CAN
OFTEN BE A BABY IS WHEN IT'S AT
ITS BEST. IS INSTEAD OF TOP
DOWN IMPOSITION INSTEAD OF
POLICE DEPARTMENTS SAYING THIS
IS WHAT WE'RE DOING AND THESE
ARE THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT. IT'S REACHING
OUT TO THE COMMUNITY IN
DIALOGUE IN CONVERSATIONS AND
YOU TELL US. WHAT ARE THE AREAS
OF CONCERN YOU TELL US WHAT ARE
THE THINGS THAT MAKE YOU FEEL
UNSAFE YOU TELL US WHAT WE CAN
DO TO REBUILD THAT TRUST. AND
ESSENTIAL PART OF THAT WOULD BE
THINGS LIKE COMMUNITY MEETINGS.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENS FAR TOO OFTEN
IN THOSE COMMITTEE MEETINGS.
WHAT THEY DEVOLVE INTO. IS
COMPLAINT SESSIONS WHERE THE
MEMBERS THE COMMUNITY COMPLAIN
TO THE POLICE OFFICER THE
POLICE. OFFICER STOICALLY TAKES
THAT ABUSE AND WALKS OUT AND
THE QUESTION IS WELL WHAT'S
GETTING DONE. WHAT'S COMING
FROM THAT. IT'S JUST A VENTING
SESSION THEN THAT'S NOT
ACTUALLY REPAIRING THE
RELATIONSHIP IT IS JUST A
VENTING SESSION WHERE NOT
THERE'S NO CONCRETE PROGRESS
AND THAT DOESN'T REBUILD TRUST
TO THE DOESN'T REBUILD
COMMUNITY. AND IN FACT- PERHAPS
MORE DANGEROUSLY. WHAT THE
CONCERNS RECENTLY HAVE BECOME.
IS THAT WHEN IT COMES TO THESE
COMMITTEE COMES COMMITTEE
POLICING INSTEAD OF IT BEING
THE COMMUNITY TELLING POLICE
DIRECTING OF POLICE AS TO WHAT
OUR INTERESTS ARE WHAT WHAT
ISSUES ARE OF INTEREST TO THE
COMMUNITY. TOO OFTEN BECOMES A
CHECK ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY FOR
INTELLIGENCE GATHERING. WHERE
INSTEAD THEIR POLICE OFFICERS
IN THE POLICE DEPARTMENTS ARE
USING THE COMMITTEE MEETINGS TO
GATHER INFORMATION TO GATHER
INTELLIGENCE. BUT NOT BUT IT'S
NOT A TWO WAY STREET. ONCE
AGAIN WE RISK LEARNING THE
WRONG LESSON. CLOSENESS CAN BE
GOOD CLOSENESS CAN BE IMPORTANT
WHEN IT TAKES IN IT ESSENTIAL
FOR LEGITIMACY AND TRUST. BUT
WHEN POLICE USE THAT CLOSENESS.
AND PUT IN AND AGAIN THE
CONCERN HERE IS NOT NECESSARILY
EVEN WHAT'S ACTUALLY OCCURRING
BUT WHAT WHAT COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ARE PERCEIVING. IF COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PERCEIVE BUT THE ONLY
THING THESE MEETINGS ARE BEING
USED FOR IS FOR POLICE OFFICERS.
TO GATHER INTELLIGENCE TO MAKE
ARRESTS. AS OPPOSED TO
LISTENING TO LISTENING TO
COMPLAINTS AND LISTENING TO
ISSUES THEN YOU RESTORE ROADING
THAT TRUST IN A ROADING THAT
LEGITIMACY. FINALLY DATA. ONE
OF THE GREAT REVOLUTIONS OF
POLICING IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES WAS THE USE OF STE
SOPHISTICATED STATISTICAL DATA
WAS THE RECOGNITION. THAT
INSTEAD OF GOING TO BLINDLY
GOING OUT FOR A WAITING FOR
RADIO THANK PLEASED MORE TO AND
MORE PROACTIVE IN THEIR
POLICING THAT'S THE LESSON THAT
WE LEARNED AND COMPSTAT IN NEW
YORK AND SERRA IN SAN DIEGO AND
POLICE DEPARTMENTS AROUND THE
COUNTRY. BUT THE CONCERN AGAIN
SO OFTEN IS WHAT IS THE DATA
USED FOR. IF THAT DATA WE SAY
OKAY WHERE WE CAN SEND THE
POLICE WERE GONNA SEND THE
WHERE THE HOT SPOTS ARE WELL
HOW DO YOU KNOW WHERE THE HOT
SPOTS ARE WHERE THE DATA TELLS
US THE HOT SPOTS ARE. HOW DO
YOU KNOW HOW DOES THE DATA WITH
THE HOT SPOTS ARE WELL THAT'S
WERE MADE ARRESTS. WOULD YOU
RISK DOING IS LAUNDERING IN.
THE SAME KIND OF BIASES. AND
THE SAME KINDS OF PATTERNS. OF
DISCRIMINATORY POLICING THAT
MIGHT HAVE EXISTED BEFORE. IN
FACT IT'S ENTIRELY POSSIBLE.
THAT YOU HAVE. EVERYONE IN A
POLICE DEPARTMENT WITH THE BEST
OF INTENTIONS. LOOKING AND
SAYING WELL I'M JUST DOING WHAT
THE DATE IS TELLING ME TO DO.
NOT REALIZING THAT WHAT HAD
GOTTEN BAKED INTO THAT WOULD
GOTTEN BAKED INTO THE DATA
ANALYSIS. WITH THE SAME
PATTERNS OF THAT WE SAW IN THE
BATTLE DAYS. AT THE SAME TIME
THE RESPONSE TO THAT CAN'T BE
WILL GET RID OF DATA. IT IS
UNFORTUNATELY SI VAT HAPPENING
AS WELL. THAT WAS A SCANDAL IN
THE NEW YORK NEW YORK POLICE
DEPARTMENT A FEW YEARS AGO WITH
ADRIAN SCHOOLCRAFT WITH THIS
CONCERN ABOUT MANIPULATING THE
DATA IN ORDER TO MAKE CRIME
STATISTICS LOOK BETTER THAN
THEY WERE. FOR AND THAT'S THE
CONCERN WE ALSO SEE WITH THE
FACT THAT NONE OF US NONE OF US
CAN ACTUALLY GIVE YOU A GOOD
NUMBER AS TO HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE KILLED BY THE POLICE EVERY
YEAR IN THE UNITED STATES. WE
HAVE ESTIMATES. BUT NONE OF US
ACTUALLY KNOW WHY BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE THE DATA SHOULDN'T
WE HAVE THE DATA FOR THAT.
THERE ARE SOME THINGS OUR DATA
IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL FOR AND
THE SOLUTION CAN'T BE TOO TO
IGNORE THE DATA. WE NEED MORE
DATA DATA IS ACTUALLY ONE OF
THESE REFORMS THAT IS CAPACITY
BUILDING. BECAUSE BY GETTING
GOOD DATA WHAT WE CAN DO. IS
MAKE BETTER REFORMS THE FUTURE
BECAUSE WE CAN INFORM WHAT
THOSE REFORM SHOULD ACTUALLY BE
YOU WANT TO KNOW IF THERE'S A
PATTERN OF RACIAL PROFILING YOU
WANT TO KNOW IF THERE'S
ACTUALLY A PATTERN. OF DRIVING
WHILE BLACK. WHEN YOU NEED THE
DATA TO PROVE THAT. AND IF YOU
DON'T HAVE GOOD DATA ON WHAT.
WHO YOU'RE STOPPING WHY YOU'RE
STOPPING THEM WHAT HAVE ONCE
YOU STOP THEM IS AN ARREST MADE
WHAT WAS THE BASIS FOR THE
ARREST WHAT HAPPENS LONG TERM.
WHAT WAS THE CONTEXT OF THE
ARREST ALL OF THAT INFORMATION
IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL
CALIFORNIA HAS DONE GREAT WORK
IN RECENT YEARS IN GETTING MORE
DATA. BUT THE SOLUTION HAS TO
BE TO KEEP GOING. BECAUSE WE
DON'T MAKE PROGRESS IF WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING. SO
DEPENDENT TO WRAP UP BUT WHAT
I'D SAY IS A I'M TEACHING A
CLASS RIGHT NOW ON THE HISTORY
OF AFTER THE HISTORY OF
POLICING WE JUST WRAPPED UP
TALKING WITH THE KERNER
COMMISSION AND RIGHT NOW WE'RE
TALKING WITH THE CHRISTOPHER
COMMISSION. A FEW WEEKS FROM
NOW WE'LL TALK ABOUT THE
FERGUSON REPORT. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT MY STUDENTS SAID TO
ME AFTER WE FINISH THE KERNER
COMMISSION IS. THIS ALL SOUNDS
SO RELEVANT. THIS ALL SOUNDS
LIKE IT COULD BE HAPPENING NOW.
AND I THINK THAT CAN BE A CAUSE
FOR PESSIMISM. IT CAN BE A
CAUSE FOR PESSIMISM TO SAY
HAVEN'T WE LEARNED THE LESSONS
FROM FIFTY YEARS AGO WE'RE
LOOKING BACK AT CHRISTOPHER
HAVEN'T WE LEARNED THE LESSONS
FROM THIRTY YEARS AGO. AND THE
KEY IS TO LEARN THE RIGHT
LESSONS. AND THAT'S WHAT'S
IMPORTANT WE LOOK AT HISTORY.
IS NOT TO SWING JUST FROM ONE
SIDE OF THE PENDULUM TO THE
OTHER. BUT RATHER TO FIGURE OUT
EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING ON. AND
WHAT REFORMS ARE THE MOST
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THAT FROM THE ACADEMIC
PERSPECTIVE THE HISTORY OF
POLICE REFORM EFFORTS NEXT UP
OUR SECOND PRESENTER WILL BE
OUR REEF CON PLEASE- CERTAIN
CORRECT ME ON YOUR FIRST YOUR
LAST NAME- YOU HAVE UP. TO
TWELVE MINUTES TO PRESENT. WE
WILL ALSO A MA'AM IN ME AFTER
THEIR THIS PANEL WILL OPEN A
MEMBER QUESTIONS AND ANSWER OF
THOSE WHO PRESENTED SO WITH
THAT. THIS CHANGE IN A
MICROPHONE. FOR AND PLEASE
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OFTHE COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY- TO SPEAK
TO YOU ABOUT THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE THAT AFFECTS ALL
CALIFORNIANS-IN A VERY
PROFOUND WAY MY NAME IS ARIF
ALI KHAN I AM THE FORMER
DIRECTOR OF CONSTITUTIONAL
POLICING IN POLICY OF THE LOS
ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT AND
ALSO A FORMER DEPUTY MAYOR OF
PUBLIC SAFETY AND HOMELAND
SECURITY. I COME TO YOU TODAY
TO SPEAK TO YOU BASED ON MY
EXPERIENCE OF TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AS A FEDERAL PROSECUTOR AS A
POLICY ADVISER AND DEVELOPER
BOTH AT THE FEDERAL AND LOCAL
LEVEL AS A POLICE EXECUTIVE AS
THE DIRECTOR OF AIRPORT POLICE
LA ACTS WITH ITS FIVE HUNDRED
SWORN AND SEVEN HUNDRED
CIVILIAN OFFICERS. AND AS A
POLICE EXACTLY WITH THE LAPD AS
ITS DIRECTOR CONSTITUTIONAL
POLICING AND POLICY- I ALSO
CURRENTLY ADVISE AND CONSULT
LARGE AND SMALL POLICE
DEPARTMENTS ON ISSUES REGARDING
CONSTITUTIONAL POLICING POLICY
DEVELOPMENT AND LEADERSHIP IN
PUBLIC SAFETY. WE HEARD TODAY-
FROM DOCTOR HANNAH BECAUSE
ACTUAL PRESENTATION ON THE
THREE THINGS THAT HE SEES AND
GREENS FROM HISTORY THERE ARE
SO IMPORTANT TO THIS ISSUE OF
POLICE REFORM AND I'M GOING TO
BUILD ON THAT BY ARE ALSO
LOOKING AT THE PRACTICALITIES
OF POLICE REFORM. IN CALIFORNIA
TODAY BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE
AND WHAT I SEE- BUT I THINK
WHAT'S RIGHT AND WHAT'S
IMPORTANT LOOK AT THIS RIGHT
NOW IS THERE'S OFTEN TO TALK
ABOUT REIMAGINING POLICING BUT
IN MANY WAYS I THINK WE HAVE TO
IMAGINE POLICING IN THE WAY
THAT BOTH HISTORY AND COMMUNITY
HAS EXPECTATIONS. THERE ARE
MANY THINGS THAT PROFESSOR
HANNAH COULD MENTION ABOUT
DISCRETION DISTANCE AND DATA
THAT EVEN TALKED ABOUT FOR MANY
MANY YEARS. BUT THE ONE THEME
THAT YOU WILL SEE IN MOST.
HISTORY OF. AND REFORM IS THE
IDEA OF HAVING A PROFESSIONAL
WORK FORCE AND PROFESSIONALISM.
IN POLICING. BOTH ON THE
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL ON THE AGENCY
AN INSTITUTIONAL LEVEL AND
CERTAINLY ON THE REGULATORY AND
STATUTORY FRAMEWORK. THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR.
THE PUBLIC EXPECTS AND DESERVES
PROFESSIONAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY OFTENTIMES
THE STANDARDS THE STRUCTURES
AND ALL TOO OFTEN THE BEHAVIOR
OF OFFICERS. LACKS THAT
PROFESSIONALISM. I'VE BEEN VERY
HONOR TO HAVE BEEN EXPOSED TO
INCREDIBLE PROFESSIONALS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT BOTH AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. WITH THE F. B.
I. U. S. SECRET SERVICE AND
OTHERS. THE MILITARY CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIVE ORGANIZATIONS AND
THEN THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
POLICE OFFICERS THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES. AND IN
PARTICULAR MY TIME AT THE L. A.
P. D. WHICH IS HALLMARK HAS
ALWAYS BEEN ABOUT
PROFESSIONALISM FROM. ITS
REFORMS THAT IS INSTITUTED AND
I MET AND WORKED WITH SOME
INCREDIBLE PEOPLE WITH
INCREDIBLE TO INTEGRITY AND
DEDICATION. WHAT IS THE
EVOLUTION OF ITS
PROFESSIONALISM THAT I THINK IS
INSTRUCTIVE. AND EVEN THOUGH IT
SOMETIMES YOU MAY HAVE THE
APPEARANCE OF PROFESSIONALISM.
IT'S ULTIMATELY THE STANDARDS
IN THE STRUCTURAL FORMS THAT
ACTUALLY BREED THAT
PROFESSIONALISM. THAT YOU CAN
SEE IN THE FIELD. AND IT OFTEN
WAS FROM THE MANY REFORMS UNDER
THE CONSENT DECREE IMPOSED BY
THE US DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THE CHANGE OF THE STRUCTURES
AND THE STRUCTURAL REFORM. TO
HAVE THOSE TYPES OF
PROFESSIONAL ASPECTS THAT I
THINK ARE IMPORTANT. BUT THERE
ARE OF COURSE LIMITATIONS AND
STRUCTURAL PRESSURES. THAT HAVE
THAT THAT LIMIT THE ABILITY OF
ANY ORGANIZATION CALIFORNIA. TO
BREED THE PROFESSIONALISM THAT
WE ALL WANT AND DESERVE. SO
WHAT DO I MEAN BY
PROFESSIONALISM. WELL IF YOU
LOOK AT THE OTHER
PROFESSIONALS- IN OUR SOCIETY
WHETHER THEY'RE DOCTORS LAWYERS
ENGINEERS OR ACCOUNTANTS. THERE
ARE MANY THINGS ABOUT THEM
THAT. WE PERHAPS EXPECT OUT OF
POLICE OFFICERS BUT DON'T
NECESSARILY EXISTENCE
CERTAINLY. GIVEN THE SIZE AND
THE DIVERSITY OF THE NUMBER OF
AGENCIES MAY NOT EXIST. BUT WE
EXPECT PROFESSIONALS LIKE IT
DOCTOR LAWYER TO BE ABLE TO
DIAGNOSE AND SOLVE PROBLEMS. WE
EXPECT THEM TO BE EDUCATED IN
THEIR FIELD OF EXPERTISE BEFORE
THEY EMBARK ON A TRAINING TO
BECOME A DOCTOR AN ENGINEER. WE
EXPECT THEM TO BE PROVEN WITH
SKILLS AND ABILITIES WITH
QUALIFICATION STANDARDS- WE
EXPECT THEM TO BE LICENSED AND
CREDENTIALED. WE DIDN'T EXPECT
THEM TO ADHERE TO STANDARDS OF
CARE WE EXPECT THEM TO BE
CONTEMPORARY AN UP TO DATE WITH
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THEIR
PARTICULAR FIELD. WE OF COURSE
EXPECT ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY WE EXPECT THEM TO
HAVE EXCELLENT JUDGMENT. AND
CRITICAL THINKING SKILLS. AND
FINALLY WE EXPECT HEM TO BE
UNBIASED AND FREE FROM ANY
PREJUDICE AND ALL THE THINGS
THAT HAVE PLAGUED OUR SOCIETY
FOR SO LONG. WHY DO WE WHY IS
BEING PROFESSIONAL SO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE BEING A PROFESSIONAL-
BUILDS TRUST WITH THE COMMUNITY
WE OFTEN DEFER TO THEIR
JUDGMENT AND WE HAVE RESPECT
AND ADMIRATION FOR THEM- WE
OFTEN ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THAT.
BUT WE ARE ULTIMATELY ARE
HOPING THAT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ENTRUSTED WITH THESE POWERS
CANNOT ONLY PROBLEM TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS.BUT CAN APPLY THE LAW
OR OR DEAL WITH THESE ISSUES
WHEN IT COMES TO POLICING. ON
THE INSTITUTIONAL LEVEL WE HAVE
MANY OTHER STRUCTURES HOSPITALS
CLINICS LAW FIRMS ACCOUNTING
FIRMS. THAT SUPPORT THE
PROFESSIONALISM OF THOSE.
FIELDS AND THEN OF COURSE AT
THE STATEWIDE LEVEL SO MANY
REGULATORY SCHEMES THAT ENSURE
THE PROFESSIONALISM AND THE
FACT IS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
NOW FORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA I
HAVE TO SAY GIVEN MY
INTERACTION AND THE WORK I'VE
DONE WITH MANY DEPARTMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES.
IS FAR AHEAD ON THE CURVE ON
THE ISSUE OF POLICING AND
PROFESSIONALISM. WE DO HAVE
CALIFORNIA POST WITH ITS
STANDARDS WE HAVE MANY AGENCIES
THAT HAVE TAKEN IT ON
THEMSELVES TO PROMOTE THE IDEA
OF PROFESSIONAL POLICING. NOT
JUST THE L. A. P. D. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S A VERY LOW
BAR. THERE ARE MANY DEPARTMENTS
OF THE EIGHTEEN THOUSAND THE
UNITED STATES WHERE ACADEMY
CERTIFICATION MAY ONLY BE
REQUIRED FOR THREE MONTHS SUCH
INSTANCE IN SOUTH CAROLINA.
WHERE ONE MONTH OF IT IS FULLY
ONLINE AND YOU ONLY NEED TO BE
CERTIFIED- IN THE ACADEMY
WITHIN THE FIRST YEAR OF YOUR
ACTUAL SERVICE. CALIFORNIA HAS
HIGHER STANDARDS WORK ACADEMIES
ARE ONLY GOOD ARE FROM FOUR TO
SIX MONTHS. BUT EVEN THAT IS
VERY LIMITED WHEN WE LOOK AT
WHAT WE WANT POLICE OFFICERS TO
BE ABLE TO DO. AND MANY OF THE
OTHER PROFESSIONAL FACTORS THAT
I MENTIONED. ARE LEFT TO THE
FOR HUNDRED AND MORE MORE THAN
FIVE HUNDRED POLICE AGENCIES TO
ADOPT AND FIND THE RESOURCES
FOR. WHETHER IT'S THE MINIMUM
STANDARDS FOR QUALIFYING WITH A
FIREARM OR WHATEVER THE
EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS ARE TO
BECOME A POLICE OFFICER IN THAT
CITY. AND IN CALIFORNIA- LIKE
IN MANY STATES TO BECOME A
POLICE OFFICER THE STATE
STANDARD IS ONLY A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA. OR GED E. D. ARE YOU
WHAT BEING A U. S. CITIZEN. AND
HAVING A BACKGROUND. THAT IS
NOT THE STANDARD THAT WE WOULD
WANT OF SOMEBODY WHO HAS TO
EXERCISE SO MUCH POWER
EXERCISED DISCRETION AND USE
GOOD JUDGMENT. THE WAY I THINK
TO LOOK AT THIS IS A FRAMEWORK
WHICH IS TO LOOK AT THE ISSUE
OF PROFESSIONALISM ON THE
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL ON THE AGENCY
OR INSTITUTIONAL LEVEL. AND
THEN ON THE STATEWIDE LEVEL.
WHERE THE LEGISLATURE CAN HELP
SUPPORT THIS. OFTENTIMES RIGHT
NOW ESPECIALLY WE'RE FOCUSING
ON WHAT OFFICER SHOULD NOT BE
THEY SHOULD NOT BE BIASED THEY
SHOULD NOT HAVE CRIMINAL
HISTORIES AND ALL THOSE THE AND
VARIOUS THINGS WHICH IS.
ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT BUT I ALSO
BELIEVE WE HAVE TO LOOK AT WHAT
SHOULD AN OFFICER B. WHAT DOES
A HIGH QUALITY OFFICER LOOK
LIKE ACT LIKE AND PERFORM AS
THERE ARE MANY OF THEM. BUT AS
A STRUCTURE WE DON'T ENCOURAGE
THAT. WE SHOULD EXPECT
EDUCATION IN THEIR FIELD BEFORE
THEY GO TO THE ACADEMY WHETHER
IT'S A COLLEGE EDUCATION OR
SOME EXPERIENCE ON THE COMPLEX
ISSUE. OF CRIME AND POLICING.
WE SHOULD AFFECT THE WE SHOULD
EXPECT ESSENTIAL SKILLS TO BE
TAUGHT IN POLICE ACADEMIES ARE
VERY GOOD AT THAT THEY'RE VERY
GOOD AT TEACHING THE TECHNICAL
SKILLS OF SHOOTING OF DRIVING.
OF CONDUCTING ARRESTS BUT ARE
THEY EMPHASIZING IN ARE WE
RECRUITING AND ENCOURAGING THE
CORE FUNCTION OF POLICING WHICH
IS. SOLVING WHETHER IT'S
COMMUNITY POLICING WHICH IS
COLLABORATIVE PROBLEM SOLVING
WHETHER IT'S TRYING TO SOLVE A
PROBLEM OF A CRIME PROBLEM OR
MANY OR ANY OF THE OTHER
PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE IMPOSED
ON POLICE DEPARTMENTS TO SOLVE.
BUT EVEN IF THEY WERE TO BE
REMOVED. ISSUES WITH MENTAL
HEALTH AND HOMELESSNESS AND ALL
THE THINGS THAT VERY
LEGITIMATELY ARE BEING
DISCUSSED IN PUBLIC POLICY
CIRCLES AND IN THE COUNTRY. AT
ITS CORE POLICING IS ABOUT
PROBLEM SOLVING CRITICAL
THINKING AND ULTIMATELY
DECISIONS WHETHER IT'S
INVESTIGATING A CRIME IN TRYING
TO DISCERN WHO IS TELLING THE
OF THE TRUTH AND WHO IS LYING.
OR ITS CONDUCTING A SEARCH AND
SEE OUR X. SEIZURE IN APPLYING
THE LAW OR TO MAKING AN ARREST
OR CITATION OR OF COURSE
WHETHER THEY SHOULD USE FORCE.
BUT THE MOST CRITICAL DECISION
THAN AN OFFICER IS EXPECTED TO
MAKE. WHEN PRESS THAT INPUT
TAKE AWAY A LIFE. WHAT DO WE AS
A STRUCTURAL MATTER EMPHASIZE
THOSE DECISION MAKING SKILLS
AND I CAN TELL YOU FROM MY
EXPERIENCE ALSO HAVING BEEN
GONE THROUGH THE L. A. P. D.
ACADEMY. THAT WE DO NOT DO AN
ADEQUATE JOB AND CERTAINLY
DON'T ENCOURAGE THAT ON A
STRUCTURAL LEVEL. AND THAT IS
PARTICULARLY TRUE ON THE LAW.
DR HANNEKE MENTIONED ABOUT HOW
CONSTITUTIONAL SCHOLARS DEBATE
DIFFERENT ISSUES AND I CONSIDER
MYSELF AT LEAST A
CONSTITUTIONAL LAWYER. THERE
ARE MANY THINGS THAT HAVE TO BE
APPLIED. BUT TO EXPECT SOMEBODY
WITH A HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION IN
ONLY SIX MONTHS IN THE ACADEMY
OF WHICH A SMALL PORTION.
INVOLVES ACTUALLY UNDERSTANDING
AND APPLYING LAW. IS AN
EXPECTATION THAT IS JUST NOT
REALISTIC BUT SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULDN'T WE NECESSARILY NEED
TO LOOK AT. ON THE
INSTITUTIONAL AN AGENCY LEVEL I
THINK THE INSTITUTIONS MUST
FOCUS ON PROBLEM SOLVING AND
CRITICAL THINKING. NOT ONLY ON
THE SKILLS BUT ON THESE ISSUES
A PROBLEM SOLVING ESPECIALLY
WITH THE COMMUNITY. THEY MUST
HAVE VALUE IN EDUCATION AND
SCREENING A PROMOTION AND IT
MUST BE STRUCTURE AROUND THAT.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY THE NEED
FOR POLICE AGENCIES TO BEAT
LEARNING ORGANIZATIONS. LAPD
HAS STRUCK ME SO MUCH WHEN I
JOIN ABOUT HOW MUCH IT FOCUS ON
LEARNING. LEARNING ON INTERNAL
INCIDENTS AND ALSO LEARNING
FROM OUTSIDE AGENCIES IN
ACADEMICS. THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT IS SO CRITICAL BECAUSE YOU
CANNOT PREVENT THE NEXT USE OF
FORCE. IF YOU DON'T ANALYZE AND
ARE SELF CRITICAL ABOUT THE USE
OF FORCE THAT HAPPENED
YESTERDAY. THEY ALSO HAVE TO
ENCOURAGE DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION BECAUSE DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION IS NOT ONLY RIGHT TO
REFLECT THE COMMUNITY. WHAT IS
SO CRITICAL TO HAVE THAT IF YOU
WANT TO SOLVE COMPLEX PROBLEMS.
AND THAT. IS CRITICAL IF WE
WANT TO SOLVE THESE ISSUES
WHETHER IT'S ABOUT CRIME OR
MANY OF THE OTHER SOCIETAL
PROBLEMS WE HAVE. AND OF COURSE
WE NEED OVERSIGHT. THERE HAS TO
BE ACCOUNTABILITY TRANSPARENCY
AND OVERSIGHT IN ORDER FOR AN
ORGANIZATION TO LEARN AND
IMPROVE. AND FINALLY I JUST
WANT TO SAY ON THE STATEWIDE
LEVEL. ONE SIZE CANNOT FIT ALL.
NO ALL AGE OF THIS IN THE DO
CAN. THE LAPD CANNOT YOU CANNOT
HAVE WHAT MAY BE ADEQUATE FOR
THEIR APPROPRIATE FOR THE LAPD
TO APPLY TO THE NEWPORT BEACH
OR TO SHASTA COUNTY.
CALIFORNIA'S LARGE DIVERSE IN
THEIR VERY MANY DIFFERENT NEEDS
OF COMMUNITIES AND AGENCIES.
BUT THAT SHOULDN'T STOP THAT
THE STATE FROM LOOKING AT THE
SAME TYPES OF REGULATORY
STANDARDS AND THINGS THAT WE
EXPECT OF ALL PROFESSIONALS.
MINIMUM STANDARDS TO BECOME A
POLICE OFFICER LICENSING
CREDENTIALING CERTIFICATION AND
YES DECERTIFICATION LIKE WE
WOULD ANY OTHER PROFESSIONAL.
LEARNING ORGANIZATIONS I'M
LOOKING AT HOW TO IMPROVE
TACTICS AND OTHER THINGS.
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THE SUPPORT
AND RESEARCH NECESSARY A FOCUS
ON HOW DO WE DEVELOP THE
OFFICERS WE WANT. THAT NOT ONLY
HAVE THE SKILLS BUT HAVE THE
CRITICAL THINKING SKILLS AND
THE PROBLEM SOLVING SKILLS THAT
WE WANT AND EXPECT OF ALL
PROFESSIONALS. SO MY THOUGHT IS
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HISTORY I
THINK WHAT IT SHOWS IS A CALL
TO ACTION. FOR THIS COMMITTEE
AND OTHERS TO DO A
COMPREHENSIVE EXAMINATION THE
STRUCTURAL EXAMINATION
POLICING. BECAUSE OFTEN THE
FRUSTRATION THAT WE SEE ABOUT
WHY HASN'T POLICING CHANGED
WITH ALL OF THE REFORMS AND
LEGISLATIVE CHANGES. THIS
BECAUSE I THINK WE HAVE TO AT
THIS BASIC FACT. THAT WE OFTEN
PUT POLICE OFFICERS AND HAVE
EXPECTATIONS OF THEM THAT THE
STRUCTURE IN OUR SYSTEM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND ELSEWHERE. JUST
DOES NOT SO PORT. WHO SHOULD BE
POLICE OR OFFICERS AND HOW DO
WE ENSURE PROFESSIONALISM ON AN
INDIVIDUAL INSTITUTIONAL
STATEWIDE LEVEL I TRULY BELIEVE
IS SOMETHING THAT THIS
COMMITTEE SHOULD EXAMINE.
CLOSELY AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT
I THE POLICE OFFICER POLICE
LEADERS AND THE WITH THE- AN
EXPANDED THEY EXPECT THESE
BASIC CONCEPTS. I THINK
REIMAGINE POLICING HIS
IMAGINING THE POLICE WE HAVE
SEEN THROUGH HISTORY BECAUSE
PROFESSIONALISM AND THE URGENCY
TO MAKE THE STRUCTURAL FORMS
COULD NEVER BE MORE SIGNIFICANT
THAN NOW. BEING EDUCATE IN THE
FIELD FOCUSING ON PROBLEM
SOLVING FOCUSING ON
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
DECISION MAKING ESPECIALLY IN
USES OF FORCE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE COLLABORATIVE
PROBLEM SOLVING THAT WE EXPECT.
I THINK ARE THE KEYS TO
REIMAGINING POLICING AND
IMAGINE POLICING THAT WOULD
COMMUNITIES AND ALL OF US
DESERVE. AND WITH THAT I THANK
YOU AND I KNOW PROFESSOR
HEDICAN IRE HER HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION OR
THANK BOTH OF YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION- WE WANTED TO-
YOUR PRESENTATIONS ON HISTORY
AND POLICE REFORM IN CALIFORNIA
AND NATIONALLY. GIVING UP THOSE
PERSPECTIVE NOW WE WANT TO
BEGIN WITH A PANEL DISCUSSION-
EACH PANELIST WILL HAVE UP TO
TWELVE MINUTES TO SPEAK- AND
MAKE A PRESENTATION- WE WILL GO
IN THE ORDER THAT YOU ARE%
PRINTED ON THE AGENDA BEFORE
PRESENTING. PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES AFTER ALL PANELISTS
HAVE FINISHED MEMBERS WILL BE
INVITED TO ASK QUESTIONS AT
THAT TIME. WE WILL BEGIN WITH
MISTER NEW YES WHO BE A RIPPLE
BI PARTICIPATING VIA A CALL AND
MODERATOR. WOULD YOU PLEASE-
PLACEMENTS NOON YES IN THE
QUEUE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN THERE.
OKAY COULD YOU GIVE ME OKAY YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU CAN BEGIN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. YEAH GOOD
MORNING MR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ERIC MANY
OTHERS YOU KNOW I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION- I THINK I
JUST WANT TO THANK FIRST OF ALL
ALL. THE BEING IN BY TO
PARTICIPATE TODAY'S HEARING.
AND DISCUSS THE HISTORY OF
POLICE REFORM I APPRECIATE. THE
FORMER SPEAKERS- THAT I'VE
HEARD SO FAR AND THEIR
PERSPECTIVE AND ALTHOUGH I'M AN
ADJUNCT STAFF MEMBER FOR.
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
LONG BEACH AND THE GOLDEN WEST
CRIMINAL JUSTICE CENTER WHICH
IS THE PRIEST HAD ME IN ORANGE
COUNTY. I'M NOT NECESSARILY
HERE THAN ACADEMIC OF MY
PROFESSION OVER THE LAST.
FIFTEEN YEARS BUT AT THE THIRTY
YEAR PRACTITIONER AND PUBLIC
SAFETY ADVOCATE. FOR MY
COMMUNITY AND THE ASSOCIATION.
POLICE CHIEFS HAVE BEEN AT THE
CENTER OF DEVELOPING AND
IMPLEMENTING MAJOR REFORMS OF
THE LAST DECADE. AND I'M
PRIVILEGED TO BE HERE TODAY TO
GIVE YOU OUR PERSPECTIVE
QUICKLY. ABOUT ORGANIZATION
ELEGIES FOR THOSE WHO DON'T
KNOW THE PROFESSION OF
PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTS. ALL THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO POLICE THE KEYS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IN
ADDITION TO OUR ADVOCACY CAL
CHIEFS DEVELOPS TRAINING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
COURSES FOR TEACHERS AND SECOND
THE COMMAND WE HOPE THOUSAND.
OF LEADERSHIP TRAINING
CONFERENCES AND SEMINARS EVERY
YEAR INCLUDING THE ANNUAL WOMEN
LEADERS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
CONFERENCE THAT INVITES. FEMALE
OFFICERS AND SUPPORT STAFF FROM
VARYING LEVELS- FROM ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TO ORGANIZE AND
DEVELOP. NEW SKILLS AND BURNING
BUT OUT OF THESE. ABOUT OUR
PROFESSION THROUGH ALL THIS
WORK WE ARE CAN CONSTANTLY
EVALUATING AND SHARING
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT IS
WORKING. IN THE AREAS AND THEN
WHAT IS AND IN NEED OF
IMPROVEMENT OBVIOUSLY THERE
ALWAYS IS A NEED FOR
IMPROVEMENT. TODAY I'D LIKE TO
BRIEFLY. TALK ABOUT THE
DIFFERENT AREAS OF POLICING
GIVEN AN OVERVIEW OF MAJOR
LEGISLATIVE REFORMS. AND
DISCUSS THE MOMENT- MOVEMENT IT
COMMUNITY ORIENTED POLICING.
AND. FINISH IF YOU WILL WITH
COMMENTS ABOUT WHAT'S GOING
OPERATIONAL CHANGES WITH OUR
THAT'S WITH EVERY LONG CHANGE
OVER TIME. MOST READ POLICE AS
FROM ALMOST FOCUSED ON CRIME
PREVENTION WHICH HAS WHICH
REALLY WAS THE RESULT OF THE
HIKE RATE THE FINAL DECADES OF
THE TWENTIETH TO FOCUS IN IT
THIS ON THE PLEASE WITHIN THE
LAST. ONE TO FIFTY TWENTY. NO
OTHER PROFESSION I'VE- OR OR
EACH YEAR HAS AT MAJOR GIPSON
ALL OF THE LONG. AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM THE LAST DECADE
ESPECIALLY CAL. ALTHOUGH NOT
ALL THESE DIRECTLY RELATED TO
POLICE OPERATION THEY ALL HAVE
AN IMPACT. OF THE DAY TO DAY
ACTIONS OF OUR AGENCIES IN
PEACE TALKS WITH FARC FRANKLY
EVEN OUR COMMUNITY. IT START
WITH THE- IF THE DETENTION
POLICY WITH AB. ONE OH NINE IF
YOU LET. WE'VE BEEN GROWING ARE
GROWING FOCUS ON LEGISLATION TO
REFORM OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. CALIFORNIA ALSO PASSED
PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN WHICH
DRAMATICALLY. CHANGED OUR
PENALTIES ON DRUG POSSESSION
AND CONSUMPTION ITSELF WHICH IS
RESULT IN A NUMBER OF
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. ONE OF
THEM BEING A MAJOR- ONE BEING
BE A REDUCTION OF PARTICIPATION
IN DRUG COURT. I HAVING BEEN A
MEMBER NORTH HERE IN THE DRUG
COURT. I GOT CAN K. YOU THAT
THE BOTH. IT ISN'T US THE
DEGREE AND THEN WE NEED. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE TO GIVE YOU.
FREE THE CAN OF. AND THE
DISABILITY CONSTRAIN OF THE A
DRUG THAT THE ABUSE AND ALL THE
OVER THAT ARE OCCURRING OUR
COUNTRY NATIONWIDE. WE'VE ALSO
SEEN LEGISLATION TO ESTABLISH
AN INCREASE YOU DEFENDER AN
ELDERLY PROGRAMS INCREASE
COMPASSIONATE THE LEAVES. AN
ESTABLISHED THE BURDEN PROGRAMS
AROUND THE STATE. WE'VE REDUCE
PENALTIES ON DRUG SELVES CRIMES
INVOLVING FIREARMS BELIEVE. FOR
CALIFORNIANS IN CASES INVOLVING
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATIONS AND
CIVIL ASSET FORFEITURE. WE'VE
SET ASIDE- WITH THAT STATEWIDE
RULES GOVERNING IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
FEDERAL AGENCIES ON
IMMIGRATION. AND SET
RESTRICTIONS ON INFORMATION
SHARING WITH HOMELAND SECURITY
MORE SPECIFICALLY WITH ICE.
STEP RULES FOR WITNESS
INTERROGATIONS LINEUPS IN
CUSTODY- INTERVIEWS WITH
JUVENILES. ARE TRAINING
MANDATES WORK OUT OF THE
RECRUITERS GROWN ALMOST EVERY
YEAR- NOW INCLUDING MENTAL
HEALTH TRAINING AND RACIAL
IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING AMONG
OTHERS. OUR SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRY SYSTEM HAS BEEN
COMPLETELY REDESIGNED AND
MODERNIZED. TO BE A VERY SECURE
SYSTEM THAT WE'RE AWARE OF. OUR
STATEWIDE- CAL GANG DATABASES
BEEN PURGING AND RESET UNDER
NEW CRITERIA CONTROLS. WE ARE
SEVERAL YEARS IN THE PROCESS OF
HAVING BOND FOR A COLLECT NEW
AND DETAILED INFORMATION ON USE
OF FORCE. AND RACIAL IDENTITY
OF ANYONE. BY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ARAJ HAS LEGALIZED CANNABIS
CONNECT WRECK IN THE- WE'VE A
OF FOR THE RELEASE OF POLICE
PERSONNEL FILES WHICH MANY OF
YOU CAN RECALL THAT MAY.
REQUIRE THE PITCHES MOTION AND
NOW. ARE THE AGENCIES TO POST
ALL THEIR INTERNAL UP WE'VE
POLICIES ONLINE. THEY MAY
TRANSPARENT EVERY OFFICER
INVOLVED SHOOTING INVESTIGATION
WE HAVE ELIMINATED OUR FIRST
DEGREE MURDER WILL ALLOW FOR
NEW TRIALS IN THOSE CASES.
WE'VE CHANGED CRIMINAL OR
JURISDICTIONS OVER MINERS
VOTERS OF. ALSO PASSED
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN WHICH
IS A LOT FOR THE EARLY EARLY
RELEASE OF OFF BALANCE NOT ON
THE LIST OF VIOLENT. FELONIES
WHICH MAKES ACTUALLY. BILL
DOUBLE DOUBLE WHO HAVE BEEN CAN
OF RAPE OR- UNCONSCIOUS ARE
KNOWN IN. THE MYSTIC VIOLENCE-
THEN I CLEARLY EARLY BECAUSE-
WE'D ALREADY HAD THE- THE MERIT
SYSTEM OR THE CREDIT SYSTEM.
FOR INMATES- THAT WOULD WITHOUT
RELIEF AND BASED ON THEIR-
CONTACT AND GOOD CONDUCT
WITHIN. WALKING A KERN ST IT
NOW WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT
DOESN'T- WE WERE WE DON'T EVEN
LOOK AT ENHANCEMENTS AS SUCH AS
THE RESULT OF PROP FIFTY SEVEN.
WE HAVE LIMITED MAJORITY OF
PROPERTY PROBATION AND PAROLE-
TERMS AND- I DON'T. ELIMINATED
DOESN'T FIND AND FEES THAT HOW
PAY FOR NUMEROUS. SHAKY PRO
INCLUDING LONG TRAINING. WE
HAVE- PASSED LEGISLATION TO IN
OUR MONEY BAIL SYSTEM. WE BAND
THEN I WHEN I SAY WE I'M
TALKING ABOUT WE HAVE BEEN
CALIFORNIANS SOME OF THE STUFF
WE'VE ACTUALLY CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS ACTUALLY TAKING- AS BEEN
INVOLVED INDIRECTLY WITH THE
LEGISLATION IN THIS IS GOING TO
HELP. IF SOME OF THE STUFF
PASSED. BUT WE PAN FACIAL
RECOGNITION SOFTWARE IN THE USE
OF CAROTID RESTRAINT- AND
CHOKEHOLDS. RECENTLY WE HAVE
DOZENS OF NEW FIREARM LAWS THAT
ARE OFFICERS AND AGENCIES WILL
SOUND. WE'VE INCREASED THE
DIGITAL DISCRETION AND NOW
ALLOWED THE VIRGIN AGAINST
PROSECUTORS OBJECTIONS. AND
FINALLY WE HAVE WRITTEN ARE
OUTDATED YOU SUPPORT STATUTES
AND CREATED THE NATION'S MOST
COMPREHENSIVE USE OF FORCE
POLICY REQUIREMENTS IN THE
NATION. SB TWO THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND NINETEEN WITHOUT YOU
SPONSORED BANDITS OFFICER DE
ESCALATE WHEN PEOPLE RENDER
MEDICAL AID INTERVENE AGAINST
EXCESSIVE FORCE UTILIZED
PROPORTIONAL FORCE PROVIDE
GUIDANCE ON DEALING WITH HIGH
RISK POPULATIONS. OF THE USE OF
FORCE TRAINING THEM AND
REPORTING AND MUCH MORE MUCH
MORE THE- VERY COMPREHENSIVE
WE'VE NOT ALWAYS. SEEN EYE TO
EYE WITH LEGISLATORS OBVIOUSLY
OF THESE MEASURES THAT ON MANY
OCCASIONS WE HAVE WORKED
COLLABORATIVELY. TO ACHIEVE
SHARED GOALS OF FINDING
ALTERNATIVES TO INCARCERATION
THAT STILL SUPPORT PUBLIC
SAFETY. HOWEVER THERE IS NOT
BEEN ANY THOROUGH REVIEW OF
THESE OVERALL IMPACT ON THE
CRIMINAL. JUSTICE SYSTEM AS A
WHOLE. IN THE DARK THAT THEIR
SOME SUCCESS MEASURES AND SOME
CONTACT. THAT NEED TO ADDRESSED.
IF WE ARE TO KEEP LOOKING.
MOVING FOR AND WE WILL BE
CONTINUE TO MOVE ALL THE SNOW
ON THE ALL. WITH MORE CHANGE.
THE POLICE. THEIR NEED TO BE A
REFLECTION ON WHAT HAS ALREADY
BEEN ACCOMPLISHED AND WHAT
THESE IMPACTS HAVE. ADD UP TO
OUR COMMUNITIES OVERALL CRIME
STATISTICS REMAIN WELL BELOW
WHAT THEY WERE IN THE EARLY
NINETEEN NINETIES. BUT THAT IS
NOT THE FULL MEASUREMENT OF
SUCCESS NOR DOES IT MEAN
EVERYTHING HAS WORKED OUT
PERFECTLY OBVIOUSLY. WE HAVE
EXAMPLES FROM ACROSS THE STATE
OF GAPS HOLES. WORK JUSTICE
SYSTEMS NOW FAILING TO CORRECT
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR- OR COUGHING
AGENCIES TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS WITHOUT MEASUREMENTS OF
SUCCESS. THE HOMELESSNESS AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE PRACTICES GROW
WORSE EVERY YEAR. AND WE'VE NOT
FOUND ADEQUATE SUPPORT
RESOURCES FOR THOSE ON THE
STREETS AND IN THIS BILL AND
STILL IN NEED- WE'VE ALSO
CONTINUE TO PLACE MORE MORE
REQUIREMENTS ON A POLICE
OFFICERS BUT NOT. ALWAYS GIVEN
THE AGENCY THAT'S TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER- THE OR THE INDIVIDUALS
RESOURCES THEY TRULY NEED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. AND THESE ARE FAR
FROM THE ONLY CHANGES THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN LONG COURSE THAT
YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT A- THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY POLICING
REPORT RELEASED IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN HIGHLIGHTED. BEST
PRACTICES AND SMART APPROACHES
TO HELP RENEW. A NATIONAL FOCUS
ON COMMUNITY POLICING INCLUDING
IS BEEN VERY BIG LIKE I WOULD
SPOKE EARLIER ON IN THE- THE
RIGHT AT THE TURN OF THE- AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY. CONCEPTS THAT
WERE VAGUELY FAMILIAR UNIVERSAL
THINGS SUCH AS WE PLEDGING TO
MISSING BUT YOU DON'T JUSTICE
COMMUNITY OVERSIGHT. AN OFFICER
WELLNESS. MANY OF YOU CONCEPT
CAME FROM. LEVEL WHERE THE
WITHIN THE IN WAYS IMPROVED
REALLY. BETWEEN THE AFFECTED
GROUPS LONG. HELP HAD MANY. THE
POLICE JUST IF OF. IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE- OF MY
POLICE. ACTIVITY THAT WERE IN
INCOME. IN GROWTH EVERY. THE
CHANGES HAVE BEEN REFLECTED IN
THE CULTURAL AND OPERATIONAL
STEPS IF WE'VE MADE. AGENCIES
ACROSS OUR STATE. IT'S BEING
CALLED THEN OPERATIONAL CHANGES
INTERNALLY. AGENCIES HAVE
ADAPTED TO THE NEW REQUIREMENTS
AND ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES
BY SPECIALIZING UNITS AND
CAPABILITIES. FOR EXAMPLE THE
USE OF HOMELESS LIAISON
OFFICERS OR MULTI DISCIPLINARY
STRIKE TEAMS HAS GROWN
SUBSANTIALLY. IN ADDITION OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH VERY FEW
PROGRAMS IN JUVENILE DIVERSION
INTO BECOME MORE WIDESPREAD.
THERE'S BEEN AN INCREASED FOCUS
ON RECRUITING THE NEXT
GENERATION OF PEACE OFFICERS.
THAT ARE MORE DIVERSE AND
REPRESENTATIVE THE COMMUNITY.
FINALLY OUR TRAINING IS BECOME
MORE REALISTIC OUTSIDE THE
CLASSROOM BY INCLUDING THESE
THE SIMULATORS AND REAL LIFE
SCENARIOS THAT ALTHOUGH. THERE
IS- THE REQUIREMENT IS THAT THE
ONLY HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL
EDUCATION WE'RE FINDING THAT
MORE AND MORE OF OUR OFFICERS.
ARE COMING TO US WITH THE WITH
THE EDUCATION A LITTLE BIT
LATER IN LIFE THEN- THE TWENTY
ONE BECAUSE OF HAVING TO GO TO
COLLEGE. EARLY INCLUDES I GUESS
OVERALL TO BE PROUD OF WHAT WE
HAVE. IN TAKE NOTE OF THE MAY
REFORM WE'VE ARE ENACTED. THAT
IS NOT TO SAY THERE IS A MORE
THAT CAN BE DONE OBVIOUSLY SUCH
AS THE CREATION OF A STATE WIDE
THE CERTIFICATION PROCESS FOR
OFFICERS. FOR MR TARIQ
MISCONDUCT. BUT OUR NEXT STEP
SHOULD BE DONE IN CONTEXT WITH
WHAT HAS TAKEN PLACE. IN IN
REVIEW OF WHAT IS AND ISN'T
WORKING. IN I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE TIME MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE IN. I AM
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AFTER THE R. SPEC BUT AS OF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WAS KNOWN
AS PRE ST YOUR COMMENTS- I HAVE
A QUESTION FOR YOU- AND AGAIN
PRECIADO YOU WALKING US THROUGH
WHAT HAS TAKEN PLACE AND THEN
I'LL INVITE MY COLLEAGUES TO
ALSO CHIME IN WITH QUESTIONS
FOR. THOSE WHO'VE ALREADY-
TESTIFIED- THUS FAR. THE FIRST
QUESTION I HAVE FOR YOU IS NEW
YEARS IS WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS
ABOUT COMMUNITY BASED POLICING.
IN YOUR MIND DOES IT WORK
THAT'S THE FIRST QUESTION ABOUT
COMMUNITY BASED POLICING
DOESN'T WORK. YEAH I NEED IT I
CAN TELL YOU THIS MUCH THAT NOT
ONLY DOES IT WORK. IT YEAH WHAT
WE DO FOR A LIVING THAT POLICE
OFFICERS. WE IT. ESPECIALLY NOW
BUT IT ANYTIME COURT YOU CAN'T.
WE CAN'T BE EFFECTIVE IN DOING
WHAT WE DO WE DON'T HAVE THE
COMMUNITY HELPING US. TO HELP
NOT ONLY IENTIFY PROBLEMS UT
FRAME THOSE PROBLEMS BECAUSE I
THINK THE PROBLEMS HAVE TO BE
FAINT- FRAMED APPROPRIATELY SO
THAT WE ACTUALLY DO COME UP
WITH. YOU KNOW EFFECTIVE A
MEANINGFUL SOLUTION TO THESE
ISSUES AND ALSO THE
COMMUNICATION THAT GOES BACK
AND FORTH SO THAT WE
UNDERSTAND. THE PERSPECTIVE
FROM WHICH WE ARE WHICH WE ARE
CRAVING THOSE PROBLEMS FROM AND
IT NEEDED AND THE NEED FOR
THAT. CAN ONLY COME THROUGHOUT
REACHED IN CONSTANT AND THEN
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING. AND YEAH
I DO BELIEVE I DO BELIEVE THE
WORK I DO BELIEVE THAT IT
NEEDS- MORE WORK AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT- ONLINE I THINK IT
WAS THE- FITS BOTH EARLIER.
ABOUT THIS HI THIS ISSUE BUT I
THINK IT'S ALSO A- MORE
POSSIBLY MORE TRAINING IN- IN
EMOTIONAL INTELLIGENCE AND
LEARNING HOW TO INCREASE THE
LEVEL OF THE MOST INTELLIGENT.
NOT ONLY WITHIN OUR OFFICERS
BUT I THINK YOU KNOW WITHIN OUR
PUBLIC AND UNDERSTANDING WHAT
WE DO FOR A LIVING. AND HOW
THAT'S. NOT MEANT TO GET DONE.
THANK YOU VERY JUST GOING OFF
MY OWN X. AND SERVE THE CITY
MAY WILL. THERE WAS. ARE AND
CAPTAIN THEY DEMANDED THAT US
THAT WE GET OUT OF THE CAR. I
KNEW THE LOPEZ FAMILY I KNEW
THE GARCIA FAMILY I KNEW- THE
HERNANDEZ FAMILY AND THAT.
ABSOLUTELY MADE ME I THINK
ABOUT A POLICE OFFICER DURING
THAT TIME AND ALSO YOU PROMOTED
I THINK COMMUNITY BASED
POLICING IN THAT EFFORT SO- I
DO BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO
STRENGTHEN THAT WE NEED TO
CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE THAT. IN
ALL DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS THE SECOND
QUESTION I HAVE FOR YOU IS WHAT
IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
EXTRAPOLATIONS FROST. BETWEEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
COMMUNITY. WHAT ARE-
DEPARTMENTS DOING TO IMPROVE
AND HAT AND WHAT HAS WORKED. IN
YOUR OPINION. WELL AT OKAY ONE
THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAYS IS THIS
TRANSPARENCY. IS TO BE OPEN.
WITH YOUR COMMUNITY I THINK YOU
KNOW SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
ORIGINALLY WERE. PROBABLY THERE
WAS SOME PUSHBACK WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT ON A LIKE FOR YOU
KNOW. PUBLISHING OUR POLICIES
ONLINE AND DOING THOSE THINGS I
THINK THERE THAT THE PERFECT
EXAMPLE WHAT WE- WE HAVE
NOTHING TO HIDE. I MEAN YOU
KNOW THE WE'RE NOT GIVING OUT-
TACTICAL INFORMATION AS YET YOU
KNOW- ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON.
HAVING BEEN IN LONG COURSE BUT
WE'RE NOT DOING THAT. THE KIND
OF THING WHERE WE ARE WE'RE
JUST SHOWING THEM OUR
PROCEDURES ARE POLICIES HOW WE
GET THINGS DONE. I THINK THE
FACT AND I THINK ALL THE
DIFFERENT COMMUNITY. EVENTS
THAT WE ACTUALLY HOST THAT THE
CITY. IN OUR POLICE DEPARTMENT
TAKING PART IN THAT BECAUSE YOU
HAVE TO BECOME. PART OF THE
COMMUNITY YOU CAN'T JUST LEAVE
THE COMMUNITY. AND I THINK.
WHAT I'VE SEEN IS ONE OF ONE
POLICE FOR. THE DEPARTMENT THAT
CAN WORK WELL THAT THAT THE
THAT THEY HAVE A FORMAL-
COMMUNITY POLICING. PROGRAMS
BUT IT BE INFORMAL I THINK THAT
WORKS BEST IS WHEN YOU
ACTUALLY. DO THE THINGS THAT
YOU SAID AND GET OUT YOUR CAR
AND ACTUALLY GO OUT AND HAVE A
CONVERSATION THE- KIND OF THE
COFFEE WITH A COP IF YOU WILL.
IN THE MEANTIME WITH YOUR
PUBLIC- I THINK THE OTHER THING
TOO IS. THE MEETING WHEN YOU'VE
DONE SOMETHING. RIGHT IN AT THE
AT THE END AN AGENT. YOU KNOW I
IN B. STAR. FOR THE HAPPEN IN I
KNOW THAT THE SOMETIMES TURN A
TURN OR TURN YOU KNOW CITY IT'S-
AND- ALL THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
PART OF THE HIGHER TO PROTECT
CITIES AND- AND OTHER THINGS
AND AN APARTMENT. YOU KNOW
DON'T WORRY ABOUT THAT BECAUSE
OF LIABILITY ISSUES BUT I THINK
YOU NEED TO SPEAK OUT TO THE
PEOPLE. AROUND THAT WERE MOST
IMPACTED BY BUT WHATEVER
ACTIONS WE TOOK WHETHER THEY
WERE JUSTIFIED OR NOT. YOU YEAH
ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE JUSTIFIED
I MEAN THEY'RE JUSTIFIED YOU
NEED TO STILL GO OUT AND- TALK
ABOUT WHAT. WHAT YOU DID
BECAUSE SOMETIMES- THE END
RESULT OF THOSE- JUSTIFIED
ACTIONS. ARE STILL FEEL FOR
BOTH THE EVERYBODY INVOLVED
INCLUDING THE OFFICER- SO I
THINK YOU NEED TO SHARE IN THE
PAIN. ARE ENSURING THAT
COMMUNICATION. THANK YOU FOR
MUCH SECOND CLUE MICHAEL OVER
UP TO THE MAY. THE FIRST ONE IS
MISS GONZALEZ AFTER WILL BE MR
LACKEY AND THEN AFTER MITCHELL
LACK WE HAVE MISTER MAYES AND
MEMBERS IFYOU WANT TO BE. OKAY
JUST LET ME KNOW THANK YOU. I'M
SHIFTING AS I HAVE A QUESTION
SPECIFICALLY- HOPEFULLY YOU CAN
ANSWER I WOULD THINK AS A
POLICE CHIEF BUT- I WHAT I WANT
TO KNOW A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THE HISTORY OF POLICE OFFICER A
PEACE OFFICER DISCIPLINE IN
CALIFORNIA- HAS GOTTEN HARDER
HAS GOTTEN EASIER TO DISCIPLINE
OFFICERS WHAT'S THE- IT. WHAT
WE HAVE THERE LIKE WHAT'S
HAPPENED WHERE WHERE HAS IT
GONE. RIGHT I THINK WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IS PROBABLY- A
DISPLAY- AND LIKE IN ANY
INDUSTRY THAT YOU KNOW OF WHAT.
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS. THE
CREATION OF LAWS THAT PROTECT
EMPLOYEES IN GENERAL RIGHT AND-
IN IN IN SOME OF THOSE LAWS
THAT HAVE PROVIDED PROTECT THEY
WERE WELL INTENDED IN GOOD
MEETING AND ACTUALLY SERVE A
PURPOSE- BUT IT ALSO MADE IT
THE CONSEQUENCES OF. SOME OF
THOSE PROTECTIONS THAT IT MADE
IT MUCH MORE DIFFICULT. FOR
CHIEFS OF POLICE SAY
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT THEY'RE DRAFTING IS- A HOW
TO HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE IN
AND- BECAUSE YOU COULD EASILY.
DECIDED THE CHANGE THAT HEY
WE'RE GOING THROUGH THIS
PROCESS AND WE WANT TO YOU WANT
IT NOW THEY ARE TERMINATE
SOMEBODY. BUT THEN YOU HAVE ALL
THESE DIFFERENT BOARDS- THE
HELP THAT THEY HAVE TO GO
THROUGH AND MEDIATORS SOMETIMES
AND IF THE PEOPLE WIND UP
FIGHTING GETTING THEIR JOBS
BACK. YOU KNOW SOMETIMES A
TECHNICALITIES DOOR- JUST
BECAUSE SOME- I'M IN A MEDIATOR
JUST FELT LIKE THEY COULD GET
GIVEN A SECOND CHANCE. AND SO
THAT MAKES IT DIFFICULT. FOR A
CHEAP TO DO THEIR JOB AND I
THINK THAT THE CERTIFICATION
PROCESS THAT WE'RE INTERESTED
IN AND- IT CERTAINLY WOULD.
WOULD HELP- GO ALONG WAY THAN
TRYING TO- PROTECT THE
COMMUNITY. AND ALLOW US TO DO
THAT I THINK THAT THE-
EVERYTHING BECOME MORE
SOPHISTICATED. IN OUR WORLD AND
THE LEVEL OF SOPHISTICATION IN
TERMS OF EMPLOYEE RIGHTS AND-
AND THE LEGAL- THE LEGAL ISSUES
THAT GO BEHIND THAT HAVE BECOME
MORE COMPLEX AND SO. WE DEAL
WITH THE MUCH MORE COMPACT
SYSTEM THAN WE DID BEFORE SAY.
IN THE SIXTIES WHEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT- WELL WHAT THE
NEGATIVE CAMPAIGNING BEFORE
THAT IF THEY WANTED TO
TERMINATE SOMEBODY A LOT OF
TIME TO GET. IT FIREMAN IN YOUR
ALMOST EVERYBODY WAS THAT THE
THING WE AT WILL EVEN THOUGH
THEY WEREN'T BUT- THAT'S NOT
WHAT. IT APPEARS. REPLY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. YEAH THANK
ACHIEVE NEAR I JUST A QUICK
COME FOLLOWED BY A I DO BELIEVE
VERY VERY. HE PLAYED THE
COMMUNITY POLICING OF DOWN
PROPERLY ASSEMBLY RELATIONSHIP
BUILDING. AND IT'S HARD TO
ACCOMPLISH BECAUSE OF TRUST
BARRIERS THAT. THAT EXIST- OVER
A LONG PERIOD OF TIME MY
QUESTION WOULD BE HOW TO
OFFICERS OR DEPUTIES
DEMONSTRATE THAT THEY'RE
GENERALLY COMMITTED TO BEING A
SERVANT VERSES JUST KNOW FOR
SURE. IT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND
ONE OF OUR LACK OF THE BABY. I
THINK. THANK YOU HAPPEN
EVERYDAY TO BE HONEST WITH YOU-
I SEE THEM BECAUSE- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I'LL TELL YOU MY
OWN PERSONAL- RESPECTIVE IN THE
WAY THAT I DO WITH IT HERE. I
TEACH THESE GUYS AT LEAST OF
THE PHILOSOPHY THAT I HAVE IS
THAT WE'RE NONE OF US ARE
EXPERTS AT HUMAN DIGNITY AND
NONE OF US ARE EXPERTS AT
REASONABLE NATIONAL COURTS
DECIDE REASONABLENESS ALL THE
TIME THEY CHANGE THAT BAR. OR
THAT THEY CHANGE THE LINE- AND
ALSO LIKE TO BELIEVE WE'RE
EXPECTED HIM DIGNITY BUT I'M
NOT CERTAIN THAT WE ARE THE WE
CAN ALL BE EXPERTS AT THE
SEARCH TO STRIKE A BALANCE
BETWEEN REASONABLENESS IN HUMAN
DIGNITY. AND IT'S KIND OF LIKE
IMPORTING THE LETTER LAW VERSUS
THE SPIRIT OF ALL AND IT'S ALSO
KIND OF LIKE. STARTLES YOU
KNOW- FOR OVERTURE I BELIEVE
THAT WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
AND I THEN I TELL THEM THIS IS
THAT. WHAT THE WHAT IS THE
PURPOSE OF THESE LOG IN WHAT IS
IT THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH- SO EVEN IN THE
ENFORCEMENT SIDE OF THEM YOU
KNOW OF THE LAW AND THEN FOR.
IT SHOULD BE. WITH A REASONABLE
AS AND THEN TO BALANCE HUMAN
DIGNITY ON THE OTHER SIDE
YOU'RE RIGHT I BELIEVE THAT- I
BELIEVE YOU'RE CORRECT IN
SAYING THAT IT IS ABOUT
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING AND THE
WAY YOU WILL BUILD THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS IF YOU DON'T WAIT
UNTIL THE- THE CRISIS HAPPENS
AND THEN YOU START REACHING OUT
AND- AND DOING ALL THE STUFF
AND TRYING TO GARNER THAT YOU
AVE TO DO IT EVERY DAY. AND
SO- THEN BILL THAT BILL THAT-
THAT ACCOUNT IF YOU WILL THAT
SAVINGS ACCOUNT OF GOOD WILL
WITH YOUR COMMUNITIES SO ANY
BETTER DO THAT WITH THE TRUTH.
AND THEN YOU KNOW IT'S PAINFUL
THAT IS FOR SOME PEOPLE
SOMETIMES YOU KNOW THAT WOULD
YOU HAVE TO DO YOU HAVE TO GIVE
YOU HAVE TO ADDRESS THE REAL
SITUATIONS THE DATA THAT'S
THERE AND SHARE THE DATA YOU
KNOW. LIKE YOU SUPPORT STUFF
BUT I THINK THAT THE WE HAVE TO
DO THAT WITH OUR WITH OUR
COMMUNITIES AND WE HAVE TO HAVE
FORMAL ENGAGEMENTS WITH THEM.
AND WE HAVE TO ALSO HAVE A LOT
OF THE INFORMAL- RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THEM. IN TERMS OF JUST
GETTING OUT OF THE CAR AND IN
AND MEETING WITH FOLKS. BUT I
THINK IT'S THE JOB OF EVERY G.
I BELIEVE AND THEN AND THEN
THEN. OF MEASURE THE THERE. ARE
DEFINITELY GONNA. ARGUE OUT
THERE. AND IN MEETING WITH THE
PUBLIC N. THE AND THE EXTRA
TIME. WITH THEM- ONE EVEN FOR
CALLS FOR SERVICE YOU KNOW WHEN
THEY CAN I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SOME CITIES ARE MORE IMPACTED
THAN SAY SOMETHING WERE LIKE
LOS ALAMEDA AS- FAR MY OFFICE
IS HAVE THE TIME. THIS IS SPEAK
WITH PEOPLE BUT EVEN GIVEN THAT
TIME SOMETIMES OFFICES DON'T SO
THAT'S WHY IF YOU HAVE THE TIME
TAKE THE TIME. AND I JUST
BELIEVE THAT THAT'S THE BEST
THE BEST YOU CAN BE ON THE AND
THAT AND BE ABLE TO- FAITH THIS
BRINGS AN ARROW THAT ARE COMING
OUR WAY KNOWING THAT. THEY MAY
BE. MISPLACED ENDANGER MAYBE
MISPLACED BUT YOU YOU HAVE TO
UNDER OF WHAT PEOPLE ARE GOING
THROUGH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISSED MAYES. WELL THANK YOU G.
FOR- FOR BEING A PART OF- THIS
TODAY- I WANT TO TALK ABOUT-
ABOUT EDUCATION DUMB AND
TRAINING- JUST A LITTLEBIT WE
HEARD FROM A MISTER ERIC KAHN.
IN REGARDS TO THE AMOUNT OF
TIME- THAT IT TAKES IF IT TO
GET TO GET TRAINED. AT A FEW
MONTHS AGO AXES BY THE
BEGINNING OF THE SUMMER IS ALL
OF THESE THINGS BEGAN TO
ATTEMPT TO BOIL UP- I HAD- MY
FIANCE'S SISTER WHO LIVES IN
AUSTRALIA- SENT ME. A I MEAN
THAT SHE HAD SEEN ONLINE THAT
SAID IT DID IT DID THAT A
COSMETOLOGIST IN CALIFORNIA.
AND HAS HAVE TWICE THE HOURS.
NEEDED THEN THAT A POLICE
OFFICER TO GET POST TRAINING
AND I THOUGHT WELL THAT CAN'T
BE TRUE- AND I REMEMBER LOOKING
IT UP AND IF YOU ACTUALLY SEE
THE NUMBER OF HOURS OF. OF
TRAINING THAT ACTUALLY IS TRUE.
SO I'VE ALSO HEARD FROM MY
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT. THAT
THEY'RE HAVING A DIFFICULT TIME
IN MY TO COUNTIES HAVING A
DIFFICULT TIME. TRYING TO
RECRUIT- NUME THE NEW OFFICERS.
AND SO WE'RE THINKING ABOUT.
TRAINING IN THE AMOUNT OF TIME
TO BE ABLE TO GO THROUGH
THROUGH POST STORE- ARE. IS IT
EVEN. IS IT SOMETHING THAT'S
NECESSARY TO HAVE MORE
EDUCATION DO WE NEED COLLEGE
DEGREES FOR POLICE OFFICERS I
DO WE NEED ASSOCIATE'S DEGREES
FOR OUR POLICE OFFICERS MISTER
ERIC CONTACT ABOUT CRITICAL
THINKING HE TALKED ABOUT THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
DECISIONS VERY VERY QUICKLY-
BUT DOES THERE NEED TO BE MORE
EDUCATION IT IS THE POST
TRADING- SUFFICIENT AND THEN
WHERE THE RESOURCES COME TO BE
ABLE TO. DO THAT EDUCATION AND
TRAINING SO WANTED TO JUST.
HAVE YOU DRESS THAT. YES OKAY
ARE UP BURKE SAY THAT. THAT FOR
THE M. NINE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
HOURS ARE THERE ABOUT FOR- CAFE
MOST OF THEM ARE LIKE GOLDEN
WEST WHERE I- STRUCK THAT- THEY
AVE WELL OVER A THOUSAND HOURS.
HAVING THAT THEY GO THROUGH BY
THE TIME THEY FINISH THEIR SIX
MONTH PROGRAM AND THEN THEY GO
INTO A FIELD TRAINING OFFICER
PROGRAM. WHICH FOR MOST- POLICE
DEPARTMENT AT LEAST THREE
MONTHS- MARC TWELVE WEEKS
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE SOME
AGENCIES THAT WILL REQUIRE SIX
MONTHS ON TOP OF THAT SO.
THERE'S A BODY YEARS SOMETIMES
BETWEEN THE TIME THAT THE
PERSON. IT'S VOTE ON A CASH
UNTIL THEY'RE ACTUALLY ON THEIR
OWN- MAKING DECISIONS AND
DRIVING ALONE IN A IN A POLICE
VEHICLE SO- COULD THERE BE MORE
TRAINING YEAH I CERTAINLY TINK
YOU KNOW IT- SO MANY TIMES THAT
I'VE BEEN EVEN IN MY PROFESSION
WHEN I AND EVEN AS A CHEAT. YOU
KNOW YOU YOU'RE CHEAP FOR A
COUPLE YEARS AND THEN YOU
REALIZE THAT. YOU DON'T KNOW AS
MUCH AS YOU SHOULD KNOW AND YOU
AND THEN THE SAME THING AS AN
OFFICER. YOU KNOW- I THINK IF
YOU LOOK AT THE MILITARY MODEL
I THINK IN AND YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE. YOU HAVE- ENLISTED FOLKS
THAT DON'T REQUIRE- A DEGREE
BUT THOSE PEOPLE THAT ARE
COMMANDER THEM CERTAINLY DO AND
THAT'S WHAT YOU EXPECT- I DON'T
NECESSARILY EXPECT ALL OF OUR
GUYS- TO HAVE COLLEGE DEGREES
COMING IN BECAUSE IT'S NOT A
REQUIREMENT BUT THAT SEEMS LIKE
WE DO GET A NUMBER OF FOLKS
THAT. ARE COLLEGE EDUCATED
BECAUSE YOU'RE ENTERING THE
PROFESSION LATER IN LIFE. AND
DID DECIDE TO GO THROUGH A
CRIMINAL JUSTICE PROGRAM I CAN
TELL YOU THE DIFFERENCE IN THAT
YOU KNOW. THE APPLICATION LOG
VERSES KNOWING THEORETICALLY
WHAT THE LAW SAYS. THERE'S A
HUGE DIFFERENCE AND THAT'S
WHERE THAT THAT ON THE JOB
TRAINING
AND I DON'T THE- FOR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT I'VE BEEN SURE WHAT
WHERE THE YOU KNOW WE'RE- IT'S
NOT THE TIME YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW
IN OUR STATE. IN OR ANYWHERE IN
OUR NATION. WITH WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH THE COVER NINETEEN AND
THEN TO SEE WHAT OUR- REVENUE
STREAMS HAVE BEEN DRYING UP IN
AND- TALK ABOUT THAT
NECESSARILY BUT- HI. I KNOW
THAT THE RE ORDERING OF OUR
TRAINING. IS IMPORTANT IN HAND
KIND OF PRIORITIZING AND I'VE
SEEN POSTS DO THAT- I SPOKE
ABOUT EMOTIONAL INTELLIGENCE
AND- AND- AND I REALLY FEEL
STRONGLY ABOUT THAT I HAD READ
AN ARTICLE THAT WAS PUBLISHED
ON THAT. AND SAYING THAT IT'S A
REQUIRE IT SHOULD BE SOMETHING
THAT'S- REALLY STRICTLY TESTED.
N. M. ELEMENTS OF IT ARE. IN
THE PSYCHOLOGICAL EVALUATION.
BUT IT'S REALLY SOMETHING BIG-
FOR RECRUITMENT BUT- MORE SO
FOR EVEN FOR PROMOTIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES- YEAH I DON'T
KNOW THAT YOU KNOW THEY MAY
HAVE MORE TRAINING YET AND-
BETTING CARE- BUT I DON'T KNOW.
IF IT'S BECAUSE THEY NEED MORE
HOURS FOR THEIR TRAINING- TO
LEARN THAT TOPIC BUT YOU KNOW
YEAH- CERTAINLY- YOU KNOW THE
IT. I GUESS BE AT THE LEVEL OF.
A YOU KNOW AND I. THINK GERAKAN
WOULD TALKING YOU KNOW LIKE
BEING IN A- IN THAT. HAVE GONE
TO LAW SCHOOL. THE AMOUNT OF
CRUDE LAW THE NOW. WITH COVER.
IN THEIR SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
IT'S PROBABLY THAT TO OUR THAN
MAYBE SOME OF GOING TO GETTING
TO A LOT. YOU KNOW AND SO THERE
IS A VERY. FORM OF LEARNING.
AND THERE ARE CERTAIN CAST YOU
THEY HAVE TO HAVE TO BE HAD.
AND THAT'S WHY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AS A IS SUCH A COMPLICATED-
PROFESSION. IT IS COMPLEX IS A
LOT OF THINGS THAT THEY HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO DO. AND NOW WITH
MENTAL HEALTH WOULD ALMOST BET
THERE'S AND YOU JUST ON ADDING
THE THINGS THAT OFFICERS HAVE
TO HAVE A WIDE RANGE. OF
UNDERSTANDING AND. AND ALSO
COMPASSION FOR. MAKE A CHIEF
NEW IF I CAN JUSTIFY UP IS IT
OPINION THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
REFER WITH WITHIN THE EDUCATION
AND TRAINING. DOES THERE NEED
TO BE MORE QUALITY OF TRAINING.
I DO THINK THAT ANYTIME WE CAN
DO MORE- STIMULATION TYPE
TRAINING THEN THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
DOING WITH THE S. B. T. THIRTY-
YEAH SO YOU'RE NOT ONLY DEALING
WITH THE ESCALATION. ISSUES BUT
YOU'RE ALSO DEALING WITH. THAT
KIND OF A MORE OF A REAL. TIME
REAL EFFECT AND THEN THE
SCENARIO BASED TYPE TRAINING- I
THINK THOSE ARE- THOSE ARE
GREAT BECAUSE I MEAN. THAT'S
WHAT WE HAVE TO SEE ABOUT THE
APPLICATION OF WHAT THEY'RE
DOING- VERSUS WHAT THEY KNOW IN
THEIR HEAD BECAUSE THAT THOSE
ARE THE THINGS THAT REQUIRE. A
CERTAIN AND THAT'S WHAT ABOUT
THAT MOST ACCOUNTS THAT THEY
HAVE TO USE THAT EMOTIONAL
INTELLIGENCE. FIFTY ESCALATE
RIGHT SO I THINK THAT IF THE IF
AND I THINK THE CURRENT
PRIORITIZE NATION. OF THAT
TRAINING INTERCHANGING
LEGISLATION. THEM THROUGH I
NEED FIFTEEN. REQUESTED FROM
YOU HAVE. THE CHIEFS AND
SHERIFFS TV. THROUGH POST-
WHETHER A COMPANY BE A- I
CALLED LEVEL EDUCATED PERSON
I'VE DON'T KNOW. BELIEVE SO
CERTAINLY- CRITICAL THANK YOU
TO HELP YOU KNOW HAVING A
DAUGHTER IN COLLEGE. STILL
WAITING FOR HER TO MAKE THEIR
CALLS. BECAUSE THE CRITICAL
THING I MEAN THE BUDGET BUT- I
DON'T SEE YOU KNOW I DON'T
NECESSARILY KNOW EFFECTS WHAT'S
BEINGPROVIDED BUT- BUT I CAN
CERTAINLY BUT I CAN CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND. THE NEED FOR. MORE
EDUCATION AND THEN HELP THE
BETTER FRAME PROBLEMS. THE MORE
EDUCATION YOU HAVE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALSO MAY ONE OF YOUR
TO WE STILL HAVE THAT. 2% STILL
AWAITING SO ANYONE HAS. FOR I
TO RELEASE THOSE INDIVIDUALS SO
THEY CAN GO OKAY MISS. RB K.
HAS QESTIONS FOR OUR PREVIOUS-
SPEAKERS SO NEXT UP WE HAVE MR
GABRIEL WE HAVE MISTER MCCARTY
AND WE ALSO HAVE R. B. K. AFTER
THAT. YES YES. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I'VE
CLEARLY ON THE SAME WAY THAT
WAVE LIKE TODAY'S MY COLLEAGUE
FROM PALM SPRINGS I HAD. VERY
MUCH THE SAME QUESTIONS- I
FOUND MR ALI KHAN'S COMMENTS
ABOUT EDUCATION AND TRAINING TO
BE EXTREMELY THOUGHT PROVOKING
AND- CHIEF WAS GOING TO ASK YOU
THE SAME THE SAME QUESTIONS
THAT MY COLLEAGUE DID SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON
THIS- WOULD ACTUALLY IF WE CAN.
LIKE TO GET MISTER ALI KHAN'S
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS- ON ON
EDUCATION AND TRAINING- YOU
KNOW CERTAINLY THINKING ABOUT
THE DIVERSITY OF SITUATIONS
THAT WE PUT OUR OFFICERS IN
THE- THE THIS THAT THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE ASK THEM TO
RESPOND TO- THE BURDENS THAT WE
PUT ON THEM- AND THEN THINKING
ABOUT MY OWN TRAINING AS AS AN
ATTORNEY WHAT I HAD TO GO
THROUGH BOTH EDUCATIONALLY AND
WITH THE BAR EXAM AND HOW-
CHALLENGING IT WAS AT THE
BEGINNING BEING A YOUNG LAWYER
IN TRYING TO. DEAL WITH THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT YOU DEAL
WITH- YOU KNOW WHEN YOUR FIRST
COUPLE YEARS OF LAW PRACTICE-
SOME OF WHICH YOU LEARN IN LAW
SCHOOL MANY OF WHICH YOU DON'T
AND THEN THINK ABOUT HOW MUCH
MORE CHALLENGING IT IS TO BE AN
OFFICER IN THE FIELD AND WHAT
THEY HAVE TO RESPOND TO SO. I'M
JUST JUST CURIOUS YOU KNOW TO
GET YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON THESE
ISSUES DO YOU THINK WE NEED.
STRONGER EDUCATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS TO BECOME AN
OFFICER DO YOU THINK THAT THERE
ARE NO CHANGES WE SHOULD MAKE
TO THE TRAINING AND EDUCATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS AND THEN GIVING
YOUR VANTAGE POINT HAVING
WORKED WITH. A LOT OF AGENCIES
ACROSS ACROSS THE COUNTRY BOTH
AT THE FEDERAL THE STATE LEVEL
OR THEIR AGENCIES THAT DO
TRAINING. REALLY WELL AND
MODELS THAT WE CAN LOOK TO HEAR
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO
JUST WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
THOUGHTS AND- AND ALSO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE. TO THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES APPRECIATED
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SO MANY
MEMBER- TO ANSWER QUESTIONED.
TO THE- THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
UP EDUCATIONAL STANDARDS I DO
BELIEVE THAT WOULD BE
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. WHAT YOU SEE IN
CALIFORNIA AND ELSEWHERE IS THE
MANY DEPARTMENTS WILL. CREATE
INCENTIVES TO HAVE. OFFICERS
WITH HIGHER EDUCATION BEFORE
THEY JOINED THE ACADEMY.
THEY'LL PROVIDE. ADDITIONAL
STEPS IN IN SALARY. AND ALSO
SOME DEPARTMENTS WILL HAVE-
EDUCATIONAL. REQUIREMENTS FOR
PROMOTION- AN ASSOCIATE'S
DEGREE OR AT LEAST SOME
CREDITS- SOMETIMES EVEN A
MASTER'S DEGREE- DEPENDING ON
THE AGENCY. I THINK THE
CHALLENGES THOUGH. THOSE
REQUIREMENTS ARE INCUMBENT UPON
THE INDIVIDUAL AGENCY TO DO IT.
IT'S NOT A STANDARD IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S UNIFORM
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. AND I
THINK THAT'S DIFFICULT BECAUSE
WE EXPECT. ALL OFFICERS TO ACT.
WITH THE SAME STANDARDS OF
CARE. THE SAME STANDARDS IN
USING FORCE AND THAT DECISION
MAKING CAPABILITY. I ALSO
BELIEVE AS I THINK I MENTIONED
AYE COMMENTS THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN TRAINING.
AND EDUCATION. TRAINING IS
ABOUT SKILLS TEACHING OFFICER
HOW TO DRAW OTHER WEAPON AND
FIRE IT ACCURATELY. TEACHING
OFFICERS HOW TO GET IT IN HIGH
PRECISION DRIVING. THINGS THAT
I ACTUALLY LEARNED IN THE LAPD
RESERVE ACADEMY AND I WAS
ASTONISHED AT HOW WELL. I WAS
ABLE TO DO IN A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME BECAUSE OF THE QUALITY OF
THE INSTRUCTION. OF THOSE
SKILLS. BUT CRITICAL THINKING
AND DECISION MAKING. IS MUCH
MORE COMPLICATED ESPECIALLY
DEALING WITH THE COMPLEX
CITIES. OF DEALING WITH.
COMPLEX SOCIAL BEHAVIOR.
DEALING WITH CRIME. DEALING
WITH SOMEBODY WHO'S GOING
THROUGH MENTAL HEALTH CRISES.
AND WE WOULDN'T EXPECT. A
LAWYER. WHO HAD NEVER GONE TO
LAW SCHOOL OR STUDY THOSE
THINGS TO ALL OF A SUDDEN GO.
AND BE AN ADVOCATE FOR
SOMEBODY. OFF ON MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES BUT YET WE EXPECT POLICE
OFFICERS TO DO THAT. AND I JUST
THINK IT PUTS THEM IN SUCH A
DIFFICULT POSITION. TO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH ALL OF THESE ISSUES.
IN LITERALLY LIFE AND DEATH
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE. WE DON'T
EVEN HAVE AS A STANDARD AND
ENGAGE THEM TO TEACH THAT
CRITICAL THINKING SKILL. AND
ONE OTHER ASPECT OF IT AS WELL.
MUCH OF THIS IS NOT THE FAULT
OF THE DEPARTMENTS POLICE
DEPARTMENTS AND POLICE
ACADEMIES ARE TYPICALLY- THE
INSTRUCTORS ARE POLICE OFFICERS
OR FORMER POLICE OFFICERS WHICH
WE WANT IN MANY OF THE SKILLS
BASED ISSUES. BUT WHEN IT COMES
TO TEACHING PEOPLE HOW TO
CRITICALLY THINK- USING
CRITICAL ANALYSIS AND
EXERCISING GOOD JUDGMENT YOU
REALLY DO WANT TO HAVE
PROFESSIONAL EDUCATORS PEOPLE
COME FROM DIFFERENT DISCIPLINES
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES.
DIFFERENT TALENTS TO TEACH
THOSE SKILLS AND OFTEN TIMES
THAT'S NOT WITHIN THE RESOURCES
OF A POLICE DEPARTMENT OR
POLICE ACADEMY AND THEY OFTEN
HAVE TO USE OTHER POLICE
OFFICERS TO TEACH THOSE VERY
DIFFICULT SUBJECTS. AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING ALSO
STRUCTURALLY THAT THE STATE
SHOULD LOOK AT TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT I JUST- JUST IF I MAY
MISTER TERRA COMMENT ON WHICH I
THINK ARE CALLING FROM PALM
SPRINGS ALSO MENTION ONE THAT
YOU BRING UP WHICH IS WHICH IS
THE QUESTION OF RESOURCES IT
WAS VERY AYE AYE OPENING FOR
ME- TWO YEARS AGO I HAD A BILL.
ON THE ISSUE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
TRAINING FOR GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS AND JUST
GETTING INTO THE WEEDS WITH
POST AND SEEING HOW THAT THE
COST ESTIMATES FOR TRAINING. ON
HOW EXPENSIVE IT CAN BE TO
TRAIN LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THE IN
THIS ONE PERSON AROUND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. YOU KNOW
WE ALTERNATELY HOW TO SCALE
THAT BILL BACK BECAUSE OF COST
AND SO. I JUST WANT TO BE
MINDFUL OF THE FACT THAT WE YOU
KNOW WE HAVE REALLY HIGH
EXPECTATIONS OF OUR OFFICERS
AND YET SOMETIMES IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT WORK. YOU KNOW I'M
GOING TO MAKE IT THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE NEED TO
PROVIDE THEM WITH THE TRAINING
THAT THEY THAT THEY NEED FOR
THE DIFFICULT ON TALENT IS THAT
THEY ENCOUNTER SO I THINK THAT.
AS WE LOOK AT THIS TOPIC OF
POLICE REFORM I THINK WE NEED
TO IT TO BE WILLING TO PUT OUR
MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH IS- AND
BE WILLING TO INVEST IN IN
PROVIDING- OFFICERS WITH WITH
THE TRAINING AND THE EDUCATION
THAT I THINK YOU'VE SUGGESTED
TO US COULD MAKE A REALLY BIG
DIFFERENCE HERE SO I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THIS. COMMITTEE
TO KEEP IN MIND OBVIOUSLY WE
FACE EXTRAORDINARY BUDGET
CHALLENGES BUT BUT THIS IS
THESE ARE CRITICAL ISSUES LIFE
AND DEATH ISSUES THAT YOU
MENTIONED AND SO I THINK THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT THING THAT WE
OUGHT TO. KEEP IN THE BACK OF
OUR MINDS AS WE HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT IT WILL HAVE
MISTER MCCARTY- WE ALSO
INTRODUCTION SO YOU CAN.
INTRODUCE HIMSELF AS WELL AS
**** QUESTION AT THIS POINT.
WELL THANK YOU. FOR THAT KIND
INTRODUCTION SO. I THINK I'M-
GOOD WITH THAT- I WANT TO ASK
EITHER- THE CHIEF OR PROFESSOR
ALL THE CON. ABOUT THE
EDUCATION ISSUE I KNOW THAT. MR
GABRIEL AND- SO MEMORY MAYES
MENTION THIS ALREADY. YOU KNOW.
WE HAD A TRAGEDY LAST YEAR
WEREN'T YOUNG OFFICER TARA
SOLOMON. WAS GUNNED DOWN HERE
IN SACRAMENTO. TWO TWENTY SIX
YEARS OLD AND AT HER FUNERAL.
AND TO PRAY THE UNIVERSITY AND
THE POLICE CHIEF TALKED ABOUT
HOW SHE WAS WHEN SHE WAS IN
THIS ACADEMY AT SAC STATE SHE
DECIDED SHE WANTED TO MAJOR IN
PSYCHOLOGY. AND CHILD
DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE SHE SAID
ALL LEARN ALL THIS TALK ABOUT
BEING A POLICE OFFICER IN
TACTICAL. IN THE ACADEMY AND I
JUST THOUGHT WHAT A BRILLIANT
YOUNG WOMAN OBVIOUSLY SHE WAS
TRAGICALLY. GUNNED DOWN BUT I
WONDER. IF THAT'S A QUESTION
BECAUSE IF OFFICERS ARE DOING
SO MUCH. WITH THE YOU KNOW
PEOPLE AND JUST YOU KNOW HUMAN
ISSUES ON HE COMMUNITY AND
MENTAL AND MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
YOU KNOW MAYBE THE REQUIREMENT
SHOULDN'T BE A CRIMINAL JUSTICE
DEGREE IF THERE IS A
REQUIREMENT. MAYBE IT SHOULD
BE- PSYCHOLOGY OR HUMAN
DEVELOPMENT OR CHILD DEVELOP OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT SO. HAS
THAT EVER BEEN THOUGHT OF IF
THERE EVER IS AN EDUCATION
REQUIREMENT TO HAVE NOT
NECESSARILY CRIMINAL JUSTICE
BECAUSE YOU'LL LEARN THAT IN
THE ACADEMY MAYBE NOT AS MANY
HOURS AS- AS SHOULD BE AND YOU
LEARN THAT THROUGH THE SCOPE OF.
YOUR EMPLOYMENT BUT YOU KNOW
SHOULD WE LOOK AT OTHER ASPECTS
OF WHAT. YOU KNOW. PEOPLE DEAL
WITH IN REAL LIFE IN THE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S QUESTION.
ONE THE QUESTIONS FOR MR OR IS
THAT A QUESTION EITHER ME OR
SOME MORE- OKAY SIR WHO TALKED
ABOUT EDUCATION EITHER ONE CAN
ANSWER THAT QUESTION HOW MY
NEXT THREE QUESTIONS WILL BE
FOR THE CHIEF. YEAH OKAY SO LET
ME LET ME TAKE A SHOT AT IT
BEFORE THE CHIEF DOES I BELIEVE
THAT HAVING A DIVERSE
EDUCATIONAL WORK FOR A
WORKFORCE WITH DIVERSE
EDUCATION WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL- I DO THINK THERE
SHOULD BE SOME REQUIREMENTS
THAT THEY HAVE IN TERMS OF
UNDERSTANDING THE LAW IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM BUT
HAVING THAT DIVERSITY OF
PSYCHOLOGY AND OTHER OTHER-
EDUCATIONAL BACKGROUNDS WOULD
DEFINITELY BE USEFUL BECAUSE
POLICING AS AS AS AN INDIVIDUAL
AND AS AN INSTITUTION IS ABOUT
TRYING TO SOLVE. PROBLEMS IN
HAVING THAT DIVERSITY OF
BACKGROUNDS I THINK IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. JUST AS
DIVERSITY OF ETHNICITY CULTURE
BACK IT'S AND THERE IS- THERE
IS AN EXAMPLE OF THIS WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE FBI WHICH OF COURSE
IS VERY DIFFERENT IN TERMS OF
THEM BEING A LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY THEY'RE NOT RESPONDING
TO NINE ONE ONE CALLS OR THESE
CRISIS SITUATIONS BUT THEY
CERTAINLY ARE A GOOD EXAMPLE OF
ON THEIR INVESTIGATIVE COULD BE
CAPABILITIES IN DEALING WITH
COMPLEX ISSUES AND THEY VERY
MUCH EMPHASIZE NOT JUST HAVING
A COLLEGE EDUCATION BUT ALSO A
GRADUATE DEGREE OR OTHER
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE. AND
THEY DELIBERATELY RECRUIT FROM
A BROAD ARRAY OF DISCIPLINES
FROM MEDICINE TO LAWYERS TO
ACCOUNTANTS TO- PSYCHOLOGY AND
I THINK THAT WOULD BENEFIT
POLICE DEPARTMENTS IF THERE
WERE TO EMPHASIZE THIS ISSUE OF
CRITICAL THINKING CRITICAL AND
DECISION MAKING AND EXERCISING
JUDGMENT- IN THE ROLE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WERE HAVE RB
K. AT NOTHING IF I GET. HOMES
ARE MORE QUESTIONS YES AND I'M
NOT SURE TO THE CHIEF WANTED TO
ADD UPON THAT AS WELL. I THE
ONLY THING I. I DO THINK THAT
THE PRESIDENT SPEAKING ABOUT I
THINK THAT SOMETIMES AS WELL
BACKGROUND. ON THE- I GET THE
MORE VERSATILE OR DIVERSIFIED
THAT SOMEONE CAN BE IN THEIR-
THEIR EDUCATIONAL BACKGROUND
SOMETIMES- BRINGS FORTH THE
ABILITY TO LIKE I SAID BEFORE.
TO WELL TO CRITICALLY EVALUATE
THE SITUATION BUT TO ACTUALLY
BE ABLE TO THE FRAME PROBLEMS.
IN A DIFFERENT WAY THAT MAYBE
SOMEBODY THAT ONLY HAD- YOU
KNOW A PROFESSION SPECIFIC
LIKE- CRIMINAL JUSTICE-
MINISTRATION JUSTICE
BACKGROUND. WHICH DEALS WITH
THE WHOLE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND NOT NECESSARILY.
WITH THE CALL FOR SERVICE THAT
THAT HAND WITH THE HUMAN
CONTACT THAT YOU'RE DEALING
WITH. AT THAT MOMENT AND- SO
SOME OF THOSE OTHER KIND OF-
DEGREES- DO A PORT AND- PEOPLE
THAT THE I GUESS THE GREATER
EFFECTIVENESS. SOMETIMES. IN
CERTAIN GIVEN SITUATIONS. OKAY
THANK YOU AND I HEAR WHAT WHAT
CITY ARE YOU FROM AGAIN. FROM
THE CITY OF LOS ALL MEET WITH
THE NORTH COUNTY OKAY THANK YOU
SO I HAVE A FEW FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS FOR YOU FROM YOUR-
POSITION AS THE CHIEF OF LOS
ALAMEDA ST FROM YOUR POSITION
WITH THE STATE ASSOCIATION SO.
FROM ASSOCIATION OF COURSE WE
HAVE HUNDREDS OF POLICE
DEPARTMENT SO YOU DON'T KNOW
ALL OF THEM WHAT'S HAPPENING
BUT JUST WANT TO ASK OVERALL
THE LAST I GUESS YEAR AND A
HALF- SINCE WE'VE- HAD THE BILL
INTO INTO A FACT AB THREE NINE
TWO- THAT YOU KNOW THAT DEADLY
FOR STANDARDS AND USE OF FORCE
THAT WAS OF COURSE A- BIG LIFT
THE LEGISLATURE MONUMENTAL-
POSITION AT THE END THAT BECAME
LAW. AND I THINK THE LAW WAS
ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY BUT ALSO
PREVENTION IN THE FIRST PLACE
AND TRYING TO PREVENT INCIDENTS
OF DEADLY FORCE AND LOOKING AT
THE NUMBERS IT LOOKS LIKE IN
THE LAST YEAR WE HAVE HAD
FEWER. OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTINGS IN CALIFORNIA BUT
JUST WANTED IF YOU CAN- TALK
ABOUT WHAT'S BEEN HAPPENING AT
POLICE DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE EVEN YOURS. IN
TRAINING AND DE ESCALATION
EFFORTS AND WHAT WE ARE DOING.
TO PREVENT THESE IN THE FIRST
PLACE. YEAH WE- I THINK YOU'RE
CORRECT THAT THINK THE-
OBVIOUSLY THE- THREE NINETY
TWO- WAS A WAS A HEAVY LIFT FOR
EVERYBODY. AND GETTING THAT
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE IF YOU
WILL BUT- YEAH BUT IT WAS- WELL
CRAFTED AND- DID PROVIDE THE
STRUCTURE. THAT THAT WE NEEDED
TO HAVE FOR OUR STATE. AND I
THINK THAT- AND DEFINING YOU
KNOW USE OF FORCE IN DEFINING
THE DEADLY. USES OF FORCE AND
IT IT WAS. I WHAT ANYTIME YOU
CREATE LEGISLATION LIKE THAT
THAT KIND OF MAGNITUDE. IT
CHANGES POLICY OBVIOUSLY AND IT
ALSO CHANGES ALL WHICH HELPS TO
CHANGE- PROBABLY CULTURE A
LITTLE BIT. AT LEAST IN THE
INSTRUCTIONAL PHASE OF YOU KNOW
WHAT THESE POLICIES IN THE
LEGISLATION. ARE IDENTIFYING
AND I THINK. I THINK IF YOU
LOOK AT- THE USE OF FORCE IN
GENERAL LIKE- AS YOU INDICATED
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS THAT
WE WERE IMPORTING TO THE- DOJ
THAT YOU KNOW CREATING SERIOUS
INJURY OR DEATH- THAT THEY'VE
ALL BEEN REDUCED AND I THINK
THAT'S PART OF THAT IS. IS TO
THAT TRAINING I THINK IF WE
KEEP THIRTY EVEN THOUGH IT
DOESN'T FULLY COME INTO EFFECT
UNTIL- JANUARY- I THINK A LOT
OF US HAVE ALREADY. DROPPED THE
STATE A HAVE A HAVE CHANGE OUR
POLICIES ON DE ESCALATION AND
THEN ALL THE VERBIAGE AND ALL
THE WORDING THAT SUPPOSED TO BE
IN THERE- BY THAT DATE R. AS IN
THERE I KNOW THAT'S- TRUE ABOUT
MY POLICY. IN MY DEPARTMENT AND
WE'VE ALREADY GIVEN THAT POLICY
OUT WE'VE ALREADY HAD TRAINING
ON THAT SO. THAT OUR OFFICERS
ARE HIRING TRAINING ON THE
POLICY ITSELF WE'RE GETTING SET
UP HERE IN THE NEXT MONTH OR
TWO I BELIEVE IN NOVEMBER WE'RE
GOING TO BE. DOING THE FORMAL
TRAINING WERE WAITING PROPOSED
TO COME OUT WITH THE SIMULATORS
TO HELP US WITH THAT TRAINING-
BUT- WHAT ARE YOU KNOW I DO.
THAT I THINK. I THINK WHAT IT
DOES IS IT BRINGS EVERYTHING TO
THE POOR. AND MAY CAUSE PEOPLE
TO. NOT ONLY CHANGE LIKE I SAID
THEIR POLICIES BUT CHANGED- YOU
KNOW. THEIR CULTURE PERHAPS AND
IN THE WAY THAT THEY VIEW
pACTUALLY CARRY OUT THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES. OKAY THANK
YOU THAT THAT'S CERTAINLY THE
HOPE AND YOU KNOW WHY I FIRST
THAT MEASURE OUT WE ALL ADOPTED
TWO YEARS AGO. I WENT TO- JEFF
NOW ON INCIDENTS WHERE THERE
IS. A DEADLY FORCE AND WHERE
THERE IS AN INVESTIGATION. IT'S
EXTREMELY COMPLICATED AND YOU
KNOW. THE PERCEIVED WHETHER OR
NOT IT'S A LEGAL CONFLICT OF
INTEREST THE APPS ABSOLUTE.
PERCEIVED CONFLICT WHEN- POLICE
ESSENTIALLY POLICE THEMSELVES
AND DO THE INVESTIGATIONS A
LARGE PART OF WHY I DID THE
BILL LISTS PAST YEAR THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED ON THE PEN
DESTINATIONS. BUT THERE'S
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT CAME UP
TALKING TO SOME POLICE CHIEFS
AND I WANTED TO ASK IF YOU
COULD TALK ABOUT IT- ABOUT
THREE WEEKS AGO THERE WAS AN
OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTING IN MY
DISTRICT IN WEST SACRAMENTO.
ACTUALLY WON THE FIRST TWO
INNINGS AND WESTPAC IN TWENTY
YEARS. AND YOU KNOW BY ALL
ACCOUNTS THE IT WAS A- KIND OF
A SUICIDE BY COP THE OFFICERS-
YOU KNOW. WE'RE DOING THEIR JOB
AND HAD TO RESPOND ACCORDINGLY
AND THE INVESTIGATION THAT
STARTED THE VERY NEXT DAY. I
READ AND I AND I HEARD ABOUT I
JUST THOUGHT WELL THIS PROBABLY
SHOULD BE BUT ALL POLICE
DEPARTMENTS DO. THEY HAD AN
ADJACENT CITY THE CITY OF DAVIS
BEING THE LEAD INVESTIGATOR OR
FOR THAT OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTING WHEN THERE'S A
FATALITY- BECAUSE THERE IS
THIS. CONFLICT AND WHETHER IT'S
REAL AGAIN IT'S THIS PERCEPTION
THE COMMUNITY WHERE YOU KNOW
THE PERSON YOU'RE WORKING WITH
IS INVESTIGATING YOUR BODY AND
IF SOMEONE YOU WORKED WITH AND
JUST HOW HOW DO YOU HAVE THAT.
INDEPENDENCE AND TRANSPARENCY.
AND KIND OF A DISTANCE AND
WHILE THE ADJACENT AGENCY MAYBE
THERE HAVE SOME KNOWLEDGE
THERE'S A LITTLE SEPARATION
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENT. SO I
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE FEW
CITIES. ACROSS CALIFORNIA HAVE
THESE- POLICIES SO MY QUESTION
SHE DO. YOU THINK THAT'S A GOOD
IDEA I SHOULD ALL POLICE TO.
HAVE THESE DEMO. WERE YOU HAVE
YOU KNOW THE CITY OF. SAN DIEGO
HAVING WITH THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO OR- LA AND- THE COUNTY
THE SHERIFF FOR LONG BEACH
UNLESS ALAMEDA US. HAVEN'T HAVE
AN ARRANGEMENT WE HAVE AN
ADJACENT CITY. BE THE LEAD ON
AN OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTING
WHETHER IS A FATALE DAY. YEAH
SEVEN I'M I'M ACTUALLY KIND OF
BIASED ON THIS SITUATION ONLY
BECAUSE IN ORANGE COUNTY WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF THE CITY OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH- ALL OF OUR
OFFICER OF ALL SHOOTINGS ARE
INVESTIGATED BY THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND THERE'S
SPECIALIZED UNIT- ABOUT CIVIL
SHOOTING UNIT THAT- THEY CALL
THAT THE ROLLOUT TEAM TO COME
OUT. TO THAT AND IF YOU AND I
THINK ONE- THE- DOJ AT- CAL
DOJA DONE- LOOK AT ALL OF THE
SHOOTING THAT HAPPENED IN
CALIFORNIA WHOSE LARGEST TOP
TEN PEOPLE THAT DIDN'T YOU KNOW
LIVED AT THE GATE HEARINGS I
THINK LORD COUNTY VA WAS NUMBER
ONE ONLY BECAUSE THEY
INVESTIGATE ALL THE CITIES
WITHIN ORANGE COUNTY. I NEED TO
BE TO ACTUALLY USE THAT THE
SHERIFF'S BUT THE TERRORISTS
WERE INVOLVED IN THE IN THAT
SITUATION THEY USE THE DA'S
OFFICE SO- I'M NOT SURE WHY
THEY DON'T USE THE DA'S OFFICE
BUT- I DO THINK THAT THERE IS-
BECAUSE THE IT. I DO THINK THAT
ONE IS IT CREATES A SEPARATION
AND ALLOWS FOR- YOU KNOW THAT
LIKE YOU SAID EVEN IF YOUR
NEIGHBORING AGENCY THERE'S
ALWAYS GONNA BE A LITTLE BIT
SOMEBODY THINKING THAT YOU KNOW
THAT IT NEW OR WHAT THAT IS-
IMPARTIAL AS THEY CAN BE BUT-
AND THAT'S ALWAYS A CONCERN
EVEN WITH THE AID THEY
CONCERNED THE KIDS ARE
PROSECUTING THE THEY WANT TO
PROSECUTE COPS I THINK THEY
WANT TO PROSECUTE PEOPLE THAT
COMMIT YOU KNOW CRIMES. AND
ANAHIT COPIES COMMITTEE CRIME
THEY WILL FALL THROUGH THE
PROSECUTION BUT- SO AND I AM
AWARE OF THE NUMBER OF- I CAN'T
THINK OF MY POP MY HEAD BUT I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE AGENCIES
THAT ARE NOW CREATING THESE
REVITALIZED UNITS WHERE THEY'RE
USING OFFICERS ON THEM LIKE
WITH A GROUP OF POLICE
DEPARTMENTS- TO DO A KIND OF A
ROLLOUT TEAM IF YOU WILL TO
INVESTIGATE OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTINGS. AND IN THAT THE- IT
IF IT'S THEIR AGENCY THAT'S
INVOLVED THEN THEY THEN
OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE ACCUSED THEIR.
INVESTIGATORS FROM BEING PART
OF THAT THERE UNITS I THINK IT
IS I THINK IT IS. THAT YOU KNOW
I CAN'T SPEAK FOR THE LAW YOU
CAN AS THEY YOU MENTIONED HAVE
YOU GOING UNIONIST KERR.
DEPARTMENT BECAUSE I KNOW THE
THEY HAVE TO LARGE THE PARK
DEALING HAVE CAN'T. FEET
WORKING AT POSSIBLE THE THAT
THAT BY FOR K. OF THE UNIT.
THERE NOT MIXED IN WITH A WHOLE
LOT OF THE- YOU KNOW THE
GENERAL. IF YOU WILL THE FOLKS
ARE WORKING OF LONG. SO BUT-
BUT I KNOW FOR A LOT OF THE
OTHER AGENT IS YEAH YOU YEAH I
THINK IT'S A GREAT IDEA AND-
AND I THINK THE- THE IDEA OF
YOU KNOW I'M GETTING YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY CAL CHIEFS WANTED. TO
HAVE THE- OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL INVESTIGATE- THOSE
THOSE KINDS OF CASES THAT ARE
REQUEST AND NOW IT'S YOU KNOW
MANDATORY FOR THEM TO DO- BUT-
YOU KNOW SO BUT THAT WAS IT WAS
FOR THE PROBABLY THE SAME
PURPOSES THAT YOU'RE DESCRIBING
NOW. SHARE THAT JUST JUST TO
CLARIFY IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
THAT THE THAT THE SECOND PART
WITH THE AG COMES IN BECAUSE
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN BUT- THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OR IDA THEY
HAVE TO RECEIVE THE INITIAL
WORK FROM A POLICE DEPARTMENT.
AND THOSE FIRST STEPS AND SO.
THE MORE TRANSPARENCY
INDEPENDENCE THE BETTER LIKE.
THE EXAMPLE RECENTLY IN VALLEJO
WHERE THEY HAD THAT. SHOOTING
WHEN THEY OFFICERS SHOT FROM
THE BACK OF THE PICKUP TRUCK
WITH THEIR- YOU KNOW THE
THOUGHT POLICE ISSUED ASSAULT
RIFLE AND SHOT THROUGH THE
WINDSHIELD AND VERY
QUESTIONABLE IN THE COMMUTING
VALLEJO. AND THEN THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT YOU KNOW DESTROYED
THE WINDSHIELD AND SO YOU KNOW
THERE'S- SO HAVING AN OUTSIDE.
POLICE DEPARTMENT- YOU KNOW BE
THE LEAD CERTAINLY ALLOWS
WHETHER IT'S THAT SOLANO COUNTY
DA OR IF THEY HAD IT UP TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE. JUST
TO HAVE- YOU KNOW. MORE MORE
CLARITY IN MORE TRANSPARENT.
INVESTING THAT THEY HAVE TO
TAKEOVERS. I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS THERE AND I WOULD HOPE
THAT THE- WHAT CITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WOULD DO ON THEIR
OWN IF THE IF NOT THE STATE YOU
KNOW POTENTIALLY SHOULD LOOK
INTO THAT. HONEST ABOUT THIS
MCCARTY YEP I'M SORRY. WE WILL.
THIS IS A LONG DISCUSS AND IT
WE WANT TO WE HAVE ONE MORE
PERSON Q. WE HAVE R. B. K. THIS
HEARINGS POST AND AT TWELVE
NOON WE STILL HAVE PRESENTERS
ARE STILL WAITING TO PRESENT.
AND SO I WOULD ASK MEMBERS IF
YOU CAN JUST- PATEL'S. HOLD
YOUR QUESTIONS UNTIL AFTER ALL
THE PRESENTERS HAS HAVE
ACTUALLY HAD OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT WE'RE GOING TO EXTEND
THE TIME TO ONE O'CLOCK. AS
WELL ALL MEMBERS TO BE MINDFUL
OF THAT BECAUSE WE ARE JUST ON
THE FIRST- PRESENTS PRESENTERS
AND SO WE WANT TO BE MINDFUL OF
THE ONES ARE WAITING SO. YOU
HAVE A FINAL THOUGHT BEFORE WE
MOVE ON YEAH I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE LOOK AT
REFORM IN LARGE. DEFEATS THAT'S
MISSING IS THE CHIEF LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE HAVE THE- THAT
ADVOCATES WANT REFORMS WE NEED
TO UNDERSTAND. YOU KNOW WHAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT THINKS ABOUT
HOW YOU CAN DO THESE THINGS AND
SO POINT TO GET ANSWERS SO FAR
MY LAST ONE CHEAP. I KNOW WE'RE
NOT MAKING LOSS TODAY BUT
DURING YOUR- DURING YOUR
PRESENTATION YOU MENTION ON THE
DECERTIFICATION PIECE THAT. YOU
THINK IT'S GOOD TO HAVE THAT IN
CALIFORNIA. YOU DON'T WANT TO
MISS YOU DON'T WANT TO- YOU
KNOW SIDE STEP- WHAT WE'VE
ALREADY PUT INTO LAW SO CAN YOU
JUST BRIEFLY TALK ABOUT WHAT
WHAT WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY THAT
SO WHAT TYPE AT. A
DECERTIFICATION PROCESS SHOULD
CALIFORNIA HAVE THAT WOULD BE
RESPECTFUL OF YOU SAID-
EXISTING CHANGES TO LAW AND
THAT'S. MY FINAL QUESTION. YEAH
I'LL BE BRIEF ON THE ONLY
BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE-
COLLABORATING WITH THE- SOME OF
THE- LEGISLATOR AND THEN SOME
OF THE LAW ENFORCEMENT-
GROUP'S. LEADERSHIPGROUPS ON
ON WHAT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
AND THEN THEN WHAT I MEANT BY
THAT THERE IS. YOU KNOW WE HAVE
KHOBAR THE PEACE OFFICER BILL
OF RIGHTS AND WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF. YOU KNOW OTHER ISSUES THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE AND IT'S ALL OF YOU.
ARE WHERE IS IT THE CONCEPT OF
THE CERTIFICATION. IS THE RIGHT
CONCEPT FOR CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION IT'S THE
DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS ON HOW
THAT ACTUALLY OCCURS IN WHO
GETS T THE OVERSIGHT. AND GETS
THAN WHAT THAT WHAT LEVEL OF
YOU KNOW MISCONDUCT ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT. AND SO ALL OF
THOSE ISSUES THEY HAVE TO BE
KIND OF. A HAMMERED OUT AND
FIGURED OUT THE AND- AND TO
PROTECT YOU KNOW PROTECT THE
OFFICERS PROTECT ORGANIZATIONS
UNSERVED AND ELEGANT OF POLICE
AGENCIES. AS WELL AS THE
COMMUNITY AND SO- IN OUR
BIGGEST THING IS MAKING SURE
THAT THAT THAT THE THERE IS YOU
KNOW THE RETENTION OF BAD
POLICE OFFICERS DID NOT OCCUR
NOR DO THEY GET PASSED. ON. TO
ANOTHER AGENCY AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO PREVENT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OF OUR B. K.
EUROPE BAT THANK YOU MR ST. SO
I WANTED TO REVISIT THAT THAT
TOPIC THAT MR MAYES SR GABRIEL
REYES AROUND EDUCATION. I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE IN MY CAPACITY AS
A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE OF GOING TO NORWAY
AND SEEING. THE TRAINING THEY
DO FOR THEIR OFFICERS THAT ARE
IN PRISONS AND- IT WAS A
FASCINATING FASCINATING
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT WE DO
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES. AND
THOSE INDIVIDUALS COME INTO
THIS ACADEMY THEY GET TWO YEARS
OF EDUCATION. AND THE
EQUIVALENT OF AN ASSOCIATES
DEGREE BEFORE THEY GO INTO THE
PRISONS AND DO THEIR JOB DURING
THAT TIME THEY ARE TAUGHT
PSYCHOLOGY SOCIOLOGY
CRIMINOLOGY. AND THEY COME OUT
WITH A DEPTH OF KNOWLEDGE THAT.%
PALES IN COMPARISON TO WHAT
WE'RE PROVIDING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I APPRECIATE
THE SUGGESTION THAT WE PUT INTO
PLACE A COLLEGE REQUIREMENT I
THINK THAT. YOU KNOW THAT THE
CRITICAL THINKING THAT WAS
MENTIONED BY BOTH DR HANNEKE
AND MISTER ALI KHAN. ABOUT THE
DISCRETION THAT IS GIVING IN
AND THE WORK THAT GOES INTO
MAKING THOSE CHOICES AND-
PROBLEM SOLVING CRITICAL
THINKING IS SO IMPORTANT AT
SUCH A GOOD TOPIC BUT- WE ALSO
NEED TO BE REALISTIC ABOUT THE
DEBT. THAT ARE COLLEGE STUDENTS
GRADUATE WITH THESE DAYS AND
THEN WHAT WE ARE ASKING FROM
THEM. IS A LOT. WHEN I WOULD
URGE US AS LEGISLATORS TO THINK
CREATIVELY I KNOW WE ALL. JUST
DID FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
IN CUTS WE ARE IN THE GREATEST
RECESSION IN MY LIFETIME. BUT
WE HAVE AN INCREDIBLE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM IN THIS STATE IT
IS TEACHING MANY OF THE THINGS
THAT WE ARE DISCUSSING HERE
TODAY. AND SO ARE THERE WAYS IN
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM TO PROVIDE
THIS EDUCATION. TO THOSE GOING
INTO LAW ENFORCEMENT AT NO COST
TO THEM WITH A DEGREE ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF IT. RATHER THAN
PUTTING ON THEM ADDITIONAL
COLLEGE DEBT AND THE THINGS
THAT WE KNOW ARE SO BURDENSOME
AND SO I THINK THAT IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE. WHERE THE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES I THINK WE
CAN BE CREATIVE AND PROBLEM
SOLVING. BUT WITH THAT I DO
HAVE A QUESTION AND I'M FOR MR
ALL THE CON WHICH IS GIVEN MY
EXPERIENCE AND- AND- WHAT I GOT
TO SEE IN OUR WAY AND REALLY
THE VALUE OF THAT EDUCATION I'M
CURIOUS IF. YOU TALK A LITTLE
BIT IN RESPONSE TO MR GABRIEL'S
QUESTIONS ABOUT CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA'S DOING. BUT I THINK
WHEN WE LOOK BROADER THERE ARE
SOLUTIONS OUT THERE THAT WE
CAN- LOOK TO AND BE BETTER FROM
AND I. SO I JUST ASK OUR THEIR
SYSTEM THROUGHOUT THE WORLD
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES
THE YOU WOULD ADVISE US TO
MIRROR. AND TO BETTER EMULATE.
REMEMBER I THINK JUST ACTUALLY
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
TOUCHED UPON ABOUT OTHER
SYSTEMS ARE ACCESS AND OF
COURSE THIS THE TO EDUCATION
AND THE SOCIAL EQUITY ISSUES IN
THE DEBT. IS AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION IT ON IN THIS IN THIS
ARE. ON THIS ISSUE BUT I DO
THINK THERE'S ONE IN THE UNITED
STATES ONE MODEL THAT WE SHOULD
CONSIDER LOOKING AT AND I'M
VERY HESITANT TO DRAW ANY
ANALOGIES TO THE MILITARY BUT I
DO THINK. FOR MY EXPERIENCE
HAVING BEEN. A PROFESSOR AT A
MILITARY COLLEGE. THE EMPHASIS
THE U. S. MILITARY'S PUT ON
EDUCATION IN DEVELOPING NOT
ONLY ITS FRONTLINE SOLDIERS BUT
ALSO WITH LEADERSHIP IS TRULY
IMPRESSIVE. AND WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE STRUCTURES THAT THEY
HAVE HAD SINCE WORLD WAR TWO
WITH THE GI BILL AND MANY OTHER
PROGRAMS TO ENCOURAGE OFF. TO
ENCOURAGE SOLDIERS AND AIRMEN
AND SAILORS TO GET THEIR
EDUCATION WELL- WHEN THEY START
IN THE MILITARY AT A VERY YOUNG
AGE WHICH IS SIMILAR TO
POLICING WHERE MOST POLICE
OFFICERS DO START AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY ONE. THAT THERE ARE
MODELS THAT COULD BE PUT IN
PLACE WHERE OFFICERS COULD HAVE
A GI BILL OF SOME SORT OR- EVEN
IF YOU LOOK AT HE PROFESSIONAL
LEVEL SOME MILITARY DOCTORS AND
LAWYERS WHO BECOME JAGS. OFTEN
TIME THE MILITARY WILL HELP PAY
FOR THEIR EDUCATION AND THEN
THEY HAVE A COMMITMENT OF
SERVICE AFTER THAT SO EXCUSE ME
OUT SO I DO THINK THERE ARE
MODELS EVEN IN THE UNITED
STATES THAT SHOULD BE EXAMINED.
THAT MAY BE ANALOGOUS TO
RELEASE CERTAIN ELEMENTS WOULD
HELP ADDRESS THIS ISSUE THAT IT
SEEMS THAT EVERYBODY IS
COGNISANT OF. THANK YOU I THINK
THAT'S HELPFUL AND YOU KNOW
AGAIN I JUST HOPE THAT WE
REALLY LOOK AT. WHAT RESOURCES
WE HAVE HERE POINT HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES AND HER
CALIFORNIA TO BETTER PREPARE
OUR POLICE OFFICERS ON THE
STREET BECAUSE I HAVE TO SAY
MISTER MAYES POINT ABOUT- THE
FACT THAT THE PERSON WHO CUTS
MY HAIR HAS MORE HOURS I THINK
THERE'S LESS RISK IN A BAD HAIR
CUT SO WE- WE NEED TO DO
SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE SWIFTLY- NOW WE WANT TO
HEAR FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE. OF
SOMEONE WHO'S FROM THE LEGAL
PROFESSION. EACH PANELIST WE
HAVE TO UP TO TWELVE MINUTES
AND SPEAKING. AND ALSO
PRESENTING- THE NEXT PERSON
WHAT HAPPENS MISTER RYAN HARRIS
WOULD YOU PLEASE. APPROACH AND
TAKE A SEAT. PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF AND BEGIN WITH YOUR
PRESENTATION. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS GERMAN GIPSON AFTERNOON.
I'M THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME
TO SPEAK TODAY ON THE SUBJECT
OF POLICE REFORM I REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
BLACK LAWYERS AS A NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA GENERAL COUNSEL AND
CO CHAIR OF HIS LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE. IN ADDITION TO BEING
AN ATTORNEY I AM ALSO A FORMER
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER. AND
HOLD A MASTER'S DEGREE IN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE. CABLES
MEMBERSHIP INCLUDES OVER SIX
THOUSAND AFRICAN AMERICAN
ATTORNEYS JUDGES LAW PROFESSORS
AND LAW STUDENTS. ITS MISSION
IS TO PROMOTE REFORM IN THE
LAWS AND IN THE ADMINISTRATION
OF JUSTICE AS WE CONTINUE THE
QUEST FOR EQUALITY AND
EMPOWERMENT. WE ARE COMMITTED
TO ADVANCING JUSTICE AND
EQUALITY THAT BEING SAID. OUR
FOCUS ON THE MATTER OF POLICE
REFORM. IS IN PROMOTING THE
RULE OF LAW AND CONFIDENCE IN
OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM. IF
APPROPRIATE LEGISLATIVE
INTERVENTION FOCUSES ON
PROMOTING THE RULE OF LAW AND
CONFIDENCE IN OUR JUDICIAL
SYSTEM WITH RESPECT TO POLICE
REFORM. WE BELIEVE THE
FUNCTIONAL IMPACT. WOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT DECREASE IN THE
INCIDENCE OF POLICE BRUTALITY
AND HOMICIDES IN THE LINE OF
DUTY. LAW ENFORCEMENT
REPRESENTS THE PRIMARY POINT OF
CONTACT BETWEEN THE CITIZENRY
AND GOVERNMENT. IT IS IMPORTANT
AT THIS INTERSECTION REINFORCES
THE PREMISE THAT GOVERNMENT
EXISTS TO ENABLE OUR EXISTENCE.
NOT CHALLENGES. LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS ALSO INTEGRAL TO THE RULE OF
LAW AND OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM
WITHOUT APPROPRIATE
GOVERNMENTAL USE OF FORCE THERE
WOULD BE NO WAY TO EFFECTUATE
JUSTIN'S. BUT WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
ON TELEVISION WITH THESE POLICE
KILLINGS INCIDENTS OF POLICE
BRUTALITY AND STORIES OF POLICE
CORRUPTION AND FLAGRANT RACISM.
THESE ARE ISSUES THAT
PROLIFERATE INJUSTICE
ESPECIALLY WITHIN OUR MOST
VULNERABLE AND DISENFRANCHISED
COMMUNITIES. PEOPLE STOP
BELIEVING IN OUR SYSTEM WHEN I
THINK IT ISN'T DESIGNED FOR
THEM WHEN THEY THINK THAT
CALLING LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR
ASSISTANCE WILL RESULT IN THE
DEATH OF A LOVED ONE. IT IS
THAT SUFFER THE MOST CHALLENGES
NEED A LAW ENFORCEMENT PRESENCE
THAT THEY BELIEVE WANTS THEM TO
LIVE AND THRIVE. UNFORTUNATELY
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS QUITE THE
OPPOSITE AND FOR THE LONGEST
TIME COMMUTER. MOST IN NEED A
POSITIVE GOVERNMENT
INTERVENTION HAS SUFFERED AT
THE HANDS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
REPRESSION. THE COMMUNITY
POLICE REFORM MOVEMENT OF THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES WITH
PROMISING. IN THE EIGHTIES.
WITH ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
PRACTITIONERS REALIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF ENGAGING WITH THE
COMMUNITY STEPPING OUTSIDE
PATROL CAR WORKING WITH
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
PRACTICING PROBLEM ORIENTED
POLICING AND ENGAGING IN PUBLIC
OUTRAGE. BUT THIS WAS JUST A
SMALL FIRST STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. IN ACTUALITY FOR TWO
HUNDRED YEARS WE HAVE HAD THE
PERFECT RECIPE FOR POLICING. IN
EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINE SIR ROBERT
PEEL CREATED THE FIRST
PROFESSIONAL POLICE FORCE IN
ENGLAND IN SO DOING AS A
PREMISE FOR THE FUNCTION OF
POLICING HE SAID POLICE ARE THE
COMMUNITY AND THE COMMUNITY ARE
POLICING. THE ONLY DIFFERENCE
IS THAT THE POLICE ARE FULL
TIME. HE VIEWED POLICING AS AND
THE COMMUNITY HAS ONE IN THE
SAME AND IN ORDER TO ENSURE
SAFETY IN THE COMMUNITY HE
REALIZED. THAT THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
COMMUNITY MUST BE ONE OF MUTUAL
RESPECT PARTNERSHIP AND
COLLABORATION. MISTER PILLS
NINE POLICING PRINCIPLES SHOULD
GUIDE OUR DISCUSSION ON POLICE
REFORM. I HAVE SUBMITTED THEM
INTO THE RECORD FOR YOUR REVIEW.
AMONG THE MOST RELEVANT OF THE
NINE POLICING PRINCIPLES IN MY
OPINION OUR PRINCIPLES NUMBER
FIVE AND NUMBER EIGHT PRINCIPLE
NUMBER FIVE SAYS. LAW
ENFORCEMENT MUST SEEK AND
PRESERVE PUBLIC FAVOR NOT BY
PANDERING TO PUBLIC OPINION BUT
BY CONSTANTLY DEMONSTRATING
ABSOLUTELY IMPARTIAL SERVICE TO
LAW INCOMPLETE INDEPENDENCE A
POLICY. WITHOUT REGARD TO THE
JUSTICE OR INJUSTICE OF THE
SUBSTANCE OF INDIVIDUAL LOSS BY
READY OFFERING OF INDIVIDUAL
SERVICE AND FRIENDSHIP TO ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WITHOUT
REGARD TO THEIR WEALTH OR
SOCIAL STANDING. ALREADY
EXERCISE OF COURTESY AND
FRIENDLY GOOD HUMOR. AND BY
READY OFFERING OF INDIVIDUAL
SACRIFICE AND PROTECTING AND
PRESERVING LIFE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FIVE STAND FOR THE
PROPOSITION THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT NEEDS TO LOVE THE
COMMUNITY. ALL OF US IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT'S THEIR MANDATE
AS AGENTS OF GOVERNMENT UNDER
THE SOCIAL CONTRACT. PRINCIPLE
A PRINCIPLE NUMBER EIGHT SAYS
LAW ENFORCEMENT MUST RECOGNIZE
ALWAYS THE NEED FOR STRICT
ADHERENCE TO POLICE EXECUTIVE
FUNCTIONS. AND TO REFRAIN FROM
EVEN SEEMING TO USURP THE
POWERS OF THE JUDICIARY IN A
VENDING INDIVIDUALS OR THE
STATE AND UP WITH THOR TATE OF
THE JUDGING GUILT AND PUNISHING
THE GUILTY. PRINCIPLE NUMBER
EIGHT STANCE AGAINST POLICE
BRUTALITY. POLICE BRUTALITY IS
AT ITS CORE LAW ENFORCEMENT
USURPING THE ROLE OF THE
JUDICIARY AND EXACTING JUDICIAL
PUNISHMENT. WHEN THE POLICE ARE
VIEWED AS THE DELIVERS OF
EXTRAJUDICIAL PUNISHMENT THE
COMMUNITIES WHO SUFFER THE MOST
FROM THE VIGILANTE ISM TEND NOT
TO ASK HIM FOR HELP IN
RESOLVING DISPUTES. THUS
VIOLENT CRIME INCREASES. POLICE
VIGILANTE ISM AND OUTRIGHT
CRIMINALITY HAS REARED ITS UGLY
HEAD IN COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE. TAKE A
LOOK AT WHAT WE SEE WHAT'S
GOING ON IN VALLEJO WHERE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS HAVE BUILT
A CULTURE AROUND KILLING
CIVILIANS. IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE UPWARD MOBILITY
WITHIN THEIR AGENCY. COPS ARE
LITERALLY THROWING PARTIES FOR
EACH OTHER AFTER THEY KILL
CIVILIANS AND THEN THEY MARK
THEMSELVES WITH PRIDE BY
SLIGHTLY BENDING THEIR BADGES
TO SIGNIFY THE NEW SOCIAL
STANDING AMONG THE RANKS. TAKE
A LOOK AT WHAT'S GOING ON IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. WHERE
SHERIFF'S DEPUTIES BRAND
THEMSELVES WITH TATTOOS TO
SIGNIFY THEIR CRIMINAL
DISPOSITION. FOR YEARS
AUTHORITIES HAVE BEEN
ATTEMPTING TO ROOT OUT AND
ELIMINATE GANG BEHAVIOR WITHIN
THIS LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
THESE INCIDENTS DEMONSTRATE A
FLAGRANT DISREGARD AND
DIAMETRICAL OPPOSITION TO THE
ROLE THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS SHOULD PROVIDE WITHIN
OUR COMMUNITY. YET THE CULTURE
WITHIN THESE AGENCIES HAVE
FESTERED FOR SO LONG. AND DRIVE
WITH SO MUCH VITALITY THAT
OFFICERS FELT IT WAS SAFE
ENOUGH TO OPENLY COMMUNICATE
SYMBOLICALLY OR OTHERWISE OF
THEIR HATRED FOR THE PEOPLE
THEY HAVE SWORN TO SERVE. I SAY
ALL OF THAT TO SAY THIS. WE
HAVE A CULTURAL PROBLEM IN
POLICING AND IT NEEDS
LEGISLATIVE INTERVENTION. MORE
TRAINING WILL NOT SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM BECAUSE THE MISCONDUCT
THAT UNDERMINES CONFIDENCE IN
THE RULE OF LAW THE MOST IS
WILLFUL. THEREFORE CABLE
RECOMMENCE LET US LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTIONS DESIGNED TO
FACILITATE ROOTING OUT CULTURAL
CORRUPTION AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WE ARE IN FAVOR OF MANDATING
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
STUDY AND LEARN THE TEACHINGS
OF SIR ROBERT PEEL DURING THEIR
CERTIFICATION TRAINING THEY
NEED TO KNOW WHAT THEY'RE HERE
FOR. WE'RE IN FAVOR OF
ELIMINATING AND NARROWING
QUALIFIED IMMUNITY FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. WE'RE IN
FAVOR OF A BILL THAT ALLOWS FOR
THE DECERTIFICATION OF MY
OFFICE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS AND THE CREATION OF A
STATEWIDE RADIALIS WE HAVE
HEARD ALREADY TESTIMONY ABOUT
HOW DIFFICULT IT IS. FOR OUR
POLICE CHIEFS TO GET RID OF THE
OFFICERS OF AND NOT DOING THE
RIGHT THING. WE'RE IN FAVOR OF
CREATING A STATEWIDE MANDATE
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TO
WEAR BODY CAMERAS. AND THAT
THEY RECORD FOOTAGE AT ALL
TIMES EXCEPT FOR WHEN PRIVACY
REQUIREMENTS JUSTIFY OTHERWISE.
IN ORDER TO FIND THE PROBLEM WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO DO TO
DETECTED. AND WE'RE IN FAVOR OF
CREATING A LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTION. THAT CRIMINALIZES.
POLICE OFFICER SPEECH THAN
COURAGE'S VIOLATING THE RIGHTS.
OF THE PUBLIC BY MEANS OF
GOVERNMENTAL USE OF FORCE.NOW
THIS IS A NEW IDEA. AND WE'RE
WILLING TO WORK WITH YOU ON
CRAFTING APPROPRIATE
LEGISLATION FOR THIS. TO CLOSE.
SIR ROBERT PEEL'S TEACHINGS
HAVE BEEN ON THE BOOKS FOR TWO
HUNDRED YEARS THEY CREATE A
PERFECT FRAMEWORK FOR
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT. WE
SHOULD HAVE LAWS DESIGNED TO
EFFECTUATE THESE PRINCIPLES.
BUT FIRST WE NEED TO DEAL WITH
THE CULTURAL PROBLEM AND
POLICING. AND WE'RE READY TO
WORK WITH YOU TO ACCOMPLISH
THIS GOAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH RETIRES NEXT EVERYONE
INVITES- GABBY TRAIL TO PLEASE
COME AND- AIR SELF TO GIVE HER
PRESENTATION AND THEN AFTER
WHICH WILL ASK MEMBERS TO ASK.
WE WANT TO DO THIS. FOR THE
SAKE OF TIME SO. THESE PROVIDES
OPENING CAN YOUR INTRODUCTION-
WHEN YOU'RE READY. I THINK YOU
NEED TO PUSH THAT BUTTON THERE
WE GO CALL IT CAN HEAR ME YES I
GOT A CALL I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF SACRAMENTO ACT A
LOCAL NONPROFIT THAT IS AN
AFFILIATE FOR PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA- WE HAVE BEEN IN
THIS COMMUNITY FOR THE LAST
TWENTY NINE YEARS- AND SO
PUBLIC SAFETY IS. SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING
AND WORKING REALLY HARD AT A
LOCAL LEVEL BUT ALSO AT THE
STATE LEVEL AND- WHEN WE FIND
OURSELVES TALKING ABOUT WE AT
THE COMMUNITY- HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS ARE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY- ONE OF THE CONCERNING
AN ALARMING THINGS THAT- WE
HAVE IDENTIFIED IS THAT. THESE
THESE CONVERSATIONS ONLY
HAPPEN. AFTER A LOVED ONE HAS
BEEN TAKEN AWAY FROM OUR
COMMUNITIES IN IN A BRUTAL WAY.
I'M A MOTHER OF TWIN BOYS BROWN
VOICE. RICE SO WHEN I THINK
ABOUT POLICE REFORM. THERE IS
THE NAME URGENCY TO ADDRESS
THIS BECAUSE THERE ARE MOMS
ACROSS OUR STATE WHO CANNOT
HOLD THEIR LOVED ONES. RIGHT
THERE IS PEOPLE THAT. ARE JUST
IN SO MUCH PAIN WE ARE BLEEDING
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEIR FUTURE COULD HAVE
BEEN AND WHAT THEY COULD HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO OUR COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE- THEY WERE JUST. TAKEN
AND SO. THAT IS A I'M HAPPY
THAT WE'RE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION AND THEY'RE ALL OF
YOU ARE HAVING GUIDED US TO BE
THINKING WITH YOU ALL BECAUSE-
THIS CANNOT CONTINUE. AND YOU
KNOW OUR REFORMS CANNOT JUST
COME AFTER THE FACT AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE LEARNED
IS THAT. WE HAVE JUST NOT GONE
FAR ENOUGH YOU KNOW AT PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA IT WITH A LOT OF OUR
PARTNERS ACROSS THE STATE
THOUGHT REALLY HARD TO. GET
PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN PAST
COUPLE YEARS AGO I PERSONALLY
FROM BEING IN LAST NIGHT'S AND-
WHAT I WAS ABLE TO WITNESS IN
THESE KIND OF REFORMS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT THAT BRINGS TO
FAMILIES. PEOPLE LIKE JOY
WILLIAMS MY COLLEAGUE WHO IS
NOT ONLY ABLE TO JUST LIKE
SPEAK PROUDLY OF THE FACT THAT
HE HAS A COMMUNITY MEMBER WAS
ABLE TO CONTRIBUTE TO THESE
REFORMS. BUT THAT IT HAS
ACTUALLY OPENED THE DOOR FOR
HIM AND HIS FAMILY AND HIS
DIGNITY AS A MAN OF COLOR IN
THE STATE. AND SO WHEN I THINK
ABOUT THIS WHIMS- WE ARE ALSO
REMINDED THAT THEY'RE JUST NOT
HAVING GONE FAR ENOUGH AND AN
EXAMPLE HEARING SACRAMENTO. WAS
A FEW YEARS AGO MISTER JOSEPH
MAN WAS GUNNED DOWN IN DEL PASO
HEIGHTS BRIGHT DAYLIGHT. AND
AFTER THAT COMMUNITY GATHER AND
WE WERE ABLE TO PASS A FEW
LOCAL REFORMS AROUND GETTING
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO WEAR
THEIR BODY CAMERAS AND SO WE
CELEBRATED RIGHT WE SET OF
COMMUNITY WE ALWAYS CELEBRATE
EVERY LITTLE WINDOW WE HALF
BECAUSE THAT'S ALL. WE ARE ABLE
TO BRING BACK TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. BUT THEN. A FEW
YEARS LATER. WE FIND OURSELVES
AGAIN HAVING THIS CRITICAL
CONVERSATION AFTER ANOTHER LOVE
ONE ANOTHER LOVE ONE WAS TAKEN
AWAY FROM OUR COMMUNITY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. AFTER THE MURDER OF
MR STEPHON CLARK WE COME TO
FIND OUT THAT WE DIDN'T GO FAR
ENOUGH. I GETTING THE BODY
CAMERAS IN USING UP OUR TAX
MONEY TO MAKE BODY CAMERAS.
AVAILABLE TO OUR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. WE HADN'T GONE FAR
ENOUGH JUST DOING THAT. BECAUSE
THEY WEREN'T EVEN REQUIRED TO
WEAR HIM ON. AT ALL TIMES RIGHT
SO THEN. WE AT THE COMMUNITY
AGAIN ARE HAVING A CONVERSATION
AROUND. LIKE IS THAT IN A
SUBTLE WAY OF LOOKING AT HOW WE
SPEND OUR LIMITED RESOURCES
RIGHT- I WAS HAPPY TO HEAR
THAT- MR GABRIEL MUCH AND- A
LOT OF CONVERSATION IS LIKE HOW
DO WE MAKE RESOURCES AVAILABLE
AND THE REALITY IS THAT YOU
HAVE EXPERTS IN THE COMMUNITY.
RIGHT WE DON'T NEED TO ALWAYS
SPEND A LOT OF A TON OF MONEY
ON LET'S BRING THESE EXPERTS
THE EXPERTS LIVE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND ONE OF THE
THINGS WE ALWAYS SAY. AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING IS PEOPLE
CLOSEST TO THE PAIN HOW THE
SOLUTIONS TO THEIR PROBLEMS AND
I REALLY HAVE TO HEAR THE- THE
PROFESSORS EARLIER THIS
MORNING. TALKING ABOUT HOW. THE
COMMUNITY HAS TO BE
INSTRUMENTAL IN THIS
CONVERSATION- I HAVE AS AN
ORGANIZER BEEN WORKING WITH
BOTH NOT JUST IN IN THE ISSUES
OF HOUSING HOMELESSNESS
IMMIGRATION. ALL THOSE ISSUES
ARE DIRECTLY LINKED AND
INTERTWINED WITH THIS KOMMER
CONVERSATION AROUND POLICE
REFORM- WHEN I TALKED TO OUR
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES IN
SACRAMENTO. I WANT TO SPEAK OF
GLORIA WHO GLORIA TELLS ME
GABBY I THERE'S NO WAY I'M
GOING TO CALL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ONE BECAUSE I'M UNDOCUMENTED TO
IN IN PART OF THE REASON WAS
BECAUSE LOCALLY. WE HAVE TO
FIGHT TO END THE NICE CONTRACT.
WITH OUR LOCAL SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT LAKE CHARLES
CONTINUES TO BE BROKEN IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND SO. HAVING
COMMUNITY CENTER SOLUTIONS THAT
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE NOT JUST
BROUGHT BROUGHT ONTO THIS
CONVERSATION AS AN AFTERTHOUGHT
THEY CANNOT CONTINUE TO BE USED
AS FOCUS GROUPS BUT I THINKING
PARTNERS WHO ACTUALLY KNOW WHAT
THEY NEED. WHO ACTUALLY KNOW
THE ROLE THEY WANT LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO PLAY IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND SO. WHEN I
WHEN I REFLECT BACK ON WHAT OUR
LEADERS ACROSS THE STATE I
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA. HAVE BEEN
FIGHTING FOR SO MANY HERE'S ITS
ACCOUNTABILITY TRYING. IF WE
DON'T HAVE A WAY TO HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE TO MOLD LIKE IF AN
OFFICER. I DON'T KNOW LIKE I'M
I JUST I'M NOT BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE IT AND I AM SURE
THAT I CAN ABILITY SUCH A
BROAD. LANGUAGE BUT- LAKE ONE
WAY THAT WE THINK ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY IS THAT SOMEONE
THAT HAS DIRECT TIES TO RACIST
ORGANIZATIONS SHOULD NOT BE
POLICING OUR COMMUNITY. WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING INTO THAT AND
HOW ARE WE BEING TRANSPARENT
ABOUT THAT AND THAT A LOT OF
THE RESOURCES THAT WE ARE USING
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
IS OVERSIGHT AND THAT THERE IS
A COMMUNITY OVERSIGHT WITH- YOU
KNOW A DIVERSE COMMUNITY
OVERSIGHT SO THAT- WE ARE
ACTUALLY FEELING LIKE THEY'RE
NOT JUST. THAT COMMUNITIES NOT
JUST COMING A LONG **** JUST A
FOCUS GROUP BUT ACTUALLY AS A
THINKING PARTNER. THEN SO THE
LAST THING I WOULD SAY IS THAT.
I CELEBRATED WE CELEBRATE ALL
OF THE REFORMS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED BECAUSE- REGARDLESS OF
WHERE WE STAND IN THE SPECTRUM
WE KNOW THAT FAMILIES HAVE HAD
OPPORTUNITIES WE KNOW THAT IF
THEY SOME LICENSE BUT NOT
ENOUGH LIVES. IN SEOUL FOR US
ENSURING THAT YOU KNOW
TRAININGS ARE IMPORTANT. BUT WE
ALSO COMMUNITY HAS SEEN HOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS USE TRAINING TO
DE ESCALATE. FOR SOME
COMMUNITIES BUT NOT DE ESCALATE
WITH OUR COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ACROSS THE
STATE. AND I KNOW THAT THERE
WAS MENTION TO DATE EARLIER
INDIA IS SUPER IMPORTANT. AND
EVERY TIME WE LOOK AT DATA WE
KEEP ON SEEING THAT THESE
POLICIES THAT WE CONTINUE TO
PASS ARE NOT IMPLEMENTED.-EQUALLY AMONG THE SPECTRUM IN
THE STATE AND SO I THINK. WHEN
WE LOOK AT THE MOMENT THAT WE
ARE INWHAT THIS MOMENT IS
REQUIRING OF. YOU ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
TO TRULY REIMAGINE. COVE IT HAS
A REALLY OPEN THAT OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO. REALLY THINK OUTSIDE
THE BOX ABOUT WHAT THESE
REFORMS CAN LOOK LIKE. AND SO I
JUST WANT TO. REALLY ENCOURAGE
US TO. DO WE TRANSFER ABOUT THE
EXPECTATIONS AND HAVE CLARITY
ABOUT. WHAT WE ARE HOLDING
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE TO- AND SO
WITH THAT I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR INVITING US AND
HAVING A FEW. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF A CERTAIN INCREASING
WANNA GIVE YOU AMPLE NOT ENOUGH
TIME THIS PANEL AS WE'VE GIVEN-
TO THE PREVIOUS PADDLE SO WITHTHAT I WOULD ASK THE FIRST
QUESTION THEY WOULD ASK
MEMBERS- TO ASK QUESTIONS AND
PLEASE. GET MY ATTENTION- TO
QUEUE UP MS REYES SMITH
GONZALEZ- IN ORDER SO MY FIRST
QUESTION TO YOU IS- GABBY AND
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE ALL THAT YOU HAVE
ARTICULATED THUS FAR WHAT IS
NEEDED TO INCREASE TRUST
BETWEEN OUR COMMUNITY AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT. THAT WOULD BE THE
FIRST QUESTION. IN YOUR OPINION.
EIGHT SO I THINK IN MY OPINION
IN MY OPINION- THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS ARE NEEDED BUT ONE OF
THEM HAS TO BE- HAVING
COMMUNITY REALLY SHARE HOW THE
ROLE THAT THEY WANT TO SEE AND
HOW THEY WANT TO INTERACT IN
THEIR EXPECTATIONS OF THEIR
DEPARTMENTS- THAT HAS TO BE. AT
THE CENTER OF IT BECAUSE WE
CANNOT. WHEN UNITY IS NOT ABLE
TO TRUST THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO SERVE THEM. IT'S
KIND OF YOU KNOW COUNTER TO IT
IF TO CONTINUE TO. YOU KNOW-
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
SOLUTIONS ARE WHEN YOU KNOW THE
COMMUNITY HAS TO DO THAT IN.
AND THERE ARE SOME OTHER MOUNT
MODELS BEFORE. BEFORE THE
MURDER OF MR STEPHON CLARK TOOK
PLACE IN SACRAMENTO. AT THE
CRIMINAL ACT WE HAD BEEN
CONVENING FOR A YEAR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. PARTNERS IN THE
ECOSYSTEM SAID WE SET ALL OVER
THE SPECTRUM AROUND- ON YOU
KNOW THEIR RELATIONSHIP WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND THEY WERE
JUST MEETING BREAKING BREAD.
AND THEN. MISTER STEPHON CLARK
WAS TAKING AWAY FROM OUR
COMMUNITIES IN SUCH A VIOLENT
WAY THAT COMMUNITY MEMBERS NO
LONGER WANTED TO BE SITTING IN
THE TABLE WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T FEEL LIKE
THE CONVERSATIONS THAT WE WERE
HAVING A YEAR BEFORE FOR A
WHOLE YEAR TOGETHER WE'RE GOING
ANYWHERE AND SO IT HAS TO BE
NOT JUST A LISTENING BUT THE
ACTION PIECE- I THINK THOSE TWO
THINGS HAVE TO BE THERE
COMMUNITY HAS TO HAVE A LEVEL
OF POWER WHERE THEY FEEL LIKE.
THESE POLICIES HAVE TEETH THAT
ARE HELPING MOVE THE AGENDA
FORWARD. AND ONE QUESTION MR
HARE'S IN YOUR LEGAL OPINION
WHAT CHANGED WHAT CHANGE IN LAW
CHANGES A LAW. DO YOU THINK-
COULD IMPROVE THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM TODAY. SO TWO THINGS-
THE FIRST CHANGE I THINK WHAT
WE NEED AND WE NEEDED A LAST
SESSION WAS WAS THAT THE BRADY
LIST- SO THAT OUR DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS. NO WHETHER OR NOT TO
PUT COPS WHO HAVE HAD ISSUES
WITH HONESTY AND INTRUDE. ON
THE STAND. TO TESTIFY ABOUT THE
ARREST THAT THEY HAVE MADE WITH
REGARD TO SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN-
CONFINED BECAUSE OF CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY. AND THEN YOU KNOW
WHAT THIS LEADS TO YOU KNOW
WHEN THIS COP IS FINALLY
FIGURED OUT WHEN PEOPLE REALIZE
THAT THIS PERSON HAS A RECORD
OF MALFEASANCE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT CONDUCT. ALL OF
THAT. WORK FOR JUSTICE IS UNDER
THOSE OFFENDERS ARE RELEASED
FROM PRISON BECAUSE THEIR THEIR
CASES ARE BROUGHT INTO DOUBT
AND IT PUTS A FINANCIAL STRAIN
ON A SYSTEM EIGHTY ROADS TRUST
IN THE LAW AND CONFIDENCE IN
OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM. IS A
CANCER AND THIS BRADY LIST WILL
HELP FIX THAT PROBLEM NOT ONLY
THAT THE SECOND THING I WANTED
TO MENTION WAS THERE NEED TO BE
A LAW ON THE BOOKS THAT
CRIMINALIZES- LAW ENFORCEMENT
SPEECH THAT ADVOCATES FOR.
VIOLATING THE RIGHTS OF
CITIZENS IN PARTICULAR KILLING
CITIZENS BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT'S
GOING ON- WHETHER IT'S IN THE
FORM OF BENDING BADGES TO
SIGNIFY. AS A SYMBOL OF YOUR
POSITION SOCIAL POSITION IN THE
AGENCY OR GETTING A TATTOO.
TOOL SOME OF THESE LITTLE
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN COPS ON
THE SIDE OF THE ROAD THAT ARE
ACCIDENTALLY CAPTURED ON THE
BODY CAMS WHEN THEY'RE- TALKING
ABOUT JUDICIAL OFFICERS AND
CIVILIANS AND USING RACIAL
SLURS. THIS IS WHAT'S GOING ON
UNDER THE WATER AND IT'S
CAUSING A PROBLEM IT'S CAUSING
YOUNG IMPRESSIONABLE COPS WHO
WANT TO BE LIKE THE COOL GUY
APRICOT BAR THAT EVERYONE
LISTENS TO WHEN THEY HAVE A
STORY ABOUT USING- THEY'RE
THEIR THEIR- DUTY SERVICE
WEAPON IN THE LINE OF DUTY. OR
SOME INTERESTING STORY ABOUT
USE OF FORCE THEY WANT TO BE
LIKE THIS GUY THEY WANT TO LIVE
UP TO HIS EXPECTATIONS. AND.
THIS IS THE CULTURAL CANCER
THAT IS THIS WITHIN OUR LONG
FOR AGENTS AND THE TO BE SCHOOL.
IN THE NEEDS TO BE. A LETTUCE.
SOLUTION WITH T. THAT ADDRESSES
THAT PROBLEM NOW I'M SORRY OF
MR DIFFERENT ONE MORE THING WE
HAVE ROLES. NOT CRIMINALIZE
CIVILIAN SPEECH. LIKE FOR
EXAMPLE INCITEMENT TO RIOT.
WHEN SOMEONE STANDS UP AND SAYS
YOU KNOW SOMETHING TO THE
EFFECT OF WITH BURNS DOWN AND
PEOPLE DO IT. THEY CAN GO TO
JAIL. I THINK THOSE SAME RULES
THAT APPLY TO OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH VIEWPOINT YOU TALKED
ABOUT THE BRADY LIST- THERE SIX
ATTORNEYS ON THE SELECT
COMMITTEE THERE'S TWO FOUR
POLICE OFFICERS BUT THERE'S
PEOPLE WATCHING THAT DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE BRADY LIST IS CAN YOU
ARTICULATE THAT REAL QUICK AND
THEN AFTER THAT WE'RE GOING TO
MISS REYES MISS GONZALEZ IS TO
MAYES. YES I THOUGHT SO WHAT
WHEN A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
ENGAGES IN MISCONDUCT IN THE
LINE OF DUTY THAT BRINGS INTO
QUESTION THEIR- ABILITY TO BE
HONEST AND TRUTHFUL- OR ANY
OTHER TYPE OF SIGNIFICANT
MISCONDUCT. THEY SHOULD BE PUT
ON A LIST SO THAT WHEN THERE IS
A CRIMINAL CASE THAT THEY'RE
INVOLVED WITH THAT IS REFERRED
TO THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY TO
PROSECUTE THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
SHOULD KNOW WHETHER OR NOT THAT
OFFICER IS A CREDIBLE WITNESS
OR NOT. AND THE IMPACT OF THAT
BRADY LIST IS THAT IF YOU HAVE
A COP ON THE STREET. THAT
CANNOT BE USED AS A WITNESS IN
A CRIMINAL CASE. THE IMPACT OF
THAT IS THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER IS NO GOOD AS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER. AND SO
THEY GET REMOVED FROM THE
STREET. BACK COPS GET TAKEN OFF
THE STREETS NOW I'M AWARE THAT-
SENATOR ROBERT HAVE A- GREAT
LIFT BILL- BUT BECAUSE OF
FINANCIAL ISSUES WITH RETAIL.
AND WE NEED TO REVISIT THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS RACING
UP TO BAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THIS IS BEEN- VERY. INFORMATIVE
BEGINNING WITH DR HANNEKE FROM
CAL POLY POMONA YEAH A BRONCOS-
AND EVERYBODY ELSE OF MR
HARRISON AND MR WHO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR PRESENTING. I THINK
THAT WHEN I WHEN I THINK OF ANY
KIND OF REFORM I ALWAYS THINK
WE DON'T NEED TO REINVENT THE
WHEEL WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
WHO HAS DONE IT AND DONE IT
RIGHT AND LET'S FIGURE OUT JUST
LIKE THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE
ASKED ABOUT EDUCATION WHO ELSE
HAS DONE IT AND DONE IT RIGHT
SO THAT WE CAN THEN FIGURE OUT
HOW WE THEN. USE THE BEST. BEST
PRACTICES TO THEM BRING IT HERE
TO CALIFORNIA- I. I WAS
REMINDED THIS MORNING. OF
HARTFORD CONNECTICUT THAT HAS
NOW DONE. THERE THERE ARE
POLICE REFORM PACKAGE THAT
GOING INTO EFFECT NOW AND THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT
WERE RECOMMENDED THERE THAT
HAVE ALSO BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES ONE WAS A
POLICING CORRECTION OFFICERS
MUST INTERVENE IF THEY SEE
EXCESSIVE FORCE. AND NO
RETALIATION IF THEY DO
INTERVENE. MY COLLEAGUE MR
HOLDEN INTRODUCED THAT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL IDEA TO
INVESTIGATE USE OF FORCE MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER MCCOURT
MCCARTY- SUCCESSFULLY WAS ABLE
TO BRING THAT FORWARD. MISTER
BRETT CENTER BRADFORD ON
DECERTIFICATION- IT AND
HARTFORD CONN DARIEN
CONNECTICUT THE STATE NOW SAYS
IF YOU'RE JUST CERTIFIED AS A
POLICE OFFICER YOU CAN'T EVEN
HOLD A JOB AS A SECURITY
OFFICER YOU'RE DONE. ANOTHER
WAS FALSE REPORTS- FOR BOGUS
NINE ONE ONE CALLS WHICH MR
ALREADY JONES SAWYER. YEAH IT.
INTRODUCED AND DID THE LIMITED
GOVERNMENT IMMUNITY PROTECTION
FOR POLICE WE TALKED ABOUT THAT
AND NUMBER SPEAKERS HAVE TALKED
ABOUT THAT. I ALSO APPRECIATED
THE COMMENT TO OF FROM IS THAT
I HOPE ABOUT THIS IS CONTACTED
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND DOING AWAY
WITH THAT SOMETHING THAT WE
ABSOLUTELY HAVETO LOOK AT IF
WE'RE LOOKING AT TRUST BETWEEN.
OUR NOT JUST THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY BUT THE LATINO
COMMUNITY AS A WHOLE AND IT
ISN'T ONLY LATINOS THAT ARE
IMMIGRANTS WE HAVE IMMIGRANTS
FROM HAITI AND FROM SO MANY
OTHER. COUNTRIES THAT HAVE AN
ISSUE WITH WITH TRUST WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO WE HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT THE BIG PICTURE OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO FIND SOLUTIONS.
ON THE BACKGROUND CHECKS THAT
HAS BEEN TALKED ABOUT- NOT ONLY
FOR CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CHECKS
FOR THOSE WHO ARE GOING TO
SERVE AND PROTECT OUR COMMUNITY
AS MR PERSON YOU TALKED ABOUT
BUT ALSO THOSE WHO ARE MEMBERS
OF A RACIST GROUP OR- HAVE
THOSE RACES TENDED TENDENCIES.
THE BRADY LIST THAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT- AND WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
EDUCATION WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT
EDUCATION AND MENTAL HEALTH AS
WELL. THERE'S SO MUCH THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE I THINK THAT
WITH AGAIN WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT REFORM IT'S RECOGNIZING
WE HAVE AN ISSUE. AND THAT'S
WHY THE SPEAKER CONVENE TO THIS
SELECT COMMITTEE WE'VE MADE IT
CLEAR IT'S NOT WINDOW DRESSING
AND IT CAN'T JUST BE WORDS THAT
WE'RE NOT JUST WINDOW DRESSING
IT HAS TO BE ACTION AND THIS IS
TOUGH ACTION. IT'S GOING TO
TAKE COURAGE IT'S A WEEK WE ALL
HAVE TO BE BOLD ABOUT WHAT IT
IS WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE INCLUDE ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS SO THE COMMUNITY
CAN JUST BE FOR LISTENING. THE
COMMITTEE HAS TO BE PART OF THE
ACTION I ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH
YOU MR HOLE AND I APPRECIATE
THOSE. COMMENTS YOU HAD A FEW
GOOD QUOTES I DIDN'T HAVE TO
HIM DOWN. SOME I WATCHED TAPE
LATER. ON IT'S MAKING SURE.
ALSO THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT IS AT
THE TABLE I THINK IT WAS OUR
VICES FUTURE VICE PRESIDENT AYE
MISS COMELY HERIS ARE RETURNING
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO
SAID THAT BAD COPS ARE BAD FOR
GOOD COPS. THAT'S ABSOLUTELY
THE TRUTH AND ARE GOOD COPS
WANT TO BE AT THE TABLE THEY
WANT TO HELP FIND THE SOLUTIONS
AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT
I WANT THOSE GOOD COPS WITH US
BECAUSE WE HAVE A WHOLE LOT I
HAVE SOME IN MY FAMILY. WE HAVE
A LOT OF GOOD COPS IT WANT TO
BE PART OF THE SOLUTION THAT
WANT TO BE PART OF THAT
COMMUNITY POLICING AND
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT. SO I AM
ABSOLUTELY LOOKING FORWARD TO I
KNOW TODAY WAS THE HISTORY
REFORM OF POLICE. RIGHT TO SUE.
AND I LOOKING FORWARD EVERY
MEETING THAT WE HAVE AND I HOPE
THAT YOU. FOR A IT WILL
CONTINUE TO BE PART OF THIS SO
I WANT TO THANK I DON'T HAVE A
QUESTION I JUST WANTED TO GIVE
MY COMMENTS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS REYES MS
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU MR IS A GREAT WITH
EVERYTHING SHE SAID BUT I THINK
BOTH OF YOU- FOR COMING FORWARD
AND REALLY- SPEAKING AS MEMBERS
OF THE COMMUNITY AND REPRESENT
THE VIEWS. OF COMMUNITY MEMBERS
BECAUSE THERE IS. SOMETIMES IN
THIS DISCUSSION SUCH A
DISCONNECT- AND IT CAN'T WE
CAN'T LEGISLATE WITH THAT
DISCONNECT I MEAN IT YOU KNOW I
THINK ABOUT IT ALL THE TIME
WHEN I'M UP HERE. AND I'M
THINKING THROUGH CERTAIN THINGS
HOW MUCH SOMETHING COST- HOW
IT'S GONNA AFFECT THESE
DIFFERENT LAWS HOW THE
INTERPLAY EVERYTHING LIKE THAT
MAKE A HOME AND THAT'S NOT WHAT
MY NEIGHBORS THINK ABOUT. MY
NEIGHBORS THINKING IF I CALL
THE POLICE ARE THEY GOING TO
CALL ICE. AM I GONNA GET
DEPORTED RIGHT IN SO IT'S
REALLY. IMPORTANT TO HAVE YOUR
VOICES IN THIS I JUST- MYSTERY
HOW WHEN YOU WERE TALKING I WAS
REMEMBER IN ACTUALLY I USED TO
BE AN ORGANIZER AS WELL. AND I
WAS. I WAS REMEMBERING ONE
REALLY GOOD- EVENT WE HAD
BASICALLY WITH OUR POLICE
CHIEF- WE HAPPEN TO HAVE A VERY.
GOOD POLICE CHIEF IN SAN DIEGO
WHO IS RESPONSIVE WHEN WE WOULD
CALL THEM BUT WE HAD OUR- ADOPT
MANY UNION MEMBERS COME IN AND
HIM COME. IN TO DISCUSS JUST
THE ISSUE OF CARS BEING
IMPOUNDED THIS WAS BEFORE WE
HAD THE RIGHT HAVE LICENSES.
AND BECAUSE WE YOU KNOW THERE
WAS. THERE WAS COMPANY POLICY
IF YOU WILL AND THEN THERE WAS
WHAT WAS ACTUALLY HAPPENING.
AND IT WAS A AN AMAZINGLY
POWERFUL INTERACTION AND- ON
THAT ONE POLICY ISSUE AND WE
GOT SOME RESULTS OUT OF IT
BECAUSE HE REALLY HEARD FROM
THE COMMUNITY AND THEY THEY
MADE SUGGESTIONS AND- THERE
THERE BECAME THIS LIKE. EMAIL
BACK AND FORTH IF THE OFFICER
ACTUALLY IMPOUNDED A CAR IN SO
THAT OFFICERS FOUND OUT REALLY
QUICK IF THEY IMPOUNDED THE CAR
OUTSIDE OF POLICY THAT THEY
WERE ACTUALLY TO BE TOLD ABOUT.
THE COMMUNITY. AND IT BECAME
AND LITTLE ACCOUNTABILITY. BUT
I WAS THINKING- YOU KNOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT UTILIZING THE
COMMUNITY AS PART OF THE
SOLUTION. BUT IS THERE ANYTHING
THAT. IT'S SO HARD TO PUT THAT
LOCK RIGHT AND I'M I'M
WONDERING IF THERE IS IF WE
HAVE EXAMPLES MAYBE FROM OTHER
STATES. OR IF THERE'S ANYTHING
THAT SCALABLE WHEN IT COMES TO-
SOME OF THESE ISSUES NOT NOT AT.
NESSA ARE ARE TRANSPARENCY
WHICH WE NEED A LAW BUT-
COMMUNITY POLICING MAYBE SOME
OF THE REFORMS THAT WOULD HELP
BUILD TRUST IS THERE ANYTHING
OUT THERE THAT THAT WE HAVEN'T
THOUGHT OF OR OR THAT YOU HAVE
SEEN. I'M THAT WOULD BE
SCALABLE OR EVEN LEGISLATIVE
LEE. IT'LL ALLOWING US AYE I
GUESS THROUGH THE BUDGET WE
COULD DO SOME BUT LIKE. WHAT
THINGS THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
LEGISLATING. THE FIRM I HAVE
ONE IDEA AND IT COMES FROM.
SOMETHING RECENT I WAS I WAS
LISTENING TO NPR. AND THERE IS
A STORY ABOUT A LONG FORCING
OFFICER I THINK IT WAS DOWN IN
LA. SHE WAS- AND I COULDN'T SEE
WHAT SHE WAS DOING ITS COULD
HEAR. SHE WAS DRESSED IN PLAIN
CLOTHES I KNOW THAT- AND
EVERYONE KNEW SHE WAS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER BUT SHE AND
SHE WAS OUT IN THE COMMUNITY I
THINK SHE WAS SITTING AT A
TABLE IN FRONT OF A RESTAURANT.
CHATTING UP SOME FOLKS FROM THE
COMMUNITY SHE WAS ON THE JOB.
BUT SHE WAS. IN REALITY
SOCIALIZING AND HAVING A GOOD
TIME. AND I MEAN TO ME I WAS
THINKING LIKE WOW THAT IS
THAT'S BEAUTIFUL THAT'S AMAZING
THAT'S- PRETTY MUCH EXACTLY
WHAT POLICING SHOULD BE
BECAUSE- POLICING. HAVE TO
INVOLVE THE COMMUNITY. IN ORDER
FOR CRIMES TO BE SOLVED
EFFICIENTLY THERE NEEDS TO BE
COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT AND IN
ORDER. FOR ALL OF THIS TO OCCUR
THERE NEEDS TO BE TRUST. THEY
NEED TO BE TRUST THAT THIS LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER REALLY
CARES ABOUT ME MY WELL BEING.
KNOWS ME AND I TRUST HER. AND
THIS IS HOW THAT TRUST IS
BUILT. NOW I'VE SEEN- YOU KNOW
VARIOUS. FILMS ON YOUTUBE OR
WHATEVER OF COPS PLAYING
BASKETBALL FULLUNIFORM BADGE
AND GUN AND ALL THAT. AND IT
SEEMS KIND OF SCRIPTED YEAH
THAT'S NICE. BUT WE CAN DO MORE
NOW AS FAR AS A LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTION. IT'S INTERESTING HOW
TO CRAFT. A LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTION FOR THAT BECAUSE-
REALLY DEPEND ON IN THE- APART.
POLICY BUT IF THERE WERE LIKE
GRANTS FOR EXAMPLE THAT
ENCOURAGE THAT TYPE OF
BEHAVIOR. THEN AGENCIES WILL BE
ALL OVER IT. AND REALLY. DO YOU
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE PERSONNEL
TO WRITE. THE PERSONALITY TYPE
OF THE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
MATTERS IN THAT REGARD- YOU
CAN'T HAVE A MILITARY MINDED-
VERY- ABRUPT AND FRANK PERSON
GOING OUT THERE AND SOCIALIZING
PEOPLE PLAYING CARDS YOU KNOW
YOU NEED TO HAVE SOMEONE THAT
HAS EMOTIONAL INTELLIGENCE AND
I KNOW THAT THEY HAVE THOSE
PERSONALITY TESTS AND WHAT NOT
TO FIND OUT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
THE RIGHT FIT. AND BUT WHAT'S
ALSO INTEGRAL IN VERY IMPORTANT
IS EDUCATION. WE'LL GET A
DEGREE IN SOCIOLOGY CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SOMETHING THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO HAVE A PLATFORM WITH
WHICH TO ENGAGE PEOPLE. REACH A
COMMON UNDERSTANDING AND
FACILITATE COMMUNICATION.
MISTER BASS THEY MISTER BONTA
THANK YOU MISTER DAVIS CHAIR-
SEMESTERS I WANTED TO CHAT WITH
YOU ABOUT QUALIFIED IMMUNITY
SINCE YOU ARE- SINCE YOUR
ATTORNEY- I'D LOVE TO GET YOUR
YOUR THOUGHTS ON YOU ACTUALLY
YOUR PRESENTATION HAD BROUGHT
THIS THAT BROUGHT THIS UP- JUST
BEFORE THE END OF SESSION-
THERE WAS SOME TALK ABOUT A
BILL AND THE QUESTION ABOUT
QUALIFIED. IMMUNITY AND I THINK
BACK FOR IF I. IF I CAN'T FOR
JUST A MOMENT I THINK BACK WHEN
I WAS A YOUNG COUNCIL MEMBER.
WAS TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD WHEN
I FIRST. HAD GOT ELECTED TO THE
CITY COUNCIL. AND HAD SAT DOWN
WITH THE CITY ATTORNEY. THE
CITY ATTORNEY WAS EXPLAINING TO
ME- THAT- I'M GOING TO GET SUED
THATTHE CITY'S GET SUED AND
WON- THAT THE CITY GET SUED
OFTENTIMES THE COUNCIL MEMBERS.
GET SUED BUT DON'T WORRY-
BECAUSE YOUR BANK ACCOUNT IS IT
GONNA. END UP BEING IMPACTED BY
THAT EVEN THOUGH YOU'LL BE
NAMED- THERE IS NO- THERE'S NO
LIABILITY TO YOU IN ESSENCE
YOU'RE IMMUNE FROM FROM THAT
THAT THAT LIABILITIES CAUGHT
QUALIFIED IMMUNITY. AND IF
YOU'RE A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER IN ESSENCE YOU'RE
ACTING ON BEHALF OF- OF
GOVERNMENT REINFORCING. STATED
CALIFORNIA LAWYER AND FORCING
THE LAWS THAT ARE ON ON THE
BOOKS. AND SO THE QUESTION IS
IF YOU DID AWAY WITH QUALIFIED
IMMUNITY. A WOULD. WHAT DOES
THAT DO TO LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THEN. WOULD THEY BE THINKING TO
THEMSELVES THE RISK IS TOO
GREAT FOR ME TO DO THIS JOB-
BECAUSE THE LIABILITY TO ME AND
MY FAMILY- THAT WOULD BE TOO
GREAT SO AT TO TALK TO ME A
LITTLE ABOUT ABOUT QUALIFIED
IMMUNITY WHAT WHAT DO YOU MEAN
BY REFORM IN REGARDS OF
QUALIFIED IMMUNITY OKAY. SO.
BEFORE I GET INTO THE WEEDS
HERE- THE LEGISLATIVE ANSWER
FOR THE QUALIFIED IMMUNITY
ISSUE HAS TO BE IRONED OUT- AND
SO- I'M NOT. TRYING TO PRESENT.
A SPECIFIC ANSWER TO THE ISSUE
QUALIFY MANY I JUST WANT TO
TALK ABOUT A GENERALLY. SO AT
ITS CORE WILL QUALIFIED
IMMUNITY IS. IF YOU ARE AN
ACTOR A GOVERNMENT ACTOR. ON
YOUR OWN DOING YOUR JOB ON
BEHALF OF THE GOVERNMENT. IF
YOU HAVE A REASONABLE BELIEVE
THAT WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS RIGHT
IS LEGAL THE PROCREATIVE. THEN
YOU'RE PROTECTED YOU CAN'T BE
PHYSICALLY ECONOMICALLY ON THE
HOOK FOR THE HARM BECAUSE EVEN
IF YOU WERE IN FACT WRONG. AND
THAT REASON ABILITY STANDARD.
IT'S PRETTY LOW. NOW IF WE DID
AWAYCOMPLETELY AND ENTIRELY
WITH QUALIFIED IMMUNITY YOU
COULD HAVE COPS BEING
PERSONALLY SUED FOR VIOLATING
PEOPLE'S RIGHTS. NOW AS FAR AS
THAT THAT SEEMS LIKE A NUCLEAR
WEAPON HAYRIDE YOU YOU DON'T
WANT TO. YOU DON'T WANT TO
CHILL LAW ENFORCEMENT VIGILANCE
RIGHT WE WANT SAFE COMMUNITIES.
SO THE ANSWER SOMEWHERE IN
BETWEEN RIGHT. WHAT CAN WE DO
TO CHANGE THIS THE LEGAL THE
LEGAL STANDARD. SO THAT TOPS
CA'T JUST SAY OH WELL I
THOUGHT THAT WAS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO AND THEN GET AWAY
WITH IT WHEN WHAT THE BEHAVIOR
APPEARS TO BE ON ITS FACE IS
THAT THIS THIS LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER BY EVERY NIGHT
PRACTICAL STANDARD OF
OBSERVANCE. WAS DOING THE WRONG
THING BUT YET WHEN YOU GET INTO
THE LEGAL WEEDS OF EVERYTHING
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU GET INTO.
PROVING SOMETHING IN A COURT OF
LAW WITH STRICT EVIDENCE. THE
THERE'S NO WAY TO ACTUALLY
PROVE THAT THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER IN HIS OWN MIND DIDN'T
BELIEVE. THAT WHAT HE WAS DOING
IT RIGHT NOW SO- DANCER AGAIN
LIE SOMEWHERE IN THE MIDDLE.
AND THIS INVOLVES A LONG
DISCUSSION. ABOUT WHERE IT IS
AND HOW TO FIND. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR BONTA. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP- MISTER CHAIR
AND REALLY PLEASED TO BE ON ON
THIS ON THIS COMMITTEE AND I
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION
TODAY AND I HAVEN'T SOMETHING
THAT THAT YOU SAID MATTEO
STRUCK ME I WANT TO FOLLOW UP
ON IT AND BECAUSE I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT AND IT WAS YOUR
STATEMENT ABOUT THOSE CLOSEST
TO THE PROBLEM. OUR BEST
LOCATED TO PROVIDE SOLUTIONS
AND THAT ARE THE IMPORTANCE OF
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES AND THE
PARTNERSHIP INTEGRATION
SOLUTIONS BETWEEN POLICY MAKERS
IN IMPACTED COMMUNITIES SOMEONE
ASK YOU TWO QUESTIONS THE FIRST
IS. WHAT WOULD BE YOUR TOP
PRIORITY POLICY CHANGE I KNOW
THERE'S MANY THINGS THAT WE CAN
DO O HELP. FIX THE SYSTEM- IN
NEED OF REFORM. BUT IF YOU
PRIORITIZE THEM WITH WITH
WEIGHT WHAT WOULD BE YOUR TOP
PRIORITY AND THEN I WANT TO. IT
MAYBE COMMENT ON THE QUESTION
OF. HOW DO YOU WEIGH AND
DISCERN BETWEEN. INVESTMENTS IN
TRAINING. ON THE ONE HAND AND
IN EDUCATION AND WHO COMES INTO
THE WORK FORCE AS LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. AND
POLICY CHANGE. THANK YOU SO.
IT'S KIND OF HARD TO SAY LIKE
WHICH WHAT I WOULD PRIORITIZE
BUT I KNOW THAT- IT
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD
ACROSS THE STATE WITH LEADERS-
RECOGNIZING THAT ON PEOPLE OF
COLOR ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED THAT BLACK AND BLACK
BLACK AND BROWN BODIES ARE
BEING KILLED IN THE STATE- AT
ALARMING RATES AND- IN THAT IT.
A LOT OF OUR FOLKS DON'T
NECESSARILY FEEL LIKE THEY CAN
TRUST LAW ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE
THEY BELIEVE. THEY ARE THEIR
PERSONAL BIAS AND INTERNAL
RACISM IS WHAT'S ACTUALLY
DRIVING SOME OF THESE DECISION
MAKING- IN PART OF THAT IS WHEN
WE SEE THAT- SOMEONE THAT DOES
THE MASS SHOOTING CAN BE
ARRESTED PEACEFULLY RIGHT. AND
SOMEONE DOES HAVING A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS IT JUST GETS
KILLED RIGHT- SO DEFINITELY
DENOUNCING- INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE TIGHTS DIRECT TIES PUBLIC
TIES TO RACIST ORGANIZATIONS
IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE THAT
GETS TO THE- ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
THAT WE HAVE TO STAY WILL NOT
TOLERATE ANYBODY SERVING OUR
COMMUNITIES. WHO HAS TIED TO
RACES ORGANIZATIONS BECAUSE
THERE'S NO WAY YOU CAN PROVE
THAT. YOU KNOW IF I'M A PART OF
THE KKK I SHOULD NOT BE YOU
KNOW THAT MEANS THAT I NEED
THAT SAYS A LOT ABOUT WHERE I
SEE. YOU KNOW WHERE I STAND IN
THE IN THE WORLD AND YOU
SHOULDN'T BE POLICING PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN OUR STATE. I JUST IT'S
IMMORAL IT'S SOME IT'S A MORAL
CONTRADICTION. TO SAY YOU CAN
BE A GANG MEMBER AND JOINED THE
POLICE FORCE RIGHT BE HAVE BEEN
A FORMER MEMBER GANG MEMBER THE
KKK IS. A GANG AFFILIATED
ORGANIZATION AND SO NOT BEING
ABLE TO DISTINGUISH BETWEEN
THOSE TWO. LIKE THAT TO ME IS
SUPER IMPORTANT IN TOP PRIORITY
BECAUSE I RECOGNIZE THAT. WE AT
THE STATE. ARE NOT GOING TO BE
TOLERATING ANY KIND OF RACIST
TIGHTS TO ANY ORGANIZATION.
INTERPRETER LEFT YOUR SECOND
QUESTION. THE SECOND ONE WAS WE
THERE'S A CALMER A GOOD REALLY
GOOD CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
NEED TO INVEST IN THAT THE
CHANGE THAT WE WANT AND DOING
THAT WITH TRAINING- LOOKING AT
FOLKS- AS AS POSSIBLE WHO
LOOKING FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
CAREER WITH COLLEGE DEGREES
GRADUATE DEGREES DIFFERENT
TYPES OF- OF- EXPERTISE-
MEDICINE- LAW IT SAID DR. HOW
FOR ANYTHING THAT IS FIRST IS
JUST REALLY CHANGES IN POLICIES
THAT SOME OF THE POLICIES THAT-
IS GOMEZ REYES WAS TALKING
ABOUT THAT WE PROPOSE HERE AND
LEGISLATURE LIKE THE BRADY LIST
LIKE THE DECERTIFICATION LIKE
THE DUTY TO INTERVENE QUALIFIED.
ENEMY IMMUNITY. M. AND MAYBE
THEY'RE JUST DIFFERENT TRACKS
IN THE BOTH IMPORT. BUT YEAH I
THINK BOTH A DEFINITELY THEY'RE
BOTH IMPORTANT IT'S FUNNY I WAS
LIKE WRITING NO TEST AT MY
COLLEAGUES SHERRI- BUT I WOULD
SAY THAT. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I WHEN I THINK A LOT OF
THE CONVERSATIONS OVER HERE
IT'S AROUND LIKE ALL THE THINGS
ARE ON OFFICERS PLATE RIGHT
LIKE. ARE THEY THEY ARE NOT IN
MY OPINION IN MY PERSONAL
OPINION THEY'RE NOT THE RIGHT
PERSON TO GOAL. ADDRESSED A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS CALL SO
THAT MEANS THAT THEN YOU KNOW.
YEAH THEY SHOULD HAVE TRAINING
WHEN THEY DO ENCOUNTER THAT BUT
LIKE HOW DO WE HAVE SYSTEMS IN
PLACE AND PEOPLE THAT ARE
SPECIALIZED IN THAT THAT THEY
ARE THE ONES THAT ARE. YOU KNOW
ARE GETTING THE FUNDING DOES
ORGANIZATION SHOULD BE GETTING
THE FUNDING TO RESPOND TO THIS
KIND OF CRISES- LIKE TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT BELONG IN OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. NO THEY'RE NOT
AT EVERY SCHOOL HARPERHATED
SO- BUT- YES I WOULD SAY THAT
THEY'RE THEY'RE BOTH-
DEFINITELY IMPORTANT RIGHT THE
EDUCATION PIECE AND ALSO LIKE
REALLY DISCERNING- WHERE
WORKING ADDITIONAL FUNDING GOAL
TO ORGANIZATIONS. THAT ARE ON
THE GROUND THAT ARE DOING THE
WORK. BRITISH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO THANK OUR- WE WANT TO
MOVE QUICKLY TO THE PUBLIC
COMMENT SECTIONS THAT WILL
HAVE- OUR OPERATOR QUEUE UP WE
WANT TO ASK THOSE WHO ARE IN
THE AUDIENCE WHO PLEASE PREPARE
YOURSELF TO COME TO THE
MICROPHONE. BEHIND THE
PLEXIGLAS PLEASE DON'T TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE AND YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES BUT PRIOR TO THAT WE
HAVE THIRTY SECONDS FOR MR
MCCARTY TO MAKE A COMMENT YEAH.
WELL FIRST I WANT TO THANK MY
TO SACRAMENTO CONSTITUENTS FOR
BEING PART OF THE PANEL. AND I
KNOW WE'RE NOT LAWMAKING TODAY
BUT JUST WANTED TO PINE BRIEFLY
ON THIS THIS QUALIFIED IMMUNITY
ISSUE THAT YOU BROUGHT UP- IT
REALLY IS MANIFESTED HERE
THROUGH THIS THROUGH OUR TOM
PAINES CIVIL RIGHTS ACT WHICH
WAS BRIEFLY DEBATED IN THAT.
DECERTIFICATION ISSUE WILL COME
BACK AGAIN NEXT YEAR BUT I
THINK IN REALITY THERE IS A
MIDDLE GROUND BECAUSE WE ASK
ANY PLAINTIFFS ATTORNEY AND MY
ATTORNEY COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE
DIETS TO REALIZE THAT. THE DEEP
POCKETS IS NOT THE POLICE
OFFICER AND HIS HOUSE OR HIS
PENSION IT'S THE JURISDICTION
THE CITY. AND IN MY VIEW IF
CITIES WERE MORE ON THE HOOK
FOR WRONGFUL DEATH EXCESSIVE
FORCE USE OF FORCE. THEY WOULD
HAVE THEIR POLICE DEPARTMENT
THEY'RE CHEAP THEY'RE
LIEUTNANTS OR CAPTAINS MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE POLICING AND
A MORE JUST WAY IN THE
COMMUNTIES SO WE HAVE AN
ARBITRARY- POLICY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO IN CALIFORNIA.
THROUGH THE APPLICATION BECAUSE
OF COURT RULINGS THROUGH THIS-
DANA AXLES I THINK THERE IS A
MIDDLE GROUND IN ADDITION THERE
IS ONE STATE RECENTLYTHAT DID
OF A QUALIFIED IMMUNITY
ADJUSTMENT. AND THEY PUT A CAP
ON HOW MUCH OFFICER THINKING
LIKE THE GEORGE PLAYED OFFICER
OFFICER JOB AND WHATEVER HIS
NAME IS. A MONETARY AMOUNT
WHICH IS NOT UNREASONABLE FROM
THE OFFICER'S PERSPECTIVE SO I
DO THINK THERE'S A WAY TO
ACHIEVE WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
AND NOT MAKE SO NO OFFICERS
WHATEVER WANT THE JOB BUT HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY. FOR ACTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY VERY
MUCH MISTER MODERATOR- IF YOU
CAN PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE ON
THE LINE. I REALIZE THAT PEOPLE
HAVE ALL IN ALL PUT ME
MODERATOR WILL TO GO TO YOU TO.
RELEASE THE FOR PEOPLE TO FROM
THE TO COME AT THIS TIME.
PALLADIA IF YOU TO MAKE A
COMMENT. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO ASK A
QUESTION. PLEASE PRESS ONE TWO
ZERO NOW. IN ONE MOMENT THE
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHY NUMBER SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU THIS IS LARRY ORTEGA WITH
COMMUNITY UNION I'VE BEEN IN
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE ADVOCACY
BUSINESS SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
THREE AND OVER THE LAST DECADE
WE BROUGHT TO AWARENESS TO WHAT
BROADBAND CAN DO. TO OVER
THIRTY MILLION PEOPLE I DO NOT
APPRECIATE THE NARRATIVE THAT
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE HAS COME
UPON US LIKE SOME SYNONYMY OR
SOME KIND OF HURRICANE. SO
WHAT'S MISTER B. INDUSTRIES
MIXER I THINK THAT'S THE WRONG
HEARING THIS IS THE PLEASE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON POLICE
OFFICER FOR. MODERATED YOU CAN
QUEUE UP THE NEXT PERSON. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WANT TO ADD TO
MAKE A STATEMENT ON POLICE
REFORM PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ONE AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO TO MAKE A STATEMENT
ON POLICE REFORM. HERE WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT THE
MOMENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
HAVE IN HERE WHEN THE AUDIENCE
WHO WISH TO MAKE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENTS. HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. GREAT WELL LET ME SIMPLY
SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
VERY ROBUST CONVERSATION I ALSO
WANNA THANK MY COLLEAGUES- FOR
BEING HERE ON THE SELECT
COMMITTEE BECAUSE OF COVERT
NINETEEN ALL THE MEMBERS WERE
NOT ABLE TO JOIN US TODAY I
WANT TO UNDERSCORE THAT THIS IS
THE FIRST- IN MANY OF MANY
HEARINGS- THAT THIS COMMITTEE
WILL UNDERTAKEN CERTAINLY
DISCUSSIONS AND ALSO- INPUT IS
WELCOME- FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND ALSO OTHER. PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY SO PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO SHARE SOME OF YOUR THOUGHTS
IN TERMS OF TOPICS AND THINGS
OF THAT NATURE AGAIN WHAT I
CONTAINS TWO HERE IS ISSUES
AROUND THE CERTIFICATION I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
MANY PEOPLE ON THIS COMMITTEE
AND THOSE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
AS WELL AS THE MEANING OF THE
FUNDING- I THINK WE'RE GOING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION WILL NOT BE
WINDOW SHOPPING WE'RE GOING TO
MAKE SOME CONCRETE- HERE SOME
CONCRETE ISSUES AND TRYING TO
TACKLE SOME VERYDIFFICULT-
SUBJECT MATTERS TO ADDRESS AND
TO TACKLE. SO WITH THAT I THINK
THAT WE'RE ALL COMPLETE I WANNA
SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO OUR
PANELISTS MISTER HARRISON ALSO
MYSTERY TRAIL WOULD BEING HERE
WE REALLY ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON PLEASE I WAS REFERRED.
REFORM STANDS ADJOURNED.